Tja, ich code die ganze Nacht, aber ich habe die Kraft der zwei Dongles. Das neue MacBook Pro. Die Kraft der zwei Dongles.
Bis dann, tschüss! Das war ja das kürzeste Intro dieses Jahrtausends.
Ja, man möchte.
Naja, die Zeiten werden härter.
Der Engel muss, der Gürtel muss enger geschneit werden. Der Engel muss gürter geschneit werden?
Ja, der Engel muss kürzer geschneit werden. Ja, man bekommt den Eindruck, dass nichts passiert in der letzten Sendung.
Es könnte sein, ja. Man weiß es nicht. Gucken wir mal, wie es in dieser Sendung ist. Und diese Sendung ist die Freak Show, und zwar die 186. Ausgabe live aus der Mieter Ebene.
Wie immer im Studio begrüßen wir...
Dennis?
Zu meiner Geradeaus. Und dann hier zu meiner Linken begrüßen wir unseren Gast, den hatten wir auch schon mal, den Pavel M aus B.
Hallo Pavel.
Und hier zu meiner Rechten haben wir den Timmel P aus B. Ne, aus H.
Doch. Genau, also Timmel, Roddy, Dennis und Pavel.
Und mich natürlich, genau.
Ja, genau, Dennis ist dabei.
Und wir grüßen wie immer unsere Hörer in der Schweiz und in Österreich.
Und wir grüßen natürlich Clemens, der nicht da sein kann, Huckel, der nicht da sein kann und Letty, die auch nicht da sein kann. Und ja, ist irgendwas passiert?
Erstaunlich wenig.
War was? Tja, achso, wer irgendwie keinen Bock auf Apple-Themen hat, in der Freak Show, kann gleich abschalten.
Ist sonst nichts passiert?
Achso, du willst auch noch neue Batterien haben?
Ich will auch noch neue Batterien haben.
Ihr seht, wie in jeder Sendung, wir sind ordentlich vorbereitet.
Klar, diesmal sind wir sogar ganz gut vorbereitet.
Auch im Chat freuen sich die Schweizer, dass sie gegrüßt wurden.
Ha!
In diesem Sinne.
Richtig so. Hallo Schweizer. So, jetzt kriegst du noch Batterien. Kommen wir ja auch langsam im Flow. Ja, Pavel, gratuliere erst mal zu deinem Karriereende.
Ja, sozusagen.
Warte mal, du musst mal dein Mikrofon noch so ein bisschen...
Ja, ja, geht's besser. So, jetzt hört man mich.
Naja, das Ding zeigt an die Decke. Es muss halt, nicht so, sondern den ganzen Schwan halt so ein bisschen so...
Hört man mich jetzt besser?
Wir üben schon mal für die Beschreibung dessen, was alles noch so ansteht. Genau, ja, du bist jetzt raus.
Ja, ja, ich bin jetzt ehemaliger Abgeordneter. So und seit einer Woche, seit sich das neue Parlament konstituiert hat, ist jetzt fast endgültig vorbei, bis auf weiteres.
Bis auf weiteres. Genau, wer die letzte Sendung mit dir nicht gehört hat, vielleicht nochmal zur Erklärung. Du warst ja jetzt fünf Jahre Abgeordneter im Abgeordnetenhaus in Berlin. Ja, und das Wasser mit den 15 Piraten waren ja dann sowieso nur noch 14?
Naja, ich würde das Thema bitte nicht aufspannen wollen. Obwohl es da jede Menge widerliche Details zugibt, die nicht öffentlich bekannt sind, aber das lassen wir mal.
Nee, nee, das wollen wir jetzt hier überhaupt nicht ausbreiten. Darum ging es mir auch gar nicht. Es war dann mehr so dieses, wie war denn das so?
Geil. Es war schon, also ich möchte auf gar keinen Fall müssen so die Einblicke so zu wissen, wie das wirklich funktioniert, wie das aussieht, die ganzen Geheimnisse, die ich erfahren dürfte. Also kann ich jedem nur raten, irgendwie mal fünf Jahre als Abgeordneter am besten in einem Teilzeitparlament, dann kann man nebenher auch noch was anderes machen, so also Berlin, Hamburg oder Bremen bieten sich da an. Ja, weil Stadtstaat, da kann man mal eben von der Arbeit, also von der richtigen Arbeit, dann eben seine Tätigkeit als Abgeordneter wahrnehmen und dann wieder weiter arbeiten. So ist das gedacht.
Aber das ist doch total unrealistisch, oder nicht?
Ja, also die wenigsten machen das so, aber ich würde sagen so ein Drittel machen das wirklich in Teilzeit. Der Rest macht halt Vollzeit für halbes Geld.
Klingt ja sehr attraktiv.
Ja, also reich werden kann man damit nicht. Und es ist auch nicht mehr so, wie das früher war, mit Lobbyisten und Einladungen und Bestechungsversuchen. Das ist nicht mehr. Oder Privilegien gibt es auch nicht, sondern im Gegenteil. Man muss halt höllisch aufpassen, sich in Acht nehmen, dass man nichts tut, was dann am nächsten Tag in der Zeitung steht. Und jetzt kann ich wieder die Sau rauslassen.
Bist du genau im richtigen Ort.
Expirat hat große Buchstaben am nächsten Tag.
Provoziert Skandal in Podcasts.
Aber toppen kannst du es eh nicht mehr.
Wir hatten vor einiger Zeit miteinander gesprochen und da meintest du so, naja ich komm mal wieder vorbei, wenn es was zu MacBooks zu erzählen gibt. Das ist jetzt soweit.
Also mindestens ein Jahr habe ich auf diese scheiß Dinger gewartet.
Seit Anfang des Jahres, oder?
Ja, eigentlich seit Anfang des Jahres. Ich hatte auch noch ein Budget.
Im Sinne von, du hast damit gerechnet, dass sie im Prinzip jetzt mal rauskommt?
Ja, genau. Ich hatte eigentlich so mit Februar oder so gerechnet und hätte dann sogar noch welche für mein Büro beschaffen, für mein Abgeordnetenbüro beschaffen können. So habe ich jetzt noch, dadurch weil die nicht gekommen sind, habe ich jetzt irgendwie viereinhalbtausend Euro an Budget, die ich noch hatte, verfallen lassen. Die kommen jetzt der Staatskasse zugute, weil ich wollte ja eigentlich irgendeinen Quatsch kaufen. Ich hätte halt sonst noch Bedarf gehabt, aber da war halt nichts. So mussten dann halt meine Mitarbeiter teilweise mit fünf oder sieben Jahre alten Macs weiterarbeiten.
Wer hätte das alte Modell kaufen können?
Ich meine, das stand überall auf rot. Nicht mehr kaufen seit einem Jahr ungefähr.
Nur weil überhaupt gar keine Updates rausgekommen sind.
Das Problem war, ich wollte eigentlich nix mit ATI-Grafik. Normalerweise hatte ich das Gefühl, bei den Pros war es bisher immer so, dass die abwechselnd eine Grafik von ATI und Nvidia genommen haben. So grob bei den MacBook Pros. Ich habe jetzt gerade hier noch das vorletzte Modell, also mit 2014 habe ich das, das hat eine Nvidia-Grafik. Das nächste Modell hatte eine ATI-Grafik und ich hatte jetzt gehofft, dass die neuen jetzt auch wieder eine Nvidia-Grafik haben würden, aber ist halt leider nicht. Das war so ein Ding oder ein Grund für mich, warum ich halt die letzten Modelle nicht habe.
Aber die Frage ist, warum Nvidia?
Naja, ich mache ja eine ganze Menge so Machine Learning, Deep Learning Geschichten und da ist halt einfach CUDA der De facto-Standard.
Warum nicht OpenCL? Also ist das cool, sich auf deren spezifisches Papi da zu schmeißen?
Es ist halt einfach so, dass die populärsten Systeme, die halt aus der Forschung kommen, ist halt alles CUDA, weil auch das dort am besten funktioniert. Typischerweise so Machine Learning, wenn man halt tiefe neuronale Netze nimmt, das macht man halt auf Desktop-Rechner, wo man dann 4 oder 8 Nvidia Titan X mit je 12 GB RAM und 7 oder 11 Teraflops hat. Genau, das ist halt in dem Bereich im Moment einfach der Standard und das wäre halt ganz schön gewesen. Man muss es nicht haben, aber es wäre halt ganz schön gewesen, wenn...
Heißt das, dass nur Nvidia derzeit überhaupt diese Performance bringt oder haben die sich nur so gut verbreitet, dass jetzt CUDA da der Standard ist, deswegen kaufen auch alle Nvidia auch, wenn man im Prinzip was anderes kaufen könnte?
Also Nvidia macht da einfach am meisten, auch die bieten am meisten, die kümmern sich am meisten, die haben halt entsprechende Libraries, auch für Deep Learning und so, das ganze Umfeld und Infrastruktur und von Embedded halt bis von Embedded-Systemen bis eben zu den ganz fetten Kisten ist alles Nvidia. Also Arti spielt beim im Bereich Deep Learning eigentlich keine Rolle.
Ist ja ein bisschen komisch, weil zu Bitcoin-Zeiten, auch 2011, 2012 dann schon nicht mehr so richtig, glaube ich, da war ja schon vorbei, aber 2011 war es so, dass die AMD-Karten Bitcoin-mäßig einfach gerockt haben und bei Nvidia das war nicht nur so ein bisschen schlechter, sondern das war einfach überhaupt gar nicht zu benutzen. Die waren um den Faktor 20 oder 50 langsamer, weil die waren da, glaube ich, damals bei Floating-Point-Performance ziemlich vorne, Nvidia. Und für Bitcoin braucht es aber keinen Floating-Point und da hat AMD halt total gerockt und Nvidia lief unter Ferner, liefen so. Und dann hat sich das ja aber jetzt irgendwie vor ein, zwei Jahren oder so umgedreht, ne?
Wie gesagt, im Machine Learning, so mit neuronalen Netzen, braucht man halt Fließkommazahlen, die müssen nicht genau sein. Also reicht sogar für die meisten Anwendungen halbe Genauigkeit. Also mit 16 oder sogar mit 8 Bit Fließkommazahlen reicht für die meisten Dinger aus. Nur schnell muss es halt sein. Und da hat halt Nvidia mit den Titan-Karten einfach den Vogel abgeschossen. Achso, und du brauchst halt viel Speicher. Kannst halt auch nicht, also auch, je mehr, desto besser, weil diese Netze sind halt ziemlich groß. Aber gut, wie gesagt, es ist halt ein so ein Aspekt, dass halt leider eben Apple offensichtlich, was die Notebooks angeht, jetzt mit den neuen Geräten da, leider aufs, meine ich, aufs falsche Pferd gesetzt hat, wobei...
Aber eigentlich haben sie ja schon damals den richtigen Move gemacht. Also da gab es ja Steam von AMD, oder ist das Stream? Und von NVIDIA CUDA. Und dann hat Apple gesagt, ne, wir wollen irgendwie nicht hier für zwei verschiedene Plattformen irgendwie, Apis und so weiter, setzt euch mal einen Tisch und macht mal hier OpenCL. Und dann gab es ja OpenCL. Und das ist ja eigentlich eine gute Sache. So wenn die Leute jetzt anfangen, NVIDIA gerade besser performt, irgendwie CUDA zu machen, das heißt, selbst wenn jetzt von AMD die super Karte kommt, kann man gar nicht umschwenken, weil es nicht geht. Das ist eigentlich ein bisschen scheiße.
Ja, also es ist so, dass natürlich die ganze Software auch auf der CPU läuft. Und man auch sagen muss wiederum, was der Vorteil ist. Apple hat halt hardwarebeschleunigte Blast-Routinen, wo halt die Grafik auch mitrechnet. Das heißt, du kannst diesen ganzen Kram auch mit Matrizen-Multiplikation, mit Blast machen. Und das heißt, auch die Arti-Grafik beschleunigt dann die Software. Aber nicht halt in dem Maße. Und OpenCL ist einfach deutlich langsamer und leider nicht so ausgereift. Und Apple hat dann ja auch noch damit mit Metal, hat auch noch ihr eigenes Süppchen.
Aber kann man mit Metal auch andere Sachen machen als Grafik?
Soll ich auch berechnen? Also es ist letztlich ist Metal genau dasselbe wie im Prinzip Shadersprache, also auch wie CUDA oder OpenCL.
Aber Metal ist doch jetzt noch mehr als nur eine Shadersprache. Ich meine, das ist ja auch das API, mit dem man überhaupt mit der Grafikkarte redet und hat ja OpenGL abgelöst.
Ist alles dasselbe in grün, gelb oder blau. Also unterscheidet sich nicht wirklich jetzt.
Wie heißt nochmal dieser neue Standard, den jetzt dieses Vulkan, was eigentlich alle anderen außer Apple jetzt machen? Ist das irgendwie ein nennenswerter Unterschied? Sind das nur Details? Ist da konzeptionell irgendwas anders?
Also gefühlt hat sich da seit zehn Jahren nichts, nicht viel verändert. So bei der Architektur der Karten, die es kommt.
Bei der API hat sich natürlich was verändert, weil die Abstraktion noch eine andere ist als jetzt mit OpenG.
Nicht wirklich. Aber eigentlich selbst die Metal-Geschichten und so. Letztlich hast du überall dieselbe Art von Hardware drin. Du hast kleine Unterschiede in den verschiedenen Sprachen. Wie du das mit normalem Code dann mischt, wie die CPU mit der Grafik miteinander redet. Aber im Prinzip sind das alles noch Grafikkarten. Man merkt, wo es herkommt. Von der Struktur her sind es immer noch Vertex-Shader und Fragment-Shader. Nur, dass die jetzt alle frei programmierbar sind. Aber du musst auch, selbst wenn du Berechnungen machst, hast du halt Kacheln und hast da halt die Parallelität. Da ist da zwei Arten von Parallelität drin, um die du dich kümmern musst. Und Synchronisation und so. Also, ja, das ist eigentlich, ist halt kein Universal-Rechner und ist halt nach wie vor dazu da, um Pixel einzufärben. Auch wenn du, da siehst du halt auch an den ganzen Registern, die du hast. Du hast halt 4x4-Matrizen und Vektoren mit maximal vier Komponenten. Und also all der ganze Kram auch bei jetzt, wenn du Computations machst, fühlt sich das trotzdem an wie eine Grafikkarte.
Na gut, dass die Grafikkarte sich noch wie eine Grafikkarte anfasst, das anfühlt es mir schon klar. Ich hatte nur so den Eindruck, dass mit Metal und Vulkan, also mit dieser neuen Generation von APIs, die jetzt OpenGL entwickelt, dass halt da der Einstiegspunkt etwas nach unten verschoben wurde, dass man quasi näher am Metall ist sozusagen, hands to the name, und damit, wie soll ich sagen, eine zuverlässigere Auslastung erzielen kann, weil man nicht über Annahmen schläupert, die dann nicht zur Hardware passen.
Also die Treiber sind dünner und dümmer geworden, so das heißt, du programmierst tatsächlich ein bisschen näher am Metall, aber das ist nicht unbedingt bequemer. Nur schneller.
Aber es ist ja dann so, dass man jetzt in den meisten Fällen auf irgendwelche Engines aufsetzt, die diesen Abstraktionspart dann quasi übernehmen. Das heißt, letztlich ist es für die Apps einfacher geworden, nur dass die Subsysteme, die sie benutzen, jetzt besser auf die Hardware optimieren können.
Ja, es ist eigentlich schwieriger geworden. Du kannst sie halt mehr nutzen, musst aber mehr selber um die Speicherverwaltung kümmern.
Ja gut, aber das nehmen ja mir quasi die Subsysteme ab. Das heißt, in dem Moment, wo ich so eine Game Engine benutze oder irgendein anderes 3D-Subsystem.
Ja, oder beispielsweise Cafe als das Äquivalent im Bereich Deep Learning zu so einer Engine.
Das stellt halt den Glue bereit, um irgendwie mit dieser Hardware zu reden und man selber ist zwei Etagen darüber und pelst sich da ein Ei drauf.
Genau, man sagt dann nur, also bei Cafe zum Beispiel, gibt es halt eine CPU, also typischerweise eine CPU, eine GPU-Variante, wobei die GPU-Varianten fast alle cooler sind. So, also wenn du halt...
CUDA sind, nicht CUDA sind.
Nee, CUDA, schneller.
Schneller durch CUDA, CUDA durch CUDA.
Ja, wenn du halt, sonst musst du dir halt das Ganze... Man kann es auch, es gibt auch verschiedene Compiler, wo du halt CUDA in OpenCL von alleine kompilieren kannst und so, aber eigentlich willst du dich um diesen ganzen Hessell nicht wirklich kümmern. Also ich hätte mich sehr darüber gefreut, wenn die neuen MacBooks eine aktuelle Nvidia-Grafik drin gehabt hätten, zumal die auch ganz, ja es ist da auch jetzt ganz ordentliche Mobile-Grafiken gäbe.
Und es ist jetzt sehr speziell aus Deep Learning Aspekten betrachtet, wenn man jetzt das mal weglässt und mir so grafikmäßig geht, ist denn das, was die da verbaut haben, das ist ja hier die AMD, wie heißt die genau? 460, X460, Mobile 460 oder wie heißt die? Ich weiß gar nicht.
Es gibt drei Varianten.
450, 455 und wenn man mal extra zahlt, gibt es eine 460. Und die beiden größeren davon haben auch 4GB anstatt 2GB, die 450 hat, glaube ich, nur 2GB. Und sind die denn schlecht? Sind die mittelmaß, oberes, oberes, unteres mittelmaß? Also Highend verbaut ja Apple sowieso nie?
Ja, die sind, die sollen, ich meine ich habe es jetzt selber noch nicht auf dem Tisch gehabt, aber was man hört, ist die Grafik-Performance ganz okay. Es ist schon eine relativ moderne Karte, halt diese 460 irgendwie mit 14 Nanometer Prozess und auch relativ energieeffizient bringt.
Gibt es noch keine Benchmarks?
Nur halt, wie gesagt, so ein paar technische Daten, also die verbraucht halt irgendwie 35 Watt maximal, also Peak und schafft halt irgendwie 1,86 Teraflops. Das ist, also wenn man es mal vergleicht, also jetzt eine Nvidia GTX 1060 zum Beispiel.
Auch mobile, ja?
So auch mobile, allerdings verbraucht halt also bis zu 75 Watt Peak, ist aber auch doppelt so schnell wie jetzt, ja die jetzt in den neuen Mix drin ist. Die Pro 460.
Naja, das ist ja immer so ein Abwägen. Ich würde sagen, wir fangen vielleicht trotzdem mal ein bisschen vorne an, bevor wir uns jetzt hierzu sehr in Details vertiefen, aber wir können das ja gerne noch mal aufgreifen. Quatsch mal überhaupt erstmal über diesen Event, also wer da immer noch keine Ahnung hat, wovon wir reden, es gab mal wieder so einen von diesen glamourösen Apple Keynotes, letzte Woche, wo halt... Du weißt doch, Podcast, das Format, in dem man sogar die Ironie rauslesen kann, ohne sie. Ja, ne, sonderlich glamourös war es jetzt auch nicht. Ich meine, das fand ja dann auch in diesem kleinen, wie hieß dieser Ort, Townhall, was auch immer das ist.
Zum letzten Mal wahrscheinlich.
Ja, demnächst gehen sie dann... Mal wieder letzten Mal. Auf jeden Fall haben sie da ihre Klacköre zusammengefegt und mal versucht so ein bisschen mal wieder so zu tun, als wäre jetzt schon wieder die dritte neue Erleuchtung des Macintosh so nach Geburt. Und dann haben sie das zweite gemacht. Das ist der Hello Again, war das der iMac?
Das war der iMac, der erste Knobbel-iMac.
Und da dachte ich mir auch schon so, hm, okay, wenn sie jetzt schon so dick auftrumpfen, vielleicht...
Dann kommt wirklich was unerwartetes.
Vielleicht ist das jetzt so wirklich die Antwort auf dieses schon seit Monaten und Jahren in den Luft hängenden Dingen mit macht ja eigentlich überhaupt noch irgendwas an diesen Dingern. Sollen wir jetzt auf Windows umsteigen oder was? Also es war ja einfach und ist auch immer noch ja ein wenig dramatisch. Mich persönlich muss ja sagen, hat dieses MacBook Pro Dilemma einfach nicht so betroffen. Weil ich einfach, ich weiß gar nicht seit wann ich schon kein Pro-Modell mehr habe. Hatt ich denn überhaupt, hatte ich überhaupt ein MacBook Pro jemals? Ich weiß es gar nicht jetzt.
Was hast du denn vorher, musst du das wissen?
Ich hatte bestimmt ein, naja sag das mal nicht.
Oder hattest du, weißt du, iBooks und so ein Zeug?
MacBooks, ja. Ich hatte so ein schwarzes MacBook hatte ich. Und ich weiß gar nicht, habe ich mir überhaupt irgendwann noch mal ein MacBook Pro gekauft?
Ich glaube nicht.
Ich kann mich dran erinnern.
Kannst ja gar nicht mitreden.
Dann bist du auch gar nicht Zielgruppe hier jetzt.
Nee, mein ich ja gerade. Also ich bin halt nicht so die Zielgruppe gewesen, was auch damit zu tun hat, dass ich halt einfach mal wieder so den Desktop für mich erschlossen habe. Und mit so meinem alten Mac Pro und dann auch mal so mit meinem 2i Mac hatte ich so an Performance und Bildschirm und groß und macht, was ich brauche, wenn es mal hart kommt. Hatt ich halt einfach nicht mehr diesen Bedarf wie früher, so ein 5 Kilo Teil durch die Gegend zu schleppen und hatte einfach nur noch das Bedürfnis nach Kompakt. Und da war natürlich erst mal dieses schwarze MacBook geil und dann halt das R. Und das R war wirklich, ich glaube ich hatte da auch noch mal so ein MacBook Pro, aber ich kann mich da schon nicht mehr dran erinnern. Ja, aber jetzt habe ich ja schon seit es das geile R gibt, seitdem es dieses keilförmige R gibt, habe ich halt R. Und finde das auch immer noch am geilsten. Hat jetzt auch dieser Event ehrlich gesagt nicht so viel dran. Nur so ein bisschen vielleicht was dran. Na ja, auf jeden Fall sind sie da, fand ich doch ziemlich unter Druck geraten. Und das merkte man, glaube ich, auch an den Reaktionen, die dieser ganze Event ausgerufen hat. Da hat sich doch schon eine ganze Menge aufgestauter Ärger entladen. Und je nachdem, ob denn jetzt nun endlich das gekommen ist, was alle haben wollten oder eben genau das Gegenteil passiert ist, wurde es dann halt etwas wüster in die eine oder andere Richtung. Und ich war, na ja, ich war am Anfang war ich eigentlich überhaupt nicht begeistert. Das hatte im Wesentlichen damit zu tun, dass diese Show nach einer 1,5 Stunde vorbei war. Und ich saß da so und dachte mir so, wo ist mein Er? Also das war ja schon gestorben zu dem Zeitpunkt.
Was ich an dieser Show so absurd fand, war so, ja das ist jetzt ein Mac-Event, das ist jetzt ein Mac-Event und dann kommen sie mit Apple TV und zeigen irgendwelches Amisports mit irgendwelchen idiotischen Tweets dabei. Und da denkst du dir so, Leute, wenn ihr ordentliche Macs vorstellen wollt, was... Diese Apple TV App da, die irgendwie... Da dachte ich mir, also wenn ihr jetzt mal ordentlich Mac-mäßig auf die Tube drücken wollt, was vergeutet ihr Zeit mit so einer Scheiße? Das ist doch, ich dachte, es ist ein Mac-Event, weißt du. Da ist bei mir schon, als es mit dem Apple TV lief und lief und lief, ist die Laune schon runtergegangen. Und ich dachte so, das will keiner wissen, macht das weg.
Aber es gibt auch Minecraft jetzt bald und man kann noch einfacher Fernsehen gucken. Und ja, ich meine, dieses Apple TV ist sowieso auch ganz merkwürdig. Also das teuerste Gerät auf dem Markt und...
Ich hätte auch keins, wenn ich es nicht irgendwie als Developer fast geschenkt bekomme. Sondern weil es ist auch so sinnlos.
Ja, es hat auch auf mich bisher keinerlei nennenswerte Attraktivität ausgestrahlt. Also es ist ganz praktisch, wenn man eins hat, so einfach um einen Bildschirm drauf zu kriegen. Aber das ging auch schon vorher und da brauchen wir jetzt das heute nicht.
Es ist nett, wenn man eins hat, aber ich könnte auch leicht ohne. Besonders zu dem Preis könnte ich auch sehr leicht ohne.
Ja, dann hab ich das erst mal geschluckt, als sie dann kam mit Apple Pay.
Ja, aber auch der Zug ging vorüber, ohne anzuhalten.
Na direkt nach Japan durch. Da war ich dann auch sehr glücklich für die Japaner, dass sie jetzt ihre Verkehrs-Routing haben und dass sie auch überall mit Apple Pay bezahlen können. Denkst ja halt auch so, Entwicklungsland Deutschland. Sind wir da jetzt auch schon auf Platz 27 wie beim Glasfaserausbau? Ich kann es mir fast vorstellen. Ich habe so in letzter Zeit ein bisschen darüber nachgedacht.
Wir waren doch mal ein Land der Infrastruktur. Ja, das ist vorbei, oder?
Ja, das ist noch nicht.
Scheiß Wände kamen zu früh.
Als nächstes machen sie die Autobahnen zu und dann gibt es auch kein Wasser mehr.
Auto ist ja das Einzige, was dieses Land kann, aber seit Auto ist halt irgendwie nichts mehr passiert. Das ist schon eine Schande für ein Land, das irgendwie einen Computer erfunden hat. Die geben sich ja noch nicht mal Mühe, alle anderen wissen zu lassen, dass der Computer hier... Frag mal einen Amerikaner, wo der Computer erfunden wurde. Glaubst du, der sagt Deutschland? Weiß keiner. Zu so kennt auch niemand.
Na ja, gut, beim Telefon und bei der Glühbirne ist man sich da auch nicht einig. Einig?
So Telefon, ganz klar, Philip Reiss, 70 Jahre vorher.
Frag mal einen Amerikaner.
Ja, Glühbirne ist auch sehr umstritten.
Die Amerikaner denken ja auch, dass sie zuerst auf dem Mond waren, aber guck mal, ironsgeidern, weißt du wie das ist.
Na gut, aber dann kam es dann doch zur Vorstellung der neuen MacBooks.
Da war das Vorspiel endlich vorbei.
Da war das Vorspiel dann endlich vorbei. Und was haben wir jetzt bekommen? Es gibt im Wesentlichen drei neue Geräte. Das gibt einen 15 Zoll MacBook Pro High-End.
Ein 15 Zoll MacBook Pro?
Das High-End-Modell.
Wie auch immer.
Ja, also das, was jetzt bei Apple das High-End-Modell ist. Und dann gibt es halt noch ein 13 Zoll MacBook Pro. Und das gibt es in zwei Varianten. Nämlich eins mit einer Tastatur und dann eins...
Mit einer halben Tastatur.
Mit einer Kastratur. Mit der Kastratur, genau. Ach, Kastratur. Kastratur fand ich jetzt auch ganz gut. Genau. Also zwei Modelle mit einer Kastratur und eins mit einer Tastatur. Ja und zunächst einmal finde ich ja ganz bemerkenswert, was diese Geräte jetzt alles nicht mehr haben oder zumindest nicht ohne weiteres mehr haben. Sie haben echt einiges geopfert. Das muss ja auch nicht unbedingt schlecht sein. Zum Beispiel gibt es jetzt keinen leuchtenden Apfel mehr. Das kommt jetzt nicht überraschend, weil das hatte das MacBook ja auch nicht. Und ich frage mich, warum eigentlich?
Das verstehe ich auch nicht, weil ich meine, das Licht ist eh da. Oder ist da aber wieder kein Platz, weil ist ja jetzt noch dünner der Deckel.
Das ist ehrlich gesagt etwas, über das ich mir noch überhaupt keine Gedanken gemacht habe.
Dafür ist dieser Podcast ja da. Wir machen uns Gedanken für euch.
Ja, der leuchtet, aber den sehe ich ja selber nicht. Das ist mir doch so wurscht, ob das Ding leuchtet oder nicht.
Also ich weiß ja noch, als das erste Powerbook rauskam, wo überhaupt so ein weißer Apfel drauf war.
War das das Pismo?
Das war das davor, das war das...
Wall Street?
Ja, ich glaube, das hier ist Wall Street.
Wall Street, Main Street und Pismo. Was war das Erste, das Wall Street oder das...
Pismo kam, glaube ich, danach. Ich glaube, das Wall Street war das Erste.
Ach Gott, ja ich mein...
Und da war das ja dann so, dass dieser Apfel leuchtete nicht und er war falsch rum, in Anführungsstrichen.
Doch, leuchtet?
Nein, er leuchtete nicht.
Am Anfang leuchtet er nicht.
Das war das Main Street. Da war nämlich der Apfel anders rum, als er heute ist.
Also du meinst, er war richtig rum und nicht falsch rum, wie er sie dann später... Weil jetzt ist er ja eigentlich falsch rum.
Kommt auf an, wer ihn sehen soll.
Genau. Aber wenn du es halt aufklappen willst, musst du dich von der falschen Seite nähern.
Was ganz legitim ist, bis heute.
Die Lernkurve war schwierig, bis heute.
Das war der Grund, warum sie den Apfel so rumgemacht haben, weil sie ja dem User zeigen wollten, wo vorne ist. Und das muss ich sagen, das war, glaube ich, für Apple eine echte Erweckung. Die Reaktion der Nutzer, die alle so, nee, was hier, ich will hier posen. Und jetzt steht der Apfel auf dem Kopf, habt ihr sie noch alle irgendwie? Also ich meine, dass sie sich das Ding niemals von der anderen Seite angeschaut haben. Und dann kam das zweite Modell, das war das Wall Street, glaube ich. Und da war der Apfel dann andersrum?
Nee, der Apfel war erst zum Titanium andersrum. Weil ich hatte das Pismo, das war das Pismo und das hatte den Apfel so rum, dass es richtig war, wenn es zu war und nicht, wenn es offen war. Das kam erst zu dem Titanium, doch zu dem G4 Powerbook.
Dann war es der Lombard, der mit dieser braunen Tastatur.
Pismo und es fällt rum.
Pismo war das letzte vor dem G4.
Lombard, stimmt so, gab es auch eins.
Lombard gab es auch noch.
Das war glaube ich das vor dem Pismo, aber da bin ich mir nicht sicher. Lombard war das auch so?
Aber da hat er schon geleuchtet.
Da hat er schon geleuchtet, ja, aber er war verkehrt rum.
Er hat falsch rum geleuchtet? Ich hab mir das nämlich nicht gekauft.
Wahrscheinlich aus dem Grund.
Ich hatte keins von diesen schwarzen Powerbooks.
Doch, das war geil.
Nee, da war einfach der Apfel falsch rum. Das ging für mich überhaupt nicht.
Das war zudem alles so die Zeit. Das war, glaub ich, während meines sechsjährigen Apple Boykots so, wo ich dann irgendwie keine Apple-Geräte gekauft hatte, weil die einfach so langsam und unbrauchbar waren.
Ja, das war wirklich eine schwierige Zeit.
Ich bin dann wieder erst, als sie auf Intel geschwenkt sind, bin ich dann wieder zurück.
Ja, du warst abtrünnig. Nichtsdestotrotz, der Leuchtapfel war ja nun schon echt ein Symbol und den haben sie jetzt mit dem MacBook im Prinzip schon geopfert und jetzt ziehen sie das halt auch in der ganzen Serie durch, was ich jetzt nicht so überraschend finde, aber so richtig drüber nachgedacht hat ja da keiner. Warum? Ja, warum? Also ich meine, es gibt schon auch einen Nachteil, muss ich sagen, weil es gibt einfach Situationen, da ist es schon ein bisschen unhöflich, einfach in so einen dunklen Raum reinzustrahlen. Also es hat auch schon so was übergriffiges, so ein bisschen.
Ja, aber die andere Seite ist ja viel größer und die strahlt ja auch.
Ja, aber in eine andere Richtung.
In eine andere Richtung. Du strahlst ja nach vorne zu Leuten. Aber ich glaube, das dürfte Apple nicht so mega viel ausgemacht haben. Vielleicht war sie einfach nicht shiny genug und jetzt muss es halt diesen Glitzerglow haben, was irgendwie total absurd ist, weil sie ansonsten in ihrem Design immer alles, diesen ganzen Glow rausgenommen haben und alles so super einfach gemacht haben, auch so in ihrem ganzen Pixel-Design. Und jetzt so rum.
Naja, also wobei ich hatte neulich...
Hat das vielleicht was damit zu tun, dass das Ding jetzt irgendwie pink-rosa sein kann? Ist der Apfel dann auch so pink-rosa? Das heißt, sie können das Ding...
Ich glaube, das ist wahrscheinlich ein Display-Ding auch, dass sie das Teil, Display jetzt so dünn machen wollen, dass sie das nicht mehr richtig hinkriegen, dass es ausgeleuchtet ist ordentlich an hier und da.
Es war auch meine Vermutung, dass sie irgendwie wegen Dicke und Display und so... Und das Problem ist ja... Ich hab neulich irgendjemanden, der hatte ein Problem, weiß nicht, ob da irgendwas kaputt war oder so, aber da ist halt, wenn die Sonne drauf geschienen ist, von hinten auf den Apfel, dann gab's halt komische Verfärbungen in der Mitte von dem Display und die...
Ja, natürlich, es wird ja heller dann. Also den Effekt kenn ich auch, wenn von hinten viel Licht durch den Apfel durchfällt, dann hast du da halt einen hellen Fleck.
Das stimmt. Das ist in der Tat ein Argument, das würde ich auch sofort...
Mich hat das nie gestört, aber...
Da muss aber schon sehr hell sein.
Muss sehr hell sein.
Obwohl, mit dem neuen Display ist es vielleicht besser geworden, aber früher...
Aber da war es, das konnte auch sein, also es war halt so krass, wie ich es noch nie gesehen hatte und die Vermutung war, dass das irgendwie durch die... dass das ein thermisches Problem war, dass halt irgendwie da zu viel Infrarot reingestrahlt ist und die LCDs zu warm geworden sind. Oder wie auch immer.
So, was gab es da noch nicht mehr?
SD-Ports.
Es gibt keinen Start-up Sound by Default mehr. Was auch so ein ganz...
Ist aber nur ein Default, weil wir haben hier den Link, wo da steht, wie man es wieder einschalten kann.
Ja, genau. Also man kann auf der Kommandezeile das mal eben... Was war das nochmal gleich?
Ist das so ein Defaults, oder?
Ist das Defaults, oder ist das eine NV-Rahm-Geschichte? NV-Rahm.
Default geht ja nicht, weil der Sound kommt ja von der Firmware. Da ist das OS ja noch nicht geladen.
Naja, stimmt. Hast recht.
Ja, und dasselbe gilt, ist auch in demselben...
Ich muss noch kurz anhängen, der Sound kommt, wenn der Hardware-Test erfolgreich beendet ist. Weil es sagt nämlich was aus, dass alles okay ist. Aber wenn es nämlich nicht okay ist, dann kommen...
Sad-Mac-Geräusche.
Genau, dann kommen wie früher klierenes Glas oder so. Ich glaube, das kommt heute nicht mehr, aber früher war das ja immer, wenn der Trumpf schrott. Ja, genau. Also der Mac kann schon, der ist zwar irgendwie sehr sperrig mit LEDs und Anzeigen, aber wenn was nicht okay ist, dann passieren da schon noch so Sachen. Und wenn Leute so Probleme haben, dann können sie da auch googeln, was das genau heißt. Das kann man schon ziemlich klar eingrenzen, was das ist, anhand des Sounds. Ich hab übrigens mal als Trick, ich hatte ja eine Weile lang in meinem Mac Pro die Grafikkarte, die kein Bootscreen hatte, und ich wusste nicht, wann ich mein Passwort für 5 Volt eingeben musste, bis ich rausbekommen hab, dass die Tastatur ganz kurz die Caps Lock-Leuchte einmal an- und wieder ausgeht, wenn man sein Name eingeben kann. Das heißt, ich wusste immer genau jetzt, kann ich ihn eingeben, weil die Caps Lock-Leuchte kurz…
Was nochmal, wann geht die an?
Na kurz, also wenn man sein File-Wort-Passwort eingeben kann. Dann geht kurz die Caps Lock-Leuchte an und dann weißt du, jetzt kannst du.
Auch wenn der Bildschirm nicht zeigt?
Ist mir noch nicht aufgefallen, aber…
Ist vielleicht auch gar nicht absichtlich, vielleicht ist das so ein Nebeneffekt, aber ich hab das immer ausgenutzt, dass ich wusste, alles klar, jetzt kann ich eintippen. Weil so weiß man ja nie, du müsstest ja immer so zwei Minuten warten, bis du mal eintippst und dann suchst du dir jetzt, ist er fertig mit hochfahren oder mit seinen Selbsttests. Da ist ja noch nichts hochgefahren, das kommt ja dann erst danach.
Ja, gut, mir fiel noch einig. Generell ist das ja mit den Apple-Produkten immer so eine sehr emotionale Sache. Die ganze Debatte mit dem Wegfall des Klinkensteckers beim iPhone 7 und jetzt die weggefallene Escape-Taste. Es gibt halt Leute, die bezeichnen das als den typischen Apple-Akzeptanz-Zyklus. Nach diesem Kübler-Ross-Modell des Sterbens, was diese fünf Phasen so nämlich erst nicht wahrhaben wollen, dann zorn, dann irgendwie verhandeln, dann Depression und Leid und am Ende dann halt Akzeptanz. Also sprich zuerst so, Apple würde das nie tun. Das können die doch gar nicht machen.
Das war vor der Präsentation.
Das ist sozusagen vorher, genau. Wenn die Rumors hochkommen. Dann die zweite Phase. Okay, sie haben es getan. Aber niemand wird das kaufen. Das ist so schlimm. Dann die dritte Phase. Gut, Leute kaufen es trotzdem, aber das sind halt alles Schafe, die das kaufen. Die sind halt alle dumm. Und dann okay, in der nächsten Stufe gut. Jetzt habe ich es dann auch gekauft, weil ich dann so nicht die Wahl hatte. Aber es ist nicht so toll, wie alle anderen sagen. Und dann die letzte Phase, dann halt Akzeptanz. Okay, das war super, was Apple damals gemacht hat. Dass sie irgendwie, ja, weiß ich nicht, die seriellen Ports und die Diskettenlaufwerke. Diese fünf Phasen, die sich dann immer abspielen.
Ich hab ja noch Ethernet dabei. Wie oft nutzt ihr denn euren Ethernet-Adapter? Ich sehe, Pavel, du hast den ja auch gerade dran, obwohl es gar nicht nötig gewesen wäre.
Na gut, weil hier das erste, was ich reinstecke, wenn ich hier reingehe.
Also ich war ja auch, als ich auf das 2013er gegangen bin, dachte ich mir auch, ah, kein Ethernet-Port.
Das überleb ich nicht.
Ja, jetzt muss ich dauernd diesen blöden Adapter. In zwei Jahren hab ich, glaub ich, das Ding fünfmal benutzt. Den Adapter. Was vielleicht auch damit zu tun hat, dass ich halt zu Hause eine ordentliche WLAN-Station habe, die halt fast genau, also die halt irgendwie 1,6 Gigabit, bis zu 1,6 Gigabit übers WLAN macht. Das heißt eigentlich ist das WLAN halt schneller als dieser Gigabit Ethernet-Adapter. Wobei, es stimmt nicht ganz, weil wenn mehrere Leute und so ist natürlich immer noch Kabel besser und die Latenz und so, aber wenn ich einfach auf der, wenn ich im Wohnzimmer sitze, in der Nähe, dann ist mein WLAN schneller als das Ethernet. Insofern, ja.
Zuhause benutze ich es eigentlich auch nicht mehr, aber in der Firma, da hängt halt am LAN-Kabel der Dongle dran, so wie am Monitorkabel der Dongle dran hängt und weiß ich nicht, andere Dinge und dann stelle ich das dahin, stecke die ganzen Dinger rein und bin fertig und gut ist. Wird nicht drüber nachgedacht.
Also Dongle ist ja sowieso eigentlich gar nicht die richtige Bezeichnung.
Nein, ist es nicht.
Das war ja mal was anderes.
Gott sei Dank, dass es die nicht mehr gibt.
Das ist ein Kabelkonverter und ich glaube, dass auch sich relativ viel, aber zu den Kabeln kommen wir ja gleich nochmal. Also Startup Sound ist auf jeden Fall jetzt by default aus und das mag für manche Leute vielleicht sogar von Vorteil sein, weil man halt dann, wenn man das Ding eh schon so sehr, also wenn man es mal bootet, dann weiß man, dann ist sowieso eigentlich irgendwie gerade richtig was scheiße. Und da dann noch auf alle Anwesenden darauf aufmerksam zu machen, das ist aber so ein bisschen peinlich.
Alles guckt, was ist passiert.
Ich kenne dieses im Zug dann, oh man, der Rechner ist aus, Tasche greifen, Kabel rausholen, Stecker, also Kopfhörer rausholen, Stecker einstecken, jetzt kann ich anmachen. Insofern, ich glaube, ich vermisse den Start-up Sound wahrscheinlich eher nicht. Ich glaube, wenn ich es nicht gewusst hätte, wär es mir eventuell gar nicht erst aufgefallen.
Unangenehmer ist oder war mir das Gegenteil, dass das Gerät jetzt default beim Aufklappen bootet von alleine. Wenn es ausgeschaltet ist und du klappst es auf, ist es halt bei den neuen Geräten so, dann brauchst du halt keine Taste zu drücken, sondern fangen sie halt an zu booten.
Auf der anderen Seite, wann klappst du auf, ohne es anzumachen?
Das ist dann auch das selbe Verhalten. Wenn er schon an ist, geht er ja dann auch an. Und wenn du halt nicht weißt, dass du ihn ausgeschaltet hattest und machst ihn auf, um ihn zu benutzen, dann drückst du ja dann sowieso drauf. Also ich hab auch schon öfter mal so eine Weile auf dem schwarzen Bild schon gestartet.
Ich kann dein Bedenken verstehen, aber ich glaube, im täglichen Gebrauch ist da noch egal.
Also für den normalen Benutzer wahrscheinlich, ja, denke ich.
Also vielleicht auch für den unnormalen Benutzer. Ich weiß nicht, also für mich ist die Vorstellung, den Rechner aufzuklappen, um ihn dann offen stehen zu lassen und ihn nicht anzumachen, das kommt mir jetzt komisch vor. Aber klar, man verliert so ein bisschen Kontrollverlust. Ich drücke die Taste nicht mehr, sondern ich klappe auf, aber auf der anderen Seite.
Was auch noch weggefallen ist, ist MagSafe.
Das finde ich ziemlich scheiße. Also ich habe im Apple Store, als ich am Montag im Apple Store war, habe ich dann tatsächlich mal probiert, ziehst du mal am Kabel, wie weit kommt denn das Ding mit? Und das Stromkabel, das sitzt einfach fest in dieser Buchse. Wenn du da dran ziehst, dann ist das Ding vom Tisch. Ist es einfach so. Also MagSafe ist halt ein Geräteretter und USB-C ist halt ein Gerätekiller. Einfach mal so allein vom übers Kabel stolpern. Kannst du einfach knicken. Also wenn sie dann noch irgendwie vielleicht einen MagSafe zu USB Typ C Adapter...
Gibt es bestimmt.
Nee, gibt es glaube ich nicht. Aber ich weiß auch nicht.
Also auch da muss ich sagen, sie haben ja mit diesem Anschluss, mit diesem MagSafe-Anschluss haben sie natürlich eine super Idee geliefert und das mag sehr viele Rechner gerettet haben. Und zwar allein, weil es bei Default da ist und weil auch alle sich so gefragt haben, so, oh Gott, klar, Magnete, warum sind wir da noch nicht schon längst drauf gekommen und so. Also es war so ein No-Brain in gewisser Hinsicht. Und das war halt das Besondere daran. Mittlerweile ist es so, du kannst halt diese Funktionalität in einem Kabel kaufen. Also es gibt USB-C-Ladekabel, die haben einfach so einen magnetischen Breakout. Und wenn dir daran liegt, dann nimmst du halt ein entsprechendes Kabel, in dem diese Funktionalität so drin ist.
Ja.
Kannst du dir irgendwie hier von Griffin kaufen, BreakSafe, Magnetikkabel für USB-C und du hast genau dieselbe Funktionalität oder auch diesen kleinen Mini-Adapter, den es auch noch so gibt, den kannst du dir dann ans Netzteil ran machen. Nee, es ist nicht ein Dongle, es ist halt ein Kabel, was diese Funktionalität hat, die nicht jetzt unbedingt nach einem eigenen Port schreit.
Viele von den anderen Dongles sind auch nur Kabel, halt sehr kurz. Also ja, im Prinzip hast du recht, aber irgendwie...
Na, das ist halt ein Ladekabel, was eben so eine Trendfunktion hat.
Ja, aber warum muss ich mir den ganzen Zoo an Zeug...
Na egal.
Ja, das ist ja eh ein Ladekabel.
Ja, ich fand eher... Also ja, das mit dem Gerät runterreißen ist auf jeden Fall eine Sache. Die andere Sache, was ich aber auch immer befürchtet habe, wenn man halt, keine Ahnung, das Gerät jetzt nicht auf dem Schreibtisch, sondern in irgendwelchen gemütlicheren Positionen nutzt, dann kann das halt... dann hast du halt oft quer, also sozusagen quer Belastung und das das Ding dann halt ausleiert, beziehungsweise das ist ja auch in der Regel, ich weiß nicht...
Kippt schnell weg und dann hast du keinen Strom.
Nee, wenn das halt seitlich weggerissen wird oder mechanisch beansprucht wird, war halt oft so, dass das Motherboard dann einfach, weil die Stecker normalerweise direkt aufs Motherboard gelötet sind und du dir im Prinzip dann, wenn du da halt viel dran wackelst oder ziehst oder seitlich, dass dann halt irgendwann eben dein Motherboard Schaden nimmt. Das war halt eine Befürchtung. Aber mein Positiv natürlich jetzt an dem USB-10-Ding wiederum ist, finde ich, muss man sagen, dass man jetzt natürlich das in jeden Port reinstecken kann, um zu laden. Und oft ist das Ladekabel, also der MagSafe-Anschluss auf der falschen Seite. Die Erfahrung habe ich gemacht. Gut, statistisch gesehen in der Hälfte der Fälle. Dann kommt der Strom von der falschen Seite.
Gerade in der Bahn.
Genau, gerade in der Bahn. Und da ist es sicherlich von Vorteil, wenn man halt recht... Es gibt auch viele andere Geräte, die dann tatsächlich aus dem Grund zwei Anschlüsse, also Stromanschlüsse, nicht von Apple, aber von anderen, die für den Zweck rechts und links einen Stromanschluss haben.
Das finde ich auch ganz praktisch. Und was noch dazu kommt, was ich auch in letzter Zeit häufiger das Problem hatte, dieser MagSafe-Anschluss ist ja auch magnetisch und tendiert dazu, so kleine Metallbrösel, die so rumliegen, so anzuziehen. Und man muss schon ab und zu mal, also neulich hab ich mal so drei Minuten lang mal wirklich richtig knallhart mit der Zahnbürste diesen Port frei gebürstet, um auch noch diese letzten kleinen Metallpartikel, die sich da festgesetzt haben, rauszukriegen, weil das dazu gefüttert hat, dass dieser Stecker nicht mehr richtig saß und es sozusagen gar nicht mehr richtig loot oder eben sehr schnell abbrach. Und krieg mal so magnetisierte Metallpartikel aus so einem relativ starken Magnetport erstmal raus. Also das war auch eine gewisse, und ist auch noch eine gewisse Inconvenience. Also ich denke mir, wer das haben will, holt sich einfach ein entsprechendes Ladekabel.
Der Vorteil ist jetzt auch, dass dieses Netzteil hat ja auch einen Port. Das heißt, man hat richtig ein Ladekabel, was auf beiden Seiten USB-C hat. Richtig. Was man auch für andere Sachen benutzen kann. Das Ladekabel könnte man auch nehmen, um zwei Macs zu verbinden zum Beispiel.
Theoretisch ja, aber das ist ja nochmal ein anderes Thema.
Das ist nochmal ein anderes Thema, aber ich weiß es nicht genau. Ich vermute mal, dass die Kabel, die Apple mitliefert... Ich weiß es nicht.
Ja, das Problem ist, dass über den Port...
Also USB-C-Kabel ist nicht gleich USB-C-Kabel, weil USB-C, und das muss man jetzt auch nochmal ganz klar festhalten, USB-C ist ein Port.
Ist ein Stecker, so wie RJ45.
Genau, ist ein Stecker. Und der sagt nichts darüber aus, genau was für ein Kabel da reingehört. Und es gibt halt Kabel, die unter Umständen nicht alles können. Es gibt Kabel, die werden dieses neue Thunderbolt 3 nicht können. Es gibt Kabel, die dieses Power-Transmission nicht machen. Das heißt, da muss man schon gut hinschauen. Aber es ist auf jeden Fall möglich, ein Kabel zu kaufen, was alles kann.
Ja, aber du weißt nicht, ob das was dabei ist, ob das so eins ist.
Da hab ich jetzt keine Erkenntnisse. Ich wäre nicht überrascht, wenn das ein Universal-Kabel ist, aber wissen tu ich es jetzt gerade nicht.
Dieses, wenn das, also für das Neue oder andersrum. Es gibt ja jetzt auch, wenn man so ein Rechner hätte, müsste man ja so ein USB-C-Kabel nehmen, um sein Telefon zu laden oder anzuschließen. Zum Beispiel für Backup oder so. Und wenn man dieses Kabel hätte, könnte man das ja theoretisch auch dann in dieses Netzteil stecken. Das hat ja einen USB-C-Ausgang sozusagen. Würde sich dann das iPhone laden, weil ich meine, da kommen ja ganz andere Wollzahlen.
Das ist so. Das ist ja bei dem MacBook jetzt auch schon so. Wenn du das MacBook-Netzteil, also von dem MacBook One, um mal bei dieser Sprachregelung zu bleiben, nimmst und damit ein iPad Pro lädst, dann lädst du das iPad Pro schneller als mit dem mitgelieferten Netzteil des iPad Pros. Weil da ein ganz anderer Bums rauskommt und das iPad auch in der Lage ist, einen anderen Bums aufzunehmen. Und das ist eh schon ein bisschen verdächtig. Und ja, grundsätzlich ist es auch so, dass dieses Laden über USB-C in gewisser Hinsicht schon so eine neue Nummer ist, weil jetzt auch das erste Mal halt die Laptops und die ganzen i-Geräte in derselben Versorgungskabelverbindungsliga stehen. Also es gibt ja viel Klage darüber, was sich jetzt alles nicht miteinander verbindet, aber was Stromversorgung betrifft, läuft schon auf so eine gewisse Singularität hinaus gerade. Also wie lange die hält, das ist eine andere Sache, aber ich denke, das USB-C wird der Ladestandard sein.
So wie jetzt das normale USB das gemacht hat für lange Zeit für 5 Volt.
Ja, obwohl es das gewisser Hinsicht auch nicht ist, weil standardisiert ist eher dieses USB-Mini, was keiner hat und das ist alles furchtbar. Oder Mikro sogar, ich weiß es jetzt gar nicht.
Na gut, Type-A-Anschluss ist schon ein Standard gewesen.
Ja, kann man schon sagen. De facto ist Port A derzeit das, wo der Strom rauskam, aber da kam halt nicht viel Strom raus. Und aus USB-C kriegst du sowohl sehr wenig als auch extrem viel Strom raus, mit dem du ganze Bildschirme und fette High-End-Laptops treiben kannst und das ist natürlich schon ganz geil.
Und noch ein weiterer Vorteil, der mir gerade eingefallen ist, wenn du halt vier gleiche Löcher hast, wo es egal ist, wo du was reinsteckst, ist es halt auch weniger fummelig. Also manchmal gerade im Dunkeln oder... Wie oft ich schon USB, glaube ich, ins Ethernet geschoben habe oder sowas, der perfekt passt, da war doch irgendwas. Oder HDMI und USB auch noch richtig rum.
Wie war das, man probiert den USB-Stecker dreimal, dann andersrum und dann doch wieder wie beim ersten Mal, weil es war es doch nicht.
Wobei da ja der einfache Trick angeblich sein soll, wenn man halt dieses USB-Zeichen sieht, dann ist es nur bei Apple.
Wenn dir jetzt zum Beispiel diese geilen Ankerbatterien, was die da geritten hat, dass man die da genau wiederum andersrum reinstecken muss, ist es zum heulen.
Bei meinem Gamer-PC zu Hause war das auch. Ich musste die immer mit dem USB-Symbol nach unten reinstecken, weil die haben das auch falsch rum gemacht. Ich war sogar geneigt, das zu fixen, aber es war innen drin, die Platine, die ich gemacht hatte, die konnte man nicht so umdrehen. Also es ist total unklar. Aber die neuen USB-C-Stecker kann man jetzt ja so rum oder so rum reinstecken, das heißt, das Thema hat sich...
Aber du musst zugeben, dass USB-A der Stecker zu allem dem, was es vorher gab, doch ein deutlicher Vorteil war. Also du kriegst einen USB-A-Stecker deutlich einfacher reingesteckt als einen seriellen 9-Punkt oder so einen VGA-Stecker oder so. Also bei VGA versuche ich es immer fünfmal und dann gucke ich mal richtig hin. VGA ist doch aber noch easy. Und dann gucke ich mir den Stecker an und dann... Ach ja, so. So hätte es gleich gehen müssen.
Viel schlimmer finde ich bei diesem PS2, bei den PCs, wenn du... Ich weiß immer nicht, welches ist Maus.
Da drehst du so lange bis da drin.
Welches ist Maus und welches ist Tastatur. Und wenn du nichts siehst, kriegst du ihn auch erstmal 10 Minuten lang nicht rein, weil du weißt nicht, warum du ihn positionierst.
Das ist vielleicht grün und das andere ist lila.
Wer soll denn das wissen als...
Keiner.
Vor allem ist das vielleicht... Auf dem Board ist das noch so, bei den Motherboards, aber das Kabelende von Maus und Tastatur hat diese Farbe oft nicht, weil die einfach diesem Standard grau sind. Und dann sagt mir mal, welches wo reinkommt.
Nee, also es ist schon definitiv ein Sprung nach vorne, denke ich, diese ganze Laderei über USB-C, zumal man jetzt auch, und das war ja bei dem MacBook One jetzt ja auch schon so, dass du halt jetzt einfach mal einen fetten Akku-Pack nehmen konntest und damit kriegst du dann deinen Laptop halt auch mal über ein Wochenende. Also zumindest den kleinen bei den MacBook Pros jetzt. Von Hardwork gab es auch einen Akku-Pack mit MagSafe, wofür sie dann Netzteile kaufen durften bei Apple, die sie dann da rangeholtet haben.
Keine Ahnung, also es war relativ teuer.
Aber die haben das Ding ja nicht lizenziert, diesen Stecker. Deswegen war es auch so teuer. Erstmal mussten sie nämlich ein Netzteil kaufen, damit sie diesen Stecker haben.
Da hat Apple jahrelang geblockt, um ihn jetzt auch ganz fallen zu lassen. Also das MagSafe, das ist mit dem Magnetisch, vermisse ich doch so ein bisschen, dass er so einfach so abknicken kann. Ich fand das ganz gut.
Ja, aber wie Tim schon, also ich werde sicherlich dann hier mal gucken, wie gut das mit der Kabellösung ist.
Die USB-Abknickgabe.
Ja, weil schon vor allen Dingen halt jetzt bei dem Preis ist es schon so jetzt bei dem rechts unten Gerät so 5000 Euro. Will man halt jetzt nicht so schnell über den Tisch reisen. Auch auf dem, genau.
Gut, so viel zum Thema Laden. Haben wir noch irgendwelche Erkenntnisse? Laden läuft.
Die Frage ist noch, wenn wir schon bei Strom sind und so, wie viel Power hat dieses Laptop eigentlich als Batterie? Weil, glaubt man, sie hat hier 60 Watt oder so? 75.
Bist du jetzt bei Batterie oder bist du bei Laden?
Bei Batterie.
75 Wattstunden habe ich irgendwo gelesen. Es gibt wohl von der Flugbehörde in Amerika so eine Beschränkung, dass so ein Laptop nicht mehr als 100 Wattstunden Akkut haben darf. Damit du es mit ins Flugzeug nehmen kannst. Und das war irgendwie auch einer von den Design-Constraints, warum sie den Prozessor genommen haben und nicht den Grafikchip und haste nicht gesehen. Auf jeden Fall, ja, gelesen habe ich 75 Wattstunden.
Aber es gilt nicht für alle Modelle, ne?
Das große wohl, keine Ahnung.
Das große und das kleine. Guck doch mal nach. Wir sind doch immer gut vorbereitet und kennen die URLs.
Meistens ist der Chat der vorbereitet, der die URLs kennt. Um mal an alte Mobile-Max-Zeiten zu erinnern.
Ja, wo wir jetzt schon bei Batterien sind, kann man ja auch gleich mal erwähnen, dass sie jetzt auch so mit All-Day-Battery-Life da herkommen.
Das war ja vorher nicht so, ne? All-Day, 10 Stunden.
Ja, genau. Aber das ist ja das, was iPad und MacBook One auch haben.
Ja, aber gefühlt sind die Zahlen immer die gleichen. Aber vielleicht, ja.
Ja, also ich hab gehört, dass die Batterie kleiner ist und genauso lange halten soll. Wie bei der Vorgänger-Generation. Also kommt drauf an, was ich mache. Ich krieg die auch in einer Stunde leergesaugt. Ja logisch. Ja, was sagt er mir jetzt? Kann ich dir gleich mal sagen. Hier ist bei dem 2014 MacBook Pro eine 7500 mAh Batterie drin.
7500 mAh?
Stunden.
Bei wie viel Volt?
Ich glaube, es hat mit dem Volt nichts zu tun.
Da hat die das letzte Mal schon verloren.
Ich glaube, es sind 12,8 Volt oder so, haben die Batterien zusammen.
Ja, aber das ist ja egal. Also in Ampere-Stunden werden nun mal Ladung angegeben.
Nützt dir aber nichts, weil du musst die Wattzahl wissen.
Ja, also 54,5 Wattstunden bei dem 13 Zoll mit Tastatur. Und 49,2 bei dem mit Touchbar, 13 Zoll, also weniger. Ja, weniger.
Also Funktionstasten brauchen halt auch viel Strom.
Ich weiß nicht, was der Grund ist, aber es kann sein, dass einfach dieser Touchbar einfach noch mal Platz braucht, den die Batterie freigeben musste. Und beim 15 Zoll Modell sind es 76 Wattstunden und der USB-C Power Adapter hat 87 Watt. Also das 15 Zoll spielt schon in einer anderen Liga, sowohl was halt Batterie betrifft, das ist halt mal so 50 Prozent mehr Batterieleistung, ist ja auch größer, mehr Platz. Und braucht dann aber auch mehr Schubs aus dem Netzteil.
Verbraucht aber auch mehr wegen größeres Display. Verbraucht ja aber auch mehr wegen größeres Display. Muss ja mehr beleuchtet sein.
Vermutlich.
Also ich habe jetzt hier dieses 13 Zoll von 2013 und da war halt auch nicht das große 75 Watt oder 85 Watt, was hat das große Netzteil derzeit? Mit 65, genau.
Ist aber auch nicht ganz so schlimm, weil dieses extra breite Netzteil von früher, das 85, gibt es ja nicht mehr. Das 85er, das moderne ist ja auch kleiner geworden. Die konnten man ja nicht mehr unterscheiden.
Ja, ist ein bisschen kleiner, aber die 65er sind tatsächlich auch noch mal ein klein bisschen kleiner als die 85er. Also du siehst, wenn du sie nebeneinander hältst, siehst du den Unterschied schon. Ansonsten ist es egal.
Ich find's cool, dass man mit so einem Power-Adapter auch mal ein iPad laden kann, ohne dass du dann gleich wieder noch eine andere Art Netzteil brauchst.
Oder alle anderen Geräte, die halt USB-C haben.
Genau, was auch immer.
Gut, ging aber hier mit den, also meine USB-Ports liefern auch zwei Ampere hier bei dem 2014er MacBook. Da kann ich auch schon immer...
Aber du hast ja auch noch zwei USB-Ports, oder?
Ja, das ist halt das andere Problem. Das war auch, was mich genervt hatte hier, dass das hier halt nutzt. Und die sind ein bisschen flaky. Und ich sehe gerade, du hast auch genau so ein... Charger-Doctor. Ja, ich hab mir nämlich vor ein paar Monaten irgendwie, hab ich mir auch so ein Ding, weiß ich gar nicht...
Also für die Hörer so ein Zwischenstecker in den USB-Kanal, um zu sehen, was da tatsächlich an Leistung läuft.
Genau, wo man Strom und Spannung messen kann auf dem USB-Port. Und die lagen hier doch deutlich außerhalb der Specks.
Die Specks sind ja immer noch 500 mA, oder haben sie die irgendwann mal geändert?
Ja, ne, ich meine von der Spannung her. Voltzahl, also ich glaube eigentlich sollten es 5 Volt sein.
5 Volt ist die Speck, ja.
Ja, genau. Und ich hatte glaube ich 5,6 oder so. Ja, auch im belasteten Zustand. Und ich kann halt hier mein iPhone auch nur an meinem rechten USB-Port laden, an dem linken. Die mögen sich nicht. Also mein iPhone und mein Linker.
Was hast du für ein Kabel? Das normale Kabel?
Das Original, alles Original-Apple. So und also der mag den linken USB-Port nicht, obwohl alle anderen Geräte also kein Problem damit haben, aber mein iPhone und so. Und das sollte hoffentlich in Zukunft auch, weil ich schon gelesen hab, irgendwie auch die sollen nicht alle gleich schnell sein, die USB-C-Ports, aber I don't know.
Ja, das ist so, das bezieht sich aber nur, meinst du jetzt bei den neuen Geräten, das bezieht sich nur auf die Thunderbolt-Speed. Also du hast auf zwei Ports, hast halt die maximalen PCI-Lanes.
Und war das nicht nur bei dem 13 Zoll so?
Na, das hat ja nur zwei Ports.
Nein, das eine 13er hat auch vier Ports.
Stimmt es.
Bei denen, die vier Ports haben, sind nur zwei Ports schnell und zwar die links und die rechts sind langsamer in Anführungsstrichen.
Aber nur bei dem 13 Zoll?
Nö, auch beim 15er.
Ganz sicher?
Das ist auch so eine Beschränkung, die so sinnlos ist.
Das hat aber einen Grund, das hat irgendwas mit diesen Intel Thunderbolt-Chips, genau, mit den Lanes.
Ich glaube, die gehen auch direkt an die CPU.
Na ja klar, das ist halt PCI. Also das ist halt PCI Express.
Das ist wie, wenn man einen Mainboard kauft, irgendwie so ein normales Weitund-Wiesen-PC-Mainboard, dann hast du immer USB 3 und USB 2 Anschlüsse da dran. Dann sind die einen schwarz, die anderen blau. Dann musst du immer aufpassen, wo du reinsteckst.
Das ist total sinnlich. Lass uns mal nicht zu sehr springen. Lass uns kurz nochmal dieses Stromthema abschließen. Dann gab es noch das Gerücht, dass noch was nicht dabei sah, nämlich dieses Schoko-Kabel.
Das ist kein Gerücht, das ist so, dass das nicht dabei ist.
Ja, ich hab dann aber Videos gesehen, wo Leute dann einfach mal mit einem Messer ihre Box aufgeschnitten haben und dann lag es da drunter. Oder war das der Fake? Ich weiß es nicht. Ich bin mittlerweile total verwirrt.
Warum sollt ihr das nicht mit dabei legen? Ach so, nur noch diesen kleinen...
Ja, dieser Klappnupsi. Also was in Amiland ist, ist ja der Klappnupsi.
Ja, bei uns ist ja ohne Klapp und dieses dicke Kabel nicht mehr.
Gut, ich glaube, ich hab noch 30 Stück von dem Schoko-Kabel zu Hause rumliegen.
Wenn der passt, dann.
Wenn der passen sollte, ja. So hab ich, glaub ich, für die nächsten 10 Jahre...
Also ich hab die ja hier sehr umfangreich verbaut im Studio, weil hier war das mal echt wichtig. Weil wir hatten ja hier, erinnerst du dich, solange die Netzteile hier nicht richtig geerdet waren, hatten wir schnell mal so kleine Brummeffekte, wenn man seinen Laptop angefasst hat. Und das...
Da haben wir rausgefunden, dass nur mit diesem richtig langen Kabel hat man die Erdung mit dabei, ne?
Genau, weil der Schoko-Kabel halt dann nicht nur da in diesen Schnupsi reingeht, sondern auch noch einen metallischen Kontakt herstellt. Und das ist halt das Besondere an diesen dicken Kabeln. Ich glaube, manche Leute wissen gar nicht, warum es dieses Kabel gibt. Das gibt es halt, damit man auch Erdung hat. Weil deswegen Schoko und überhaupt...
Ja, weil der Eurostecker hat ja sowieso keine Erdung. Also kein Schutzleiter.
Und diesen Eurostecker selber benutze ich persönlich eigentlich fast nie.
Ich auch nicht, ich hab noch eine ganze Kiste.
Ich sag jetzt während hier jetzt zufällig mal einer in der Steckdose so schenkt.
Zwei, der von dir nicht zu sehen ist.
Ach so, ja. Auf jeden Fall, ich benutze sowieso immer die kleinen zweipoligen Euro-Kabel. Ich nehm so einfach so ein...
So ein Rasierdinger.
Technisch gesehen sind es nicht die Rasierer-Stecker, die sind nochmal anders, aber halt die ähnlichen.
Ja, ich weiß, was du meinst. Die zweipoligen Kaltgerätestecker.
Genau, die zweipoligen Kaltgerätestecker. Und die sind halt enorm praktisch, weil die wiegen halt nicht so viel. Die kann man halt schön lang mitnehmen. Da wird's nicht, wenn du da so zwei Meter nochmal aufgewickelt hast. Und dann ist man halt auch sehr flexibel, was so das Erreichen von Steckdosen betrifft. Aber meine Hoffnung wäre halt für so ein zukünftiges Gerät. Und da bin ich mal gespannt, ob dieses neue 13 Zoll MacBook Pro mit Tastatur da in diese Kategorie schon reingeht. Dass man das halt auch ordentlich mit Akkus laden kann, weil dann ist man einfach auch von diesen Steckdosen ein bisschen weniger abhängig. Das ist für Konferenzen glaube ich sehr fein. So, so viel zum Strom. Kommen wir zu den anderen Sachen. Wir reden ja erstmal über alles, was es nicht gibt. Was gibt es denn sonst noch nicht mehr?
Eine HDMI-Port.
Es gibt keine HDMI-Port mehr.
Das finde ich allerdings relativ scheiße, weil... Weil, also zumindest bei uns in der Firma, es gibt es in 60% der Meeting-Räume, gibt es einen Projektor. Und eigentlich an allen ist ein HDMI-Kabel dran. Das heißt, du gehst da rein mit dem Rechner, stöpselst ein, fertig. Und jetzt immer einen Dongle, oder wie du ihn nennst, Adapter mitzunehmen, ist halt so sinnlos.
Man nimmt den nicht mit. Man legt den da hin.
Und lässt ihn da.
Weil, wenn das ein Ort ist, wo alle Leute ihre Rechner anschließen...
Moment, Moment. Da gibt es Adapter, dann gibt es in vielen Adaptern einen Mini Display Port Adapter zu VGA. Der ist dann schon fest dran. Aber dann hast du natürlich an dem Gerät auch wieder keinen Mini Display Port, sprich Thunderbolt 2 Stecker. Dann bräuchtest du wiederum da für einen Adapter. Also du kannst jetzt in einer Firma mit 60 Meeting räumen. Oder wie viel es sind. Kannst du jetzt nicht hingehen und 60 von diesen Dingern da kaufen und die da hinlegen?
Nein, aber ihr habt 100 Angestellte und ihr kauft 100 Adapter für 100 Angestellte. So macht ihr das, ja? Also ich weiß nicht.
Also erstens doch, ja, kann man machen, weil die Zahl der Adapter ist dann doch sehr überschaubar, die man da wirklich, wirklich, wirklich braucht.
Ja, natürlich.
Also du hast halt keine Laptops mehr, also gut, es gibt da noch so ein paar PC-Klunker, die haben halt noch VR. Ja, ja. Aber alles was digital ist, gibt es eigentlich nur... Also was gibt es? Es gibt theoretisch Display-Port, das hat niemand.
Niemand mehr, ja.
Nein, das hat niemand. Hast du schon mal, mal ehrlich, wie viele Rechner sind dir in deinem Leben begegnet, die Display-Port haben? Also ich hab nie...
Ich hatte mal ein Powerbook G4, das hatte ich nie.
Also jetzt aber ohne Mini, richtig?
Display-Port, nicht Mini-Display-Port, Display-Port.
Der dicke, der dicke, der so ein bisschen draussah wie Scott.
Nein, das ist DVI.
Ach, das ist DVI.
Wir haben ja Mini-Display-Port, das gibt's auch noch als Display-Port ohne Mini. So ein bisschen schräger, so ähnlich wie HDMI, so ein bisschen, so komisch gewinkelt.
Den hat keiner.
Den hat keiner. Also es gibt nur Mini-Display-Port und dann gibt's irgendwie die, die sowieso HDMI haben und dann wird's halt jetzt USB-C geben. So und das wird jetzt der Standard sein.
Keine Ahnung, gibt's Projektoren mit USB-C?
Nein, aber du kannst doch da einfach USB-C mit einem Band an dieses Kabel ranmachen, dass der da immer dran klackert und dann ist das Thema durch.
Naja, also ich muss sagen, ich hab tatsächlich hier bei meinem Gerät den HDMI-Port sehr häufig, also überraschend häufig benutzt, nachdem ich entdeckt hatte, dass da einer dran.
Ist.
Und tatsächlich entweder bei Präsentationen in das Problemlos, aber auch mal bei Freunden, wenn man einen Film zeigen wollte oder so, der da drauf ist, so zack, rein. Ton, Bild, alles da, relativ hässelfrei. Aber es ist jetzt kein Killer-Kriterium, ich muss nur sagen. Ich fand ihn doch sehr praktisch und habe ihn sicherlich zehnmal häufiger benutzt als jetzt Ethernet.
Aber was man bei HDMI auch mal bedenken muss, in der Regel, nicht immer, aber in der Regel, sind HDMI-Stecker und HDMI-Kabel extrem massive, schwere Geschichten, die sich auch sehr an so einem Rechner reißen und die immer erst mal so einen halben Meter Radius brauchen.
Du verwechselst das gerade mit Scassi, glaube ich.
Nein, nein, das ist schon.
Die sind schon teilweise, das sind ganz schöne Knöpfe teilweise.
Das sind richtig dicke Teile, weil da auch so viele Leitungen drin sind und irgendwie, was du da nicht alles theoretisch noch drüber fahren kannst mit Ethernet und Pipapo.
Also hab ich jetzt noch nie das Problem gehabt, dass ich irgendwie ein störrisches HDMI-Kabel gehabt hätte.
Nicht sonderlich störrisch, aber das ist schon ein massives Ding und auch nicht selten hast du da halt auch ordentlich Kabellänge dran. Also wenn du dann irgendwie am anderen Ende daran ziehst, dann reißt das schon sehr an deinem Rechner. Das ist schon so eine Belastung, die man ungern sieht.
Also ich hoffe nicht, dass es so wird wie früher mit DVI, wo ja eigentlich die meisten DVI-Adapter haben ja nur das VGA-Analog-Signal dann wiederum weiter, also diese DVI auf VGA-Adapter, die es dann gab, haben halt, also es gab ja auch vier oder fünf verschiedene Varianten von DVI.
DVI, so mit Plus, mit Minus-Zeiten.
Das war immer kompletter Hessel, insbesondere dann auch noch den Ton dann da rauszukriegen.
Das ging gar nicht bei DVI durch.
Das war irgendwie alles ultra nervig und HDMI war eigentlich die erste so wirklich stressfreie Plug-and-Play-Audio-Video-Verbindung, die ich...
Hat eine Weile gedauert, bis Audio dazu kam.
Aus gutem Grund hat erst HDMI VGA abgelöst, bei diesen ganzen Projektoren, weil vorher war das alles kacke. HDMI ist der erste Standard, der ein echter Standard geworden ist nach VGA, weil er halt einfach funktioniert. Du stöpselst ein und der unterhält sich mit dem Beamer, macht automatisch die richtige Bildschirmgröße hin, fertig. So, und das ist halt irgendwie schade, dass das nicht mehr, du gehst hin, steckst ein ist. Das ist halt irgendwie...
Und ich hab zu Hause auch so einen netten irgendwie 5 Gigahertz Sender mit HDMI Adapter, also so eine HDMI Radio-Brücke.
Und Freisprecher-Einrichtung für HDMI.
Wenn man mal halt vom Laptop Filme abspielen will und nicht irgendwie ein Kabel, nicht am Kabel hängen will, sondern das halt dann einfach HDMI durch die Luft, so geht's halt maximal so, ich würd sagen, 5 bis 10 Meter weit, aber funktioniert eigentlich auch ganz gut. Wie heißt die Technologie? Die arbeitet halt auch im 5 Gigahertz Band.
Hast du da mal einen Tipp, einen konkreten, mein ich? Weil sowas, ich hab da ein Problem, ich brauch das.
Also ich glaube, ich hab das irgendwie bei Konrad geschoppt, pro halber, und das funktionierte einfach sogar mit Ton. Das ist halt so ein kleines Kistchen und auf der anderen Seite so ein Stecker, der ja das einzige Problem bei HDMI ist, dass da kein Strom rauskommt. Das heißt, es ist halt zusätzlich noch ein USB-Kabel dran, also brauchst du halt USB und HDMI, um diesen Sender zu betreiben. Aber eigentlich ist es tats und auch mit guter Qualität. Nur wie gesagt, es sucht sich halt irgendwie Frequenzen eben im 5 Gigahertz Spektrum und macht dir unter Umständen ein bisschen das W-Laden oder so. Platt? Platt, aber nicht schlimm. Es sucht sich halt eh freie Frequenzen. Ich benutze das Ding jetzt nicht mehr so oft, seit ich mir einen Rechner gebaut habe, der direkt jetzt am Fernseher hängt. Wenn du willst, kann ich dir das Ding gleich ausprobieren, ob es für deine Zwecke taugt.
Also was steht jetzt sozusagen an? Man hat jetzt auch USB-C als Ausgabe, als Stecker für die Zuspielung zu HDMI, was glaube ich nach wie vor eigentlich das ist, was so für Projektoranschlüsse ist. Aber es deckt halt auch den großen Monitorbedarf an. Und vor allem jetzt, wo da halt Thunderbolt 3 mit drin steckt und 40 Gigabit Kapazität, also Transferleistung möglich ist, das geht jetzt auch 5K Monitorbetrieb darüber.
Beziehungsweise es geht auch externe Grafikkarte.
Das ist natürlich die andere interessante.
Ich warte immer darauf, das Display mit der Grafikkarte drin.
Das ging vorher auch schon mit Thunderbolt, aber jetzt ist es da halt auch drin. Und angeblich ist auch Displayport unterstützt über das Kabel. Also du hast nicht nur Thunderbolt, sondern halt auch der Displayport-Modus von Thunderbolt.
Aber jetzt geht davon physikalisch halt nicht mehr rein. Ich hab ja hier so einen Apple Cinema mit Mini Displayport, muss jetzt auch einen Adapter nehmen oder müsste.
Aber du kannst jetzt... Nein, es geht. Man kann jetzt bei den neuen Geräten zwei 5K-Monitore anschließen?
Bei dem großen 15 Zoll soll es möglich sein, zwei 5K-Monitore anzuschließen.
Das klingt doch ganz gut. Und vielleicht, wenn wir schon dabei sind, externe Grafikkarte. Es gibt übrigens, ich weiß nicht, wenn ihr das mal gesehen habt, es gibt so externe Grafikkartengehäuse.
Ja, die gibt es schon schon länger.
Und da kann man sich dann, also die gibt es dann halt auch wiederum für so eine 250 Watt Titan X-Karte. Und da kann ich dann...
Dann kannst du halt vier Stück anschließen. Oder zwei dann würden wir, oder wie für Thunderbolt 3.
Die Frage, wie viele Lanes du da brauchst.
Ja, das Problem ist halt natürlich der Memory-Speed wahrscheinlich, die Zahl der Lanes, aber...
Das wäre natürlich auch so eine Alternative zum Gaming-PC. Ist einfach so eine fette Grafikkarte.
Wie gesagt, Display schon mit der Grafikkarte fett drin. Also, wozu brauche ich hier so eine fette GPU? Wenn das Display am Laptop selbst ist ja gar nicht so riesengroß, aber das 5K-Display, das braucht diese fette GPU und da kann sie die dann gleich mit reinmachen. Können das doch ordentlich weglüften und...
Das wär's. Da geht natürlich der Vorteil vom Laptop weg und als du noch vorhin meintest, dass du mehr so jetzt zum Desktop-Typen mutiert bist. Bei mir ist es eher so, also ich arbeite am liebsten im Freien an der frischen Luft.
Ja, aber dann schleppst du auch diese eGPU nicht mit dir.
Genau, deswegen schleppe ich halt...
Aber auch kein externes Display, oder?
Nein. Deswegen, also eigentlich will ich möglichst alles eigentlich am Gerät und im Gerät haben, weil ich tatsächlich... Solange die Temperaturen über 10 Grad sind, sitze ich eigentlich draußen mit meinem tagsüber, mit meinem Gerät. Also auf der Terrasse.
Und...
Und beim HDMI-Port eigentlich? Und beim Anschließen von Monitoren?
Na ja, wie gesagt, also kann man jetzt so oder so sehen, dass es jetzt egal ist, ob er draußen ist oder dass es scheiße ist, dass er draußen ist.
Ich würde sagen, es ist ziemlich egal, dass er draußen ist, weil...
Naja, das Problem ist, du kannst dich jetzt nicht mehr darauf verlassen, dass du einen USB-C Adapter für irgendeinen HDMI irgendwo vorfindest. Das heißt, du musst ihn immer selber dabei haben.
Ja, es gibt Übergangsschmerzen, aber es ist halt grundsätzlich der richtige Weg. Und das hat sich ja auch in den letzten Jahren gezeigt, da kaufst du dann halt einfach die nennenswerte Menge an Adaptern und dann war's das. Klar, ich meine, das ist ohne Änderung kein Fortschritt. Das ist immer dasselbe lief und das habe ich ja letztes Mal auch schon gesagt. Die Tatsache, dass man jetzt ein System hat, wo alle Ports für alles denselben Stecker hat, ich meine, das ist das, was wir immer wollten, was wir nicht unbedingt für möglich gehalten haben, aber jetzt und du kannst halt auswählen, wann du welchen nimmst du kannst halt auch alles anschließen. Ich sehe ja den Punkt, dass wenn man jetzt irgendeinen dieser Ports sehr oft benutzt hat, dass das dann sehr praktisch ist, wenn man halt keinen Adapter braucht. Gar keine Frage.
Aber die Adapter werden ja auch wegfallen mit der Zeit.
Weil man halt einfach die Kabel durch entsprechende USB-C-Kabel ersetzt. Die haben einfach gar nicht mehr so...
Hoffen wir, dass in fünf oder zehn Jahren in jedem Konferenzraum dann so ein USB-C...
Das ist aber dann auch die Zeit, wo dann der nächste Standard kommt.
Nein, das ist der letzte Standard.
Ich wollte noch sagen, dass das Problem noch mit den Adaptern ist aber noch ein anderes. Also nicht nur, selbst wenn man sie jetzt dabei hat, ist dann noch die Frage, wie viele Adapter man nach der Präsentation wieder mit nach Hause nimmt. Also ich hatte schon sowohl zwischen null und zwei, so variierte das dann halt immer. Das ist ja mit Kaltgeräte kalt.
Die kauft man halt so lange, bis man immer zu viele hat.
Für jeden dieser Ports, die da weggefallen ist, kann man die Diskussion aufmachen. Aber ich hab das Gefühl, dass bei HDMI der Schmerz am größten ist. Weil das jetzt endlich mal so ein Standard ist. Du kommst irgendwo hin, willst eine Präsentation halten. Was ist da? Ein HDMI-Kabel.
Aber ich komm auch schon so oft.
Also ich hab schon fast nirgendwo mehr.
Also ich finde fast überall auch mittlerweile ein Adapterset, wenn ich irgendwo präsentieren muss. Also ich hab auch schon ein paar Mal meine Adapter vergessen und es war immer eins, immer was auffindbar. Ich glaub der einzige Port, wo man wirklich lange drüber diskutieren kann, ob der überhaupt verschmerzbar ist, ist halt der gute alte USB-Port A.
Na, ich werd den überhaupt nicht vermissen. Erstens, wie gesagt, was Dennis vorhin meinte, mit dem immer dreimal reinstecken.
Ne, dass der scheiße ist, gar keine Frage, dass man den nicht haben will, auch sofort d'accord. Aber im Puncto, ich finde eine Infrastruktur vor, wo dieser Port jetzt erforderlich ist, weil sich mir nur entsprechende Stecker entgegenrecken. Das passiert ja halt öfter als nur in Präsentationssituationen, sondern halt im Prinzip Ladesituationen und Verbindungs- und schließ deine elektrische Zahnbürste an deinen Rechner an. All dieser ganze Kram ist heute erwartet halt USB-Port A. Und das wird auch noch sehr lange dauern, bis das irgendwie nennenswert weg ist und durch USB-C ersetzt ist. Das dauert wirklich mindestens fünf, sechs Jahre.
Na gut, das ist ein würdiger Konkurrent. Aber ansonsten hast du halt, weiß ich nicht, ob es sowas gibt, aber wird es bestimmt schnell geben, halt einen USB-Hub, da ist halt ein C-Stecker dran. Und dann sind da so und so viele A-Buchsen dran und fertig.
Genau, also das ist auch, sagen wir mal, etwas, was mir sogar schon dieses MacBook One schmackhaft gemacht hat, weil es gibt halt relativ günstige Adapter auch, also nicht von Apple. Hier Linus hat so ein Teil, steckst du halt rein über USB-C, fällt nochmal USB-C raus, damit du Strom reinführen kannst, fällt ein USB-Port A raus, also als USB 3, fällt ein HDMI raus und ein Ethernet raus.
Klingt wie ein Dock.
Ja, ist auch ein Dock, aber ist halt sehr...
Ein Nano-Dock.
Hat aber jetzt nicht so die Größe, ist jetzt nicht so ein Tischgerät, sondern ist wirklich mehr so ein, naja, halt so breit, wie er sein muss für diese Stecker, aber das kriegst du halt schon nochmal mit ins Laptoptäschchen so mit rein, so, und dann wiederum hast du halt so mit einmal was reinstecken, auch alles genau so, wie du es brauchst. Das heißt, wenn das jetzt wirklich so dein Problem ist mit ja, aber der und der und der Port, die hab ich immer benutzt und die hab ich immer, da hab ich immer einen Fall gefunden und jeden Tag hatte ich da was, dann musst du dir genau so einen USB-C Tour My Selection of Port-Ding kaufen und vielleicht zwei davon oder auch fünf. Und die hast du...
Gleich einen Kickstarter machen.
Die sind einfach eingenäht in deine Laptop-Tasche.
Tapest du dir unten dran, fertig.
Ja, aber dann ist es auch geiler als mit eingebaut. Weil du hast ja keinerlei Nachteile, die Dinger sind nicht irgendwie langsamer, die sind auch nicht inkompatibler oder so, die sind einfach nur woanders. Aber du hast halt auch nur einen Stecker, den du rausmachst und du bist diesen ganzen Wust los. Weil teilweise ist es ja auch mega nervig, wenn du an deinem Rechner in alle Richtungen irgendwelche Verbindungen hast, dann wird das Ding so unbehindert. Ist schon ein Punkt, oder?
Ich glaube, das...
Das gleiche gilt auch für den SD-Kartenslot.
Apple hat doch dieses OSP-A deswegen, glaube ich, weggelassen als Übergangslösung, aber das hätten ja beides machen können, weil sie halt eben das Neue ganz doll pushen wollen. Und wenn sie den A gelassen hätten, dann würden alle versuchen, das in diesen einen A reinzukriegen, und würden sagen, ja, es ist nur einer, es ist eng, und die anderen wären die ganze Zeit leer, weil keiner da, wenn der auch die Geräte kauft, die Geräthersteller auch nicht wirklich anfangen, umzurüsten, weil USB-A ist ja noch da. Und jetzt müssen sie halt für die ganzen Mac-User, die jetzt dieses neue Gerät kaufen, muss sich jetzt auch die Infrastruktur ein bisschen anpassen oder Würzeln anpassen oder die Hoffnung, dass sie sich das anpasst.
Ich glaube, mit der gleichen Argumentation haben sie damals beim allerersten iMac halt alle anderen Ports weggelassen, außer USB. Gut, da ist jetzt noch ein Ethernet und ein Telefonanschluss. Okay, auf jeden Fall, was fiel da alles weg? Apple Desktop, Bass und seriell und parallel gut, hatten die Macs eh dann irgendwie nicht. Aber das ist ja alles weg gewesen und du hattest nur noch USB. Und insofern, das geht natürlich, die Argumentation ist die gleiche. Wenn dann halt richtig. Und dann hier hat jemand ein C zu A-Ding gepostet. Wie viel? Das steht nicht mal mehr an Preis dran, was das kosten soll. 6. 6,50. Der SD-Karten-Slot, da gibt es halt eine Anwendung, die ich habe oder ich benutze. Das ist halt dieses Nifty Drive. Das ist halt diese SD-Karte, die du reinsteckst und dann ist sie so weit drin, dass sie nicht mehr rausschaut. Und du hast sie immer dabei, quasi als zweites Laufwerk, wo du halt Daten drauf hast, weil du kannst sie dann mit einer Micro SD-Karte reinstecken und dann ist sie immer dabei. Das werde ich dann wahrscheinlich, würde ich dann vermissen. Und dann muss man eine entsprechend größere SSD kaufen, was entsprechend mehr kostet als dieses Ding.
Ich sehe den Punkt mit dieser Nifty-Drive, das war ganz nifty. Aber ich denke, dass dieser Port bei den allermeisten Leuten ohnehin einfach nur ein Staubfänger war.
Ja, bei meinen anderen Geräten ist das auch so.
Ich habe den noch nie benutzt, hier an dem Gerät in zwei Jahren nicht.
Deswegen habe ich das Nifty ja auch gekauft, weil der Port ist ansonsten halt leer. Also kann man auch so ein Ding reinstecken. Fertig.
Jetzt nicht vermissen. Tastatur. Hat jemand von euch auf der neuen Tastatur schon mal rumgetippt?
Also ich war, wie gesagt, am Montag war ich im Apple Store, habe dann zu meiner Verwunderung doch von den, mit der kompletten Tastatur, von den 13 Zoll mit der kompletten Tastatur standen da vier Stück rum. Und dann habe ich angefangen da mal zu tippen. Da war leider kein Xcode drauf, also konnte ich nicht so richtig mal tippen, wie ich sonst so tippe, aber habe da in der Notizen-App da mal irgendwie so ein bisschen Code geschrieben und habe das gleiche dann nochmal bei MacBook One gemacht und konnte keinen Unterschied feststellen. Für mich war haptisch kein Unterschied zwischen der MacBook One-Tastatur und der neuen Tastatur, obwohl das angeblich die Butterfly-Dinger da irgendwie eine neue Generation sind.
Sie haben da nochmal so einen kleinen Metalldom drunter gemacht, um den den Andruck anders zu machen. Und ich habe auch gelesen, dass die Tastenkappen selber nochmal mehr so nach außen gewirkt sind und mehr etwas scharfkantiger Rückmelden, wo sie anfangen und aufhören.
Also ich hatte das ein bisschen auch das Gefühl, dass sie in so einer Art Silent-Update auch bei dem MacBook One die Tastatur nochmal nachträglich geändert haben, weil ich weiß, dass ein ehemaliger Kollege von mir, der hat sich das Ding quasi am Tag eins bestellt und geholt und es fühlte sich extrem an wie, na so Mikro-Tasten, so Competition Pro, Feuer, Mikro-Tasten. So fühlte es sich das an. Das hatte so überhaupt keinen Hub, aber dafür einen extrem starken Druckpunkt. Und dieser extrem starke Druckpunkt ist halt weg. Jetzt auch bei MacBook One. Also, keine Ahnung, vielleicht ist meine Erinnerung auch falsch. Aber irgendwie, also man kann damit tippen und ich glaube, man würde sich auch gewöhnen daran. Aber so im, wenn man jetzt eine externe Tastatur und die Tastatur wechselweise benutzt, dann wird's glaub ich schwierig.
Okay, also glaub ich, kann man festhalten.
Und sie haben natürlich diese bekloppten Cursor-Tasten.
Das ist wirklich...
Die bekloppten Cursor-Tasten.
Die bekloppten Cursor-Tasten, das verzeih ich ihnen nicht.
Man kann seine Finger nicht mehr da reinlegen.
Man kann seine Finger, man spürt einfach nicht, wo man ist.
Ich leg mein Zeigefinger und wie heißt der hier eigentlich?
Du kannst da blind cursern.
Ja, das ist...
Und was ist jetzt für die neuen?
Da sind diese hier große Tasten.
und Linkstasten sind so groß, wie die Alttaste daneben. Genau.
Genau, das ist richtig scheiße. Das würde ich auch sagen, das ist so der erste Punkt, wo ich sagen muss, das ist nicht gut.
Aber hast du auch schon mal benutzt für länger? Oder ist das wieder nur diese bestimmten fünf Phasen hier, wo man halt das scheiße findet, weil man es noch nicht kennt? Und wenn man es dann hat, ist wieder alles ganz okay.
Für länger habe ich es nicht benutzt. Ich weiß nicht, ob man sich dran gewöhnt. Du hast jetzt bei der alten Tastatur, hast du halt zwischen den Hoch- und Unterkörsertasten, hast du halt auch so diese extra große Lücke. Und die hast du halt bei den neuen auch nicht mehr. Ich weiß nicht, ob man sich dran gewöhnt.
Das ist nicht so eine Lücke, sondern schön angerundet, damit man da mit hin und her fährt.
Schräg.
Damit du merkst, wo du bist, damit du besser spüren kannst, ob du jetzt...
Also ich hab hier dieses...
Wenn ich unten oder oben bin, wo ich will, dann brauch ich ja die Lücke nicht. Aber das ist besser zum rüberrutschen, wenn das so ist.
Das war bei der neuen Tastatur für mich auch schlechter.
Also dieses Magic Keyboard, dieses Magic... Ja, dieses Ding, diese externe Bluetooth-Tastatur, die man mithilfe eines Lightning-Kabels sparen kann. So wie dieses Ding. Ja, ja, die ist ja auch sehr ähnlich dazu. Und da sind auch diese Kasa-Tasten drauf. Und das macht mich jedes Mal kirre.
Also ich muss sagen, tatsächlich bis gerade hab ich nie darüber nachgedacht, hier über die Kasa-Tasten. Aber jetzt, wo ihr es gesagt habt, ich benutze die halt auch einfach blind ohnehin.
Das geht halt mit den anderen nicht.
Ja, aber plötzlich blind und packst deine Finger genau...
Ja, ja, genau. Also ich will nicht so... Also ich muss da gar nicht hingucken.
Ja, und Johnny Alph hat sich das angeschaut und dann gesagt, das ist ja voll asymmetrisch.
Wahrscheinlich, wenn der überhaupt noch irgendwas macht.
Ich mein, das ist wirklich Design von der Optik her.
Aber ihr habt alle noch gar nicht länger benutzt.
Kann man Apple nicht verklagen irgendwie? Und sie gerichtlich zwingen dazu.
Was halt fehlt, ist halt so ein Korrektiv, das da sagt, so Leute, ich kann diese Tastatur nicht benutzen, zurück ans Reisbrett. Sondern die schweben alle in ihrer, das ist alles so schön, Filter-Bubble.
Also im Chat, mein Cucumber-Sum meint, er hätte das 12 Zoll MacBook und die neue Tastatur am iMac seit einem Jahr, man gewöhnt sich nicht dran. Ich kann mir das auch ehrlich gesagt nicht vorstellen. Und guck mal hier, schönes Foto von der alten IBM-Tastatur und auch da war halt das Cursor-Layout, das so hoch runter.
Das war schon immer so.
Das umgekehrte T, das war immer so, ja.
Ja, und das umgekehrte T haben sie halt jetzt gekillt. Und das ist so der erste Punkt, wo ich sage, kann man das noch ein paar Jahre rauszögern, zumindest so?
Kannst du da in Deutschland 64er?
Was du machen musst, was du machen musst, du musst diese Tastatur ausbauen, die beiden Tasten durchsägen in der Hälfte, wieder einbauen und dann so in den Apple Store gehen. Oder am besten zu Johnny Eif zur Gartenparty das aufklappen und sagen, ja, ich musste die Tasten fixen, das ging nicht.
Dem schicke ich einen Gruselclown auf seine Gartenparty.
Ja, ich glaube, das wäre der Gruselclown dann.
Weißt du, was ich gerade eben gemacht habe? Ich hatte gerade eben das Foto... Weißt du, was ich gemacht habe, um dieses Foto zu entfernen? Intuitiv? Ich habe nicht geguckt, ob da irgendwo ein X ist auf diesem Bildschirm. Ich habe einfach fucking Escape gedrückt.
Genau, das Johnny Ives Next One of a Kind Design Project ist der Christmas Tree. Weißt du, soweit ist es jetzt.
Sie designen einen Weihnachtsbaum?
Nein, er, er. Designt so als Hobbyprojekt einen Weihnachtsbaum.
Er und sein Mark Newsen, sein Buddy da, sein Watch-Buddy.
Und der hat mehrere Farben, das glaube ich ja nicht.
Das ist ja ein Foto von vorher. Also, let's talk about Escape, baby. Man wird sehen. Ist ein Leben ohne Escape möglich, aber sinnlos?
Ich bin ja jetzt immer noch, also ich komme ja immer noch über die Cursor-Tasten nicht so richtig hinweg. Das war mir jetzt, das war...
Eigentlich wollte Pavel ja den Pro-Apple-Typen spielen, aber jetzt hat er sich anders über den Kursor gemacht.
Er ist jetzt rausgecursert worden.
Ja, also das muss ich mir jetzt noch... Ich meine, ich hatte ja tatsächlich schon hier bei den... Ich hatte ja schon, als sie angefangen hatten, das RAM-Fest einzulöten und die Platten da fest anzulöten. Habe ich halt schon überlegt. Ich meine, das Problem ist ja, es gibt für mich keine Alternative. Also wenn du für iOS entwickelst, und so kommst du halt... Geht halt nicht.
Na gut, man könnte Android lernen.
Du musst ja beides. iOS und Android musst du ja beides machen, normalerweise bei den meisten Sachen.
Auf Mac geht halt beides.
Ja, genau. Das heißt, es gibt leider keine Alternative. Sonst hat man, weiß ich nicht, sonst kann man eine Milliarde Geräte, die draußen sind, von Apple, mobile irgendwie nicht.
Du hast natürlich recht, das war ja auch kein ernst gemeintes Vorschlag.
Nicht ernst gemeinte Vorschläge in dieser Sendung?
Nein, aber, nichtsdestotrotz, damals hatte ich schon überlegt, ob es nicht die Möglichkeit gäbe, weil es gibt mit Sicherheit tausende, wenn nicht gar zigtausende professioneller Nutzer, die sich nahezu jeden beliebigen Preis wahrscheinlich bereit wären zu zahlen für ein Gerät, für ein MacBook, das halt bestimmte Features hat, wie z.B. vernünftige Cursor-Tasten oder einen größeren Bildschirm. Bei mir war es damals der Wegfall von dem 17 Zoll, wobei ich sagen muss, dass der 15 Zoll Retina habe ich mich mit angefreundet. Das ist auch okay. Aber dann hatte ich halt überlegt, ob man nicht irgendwie so eine Kleinserie fertig, also im Prinzip halt MacBooks kauft, aber die die Elektronik da rausnimmt und dann halt in ein eigenes Design wieder einbaut.
Genau. Custom-Design mit korrekten Körsertasten.
Eskäptaste für dich, HDMI-Port für dich. Dennis, was hättest du?
Ja, und ich meine, guck dir mal die, wir sehen hier gerade ein Bild von der amerikanischen Tastatur, schau mal auf deine deutsche Tastatur, da hast du eine amerikanische Tastatur. Diese Taste da links oben.
Die ist an der falschen Stelle. Die Escape-Taste, die ist in der Ecke.
Nein, ich meine die Taste links oben.
Diese Schnattel?
Die neben der 1. Care oder Grad auf der deutschen Tastatur. Ein Akzent und Tilde auf der amerikanischen Tastatur. Jetzt würde ich ja nicht sagen, dass dieser Backtick unwichtig wäre in Unix-Country, aber den kann man ja auch nochmal woanders hinmappen. Ja, aber dann hab ich ja keinen Caps Lock mehr.
Ja, okay, aber Caps Lock, Leute, wirklich. 95 Prozent der Fälle, wo ich Caps Lock drücke, nein, 99,5 Prozent der Fälle, wo ich Caps Lock drücke, tue ich das ungewollt.
Und andere Fälle gibt's nicht.
Also von mir aus könnte die ganze Taste da verschwinden.
Da gibt's ja auch lange Debatten im Netz über irgendwie den Tod der Caps Lock-Taste und so.
Ich schreibe keinen Cobol-Code. Wozu brauche ich Caps Lock?
Also Caps Lock ist tatsächlich komplett überflüssig.
Ich benutze Caps Lock täglich, häufig, gezielt, gerne. Und ich würde sehr, sehr, sehr ungern auf Caps Lock.
Ich habe Caps Lock in den letzten 20 Jahren nicht einmal benutzt, also absichtlich.
Ganz ehrlich, unter iOS...
Gerade auf dem Mac, der einzigen Computer, wo Caps Lock richtig funktioniert.
Wieso denn? Ach so, weil er nur die Buchstaben Caps Lock tiert? Genau.
Bei Windows ist es ja ein Shift-Lock, auf dem Mac ist es ein Caps-Lock.
Ich hätte ja gerne ein Caps-Lock für iOS.
Guck mal, wenn ich eine Abkürzung in einem Text schreibe, PCMCIA, drückst du dann auf Shift und drückst dann sechs Buchstaben hintereinander.
Ich hab jeden Finger das da.
Ich schreibe beidhändig Leute. Ich mach Klapp Caps Lock mit dem kleinen Finger, schreibe PCMCIA und fertig. So mach ich das.
People can't memorize computer industry acronyms.
Richtig. Was ich mich jetzt allerdings noch...
Also Caps Lock gegen Escape austauschen?
Was ich mich jetzt frage, wo ich das gerade sehe, was macht denn die FN-Taste da unten links? Ja, ja, aber...
Die schaltet, die schaltet...
Wir sind noch nicht beim Touchbar. Lass uns noch mal kurz jetzt erstmal... Wir reden noch über das, was verloren gegangen ist. So, und bei dem derzeit kaufbaren MacBook Pro 13 Zoll ist ja alles noch gut, ja. Auch wenn sie...
Also du meinst jetzt die neue Version mit der vollen Tastatur.
Genau, mit der vollen Tastatur. Also man kann noch einen MacBook Pro kaufen und in gewisser Hinsicht ist das jetzt verfügbare MacBook Pro, also dieses kleinste MacBook Pro.
Das Zweiport, nennen wir es mal so.
Das ist ein Top, genau, das MacBook 2 ist eigentlich ein super Angebot von Apple das MacBook Air 13 Zoll abzudösen. Es ist kleiner als das 13 Zoll, es ist schneller als das 13 Zoll, es hat einen besseren Bildschirm, es hat zwei Ports und nicht ein Port wie das One und von daher benutzbar, also das hat genug Flexibilität, es hat ein viel größeres Touchpad, also es ist dem MacBook Air 13 in jeder Hinsicht überlegen. Ich habe ja einen 11er, und das 11er haben sie jetzt gekillt und es ist halt schwerer als das 11er. Aber es hat immerhin noch eine richtige Tastatur. Das heißt, es gibt zumindest noch so einen normalen Computer und man müsste halt auf die Cursor-Tasten verzichten. Ja, das ist eigentlich alles.
Aber die Escape-Taste ist schön groß, was?
Die Escape-Taste ist richtig groß. Ich finde das auch sehr angemessen, weil die Escape-Taste, ich meine mal ehrlich, ist die Escape-Taste ein Anachronismus?
Also ich benutze die ziemlich oft. Ja, also nicht nur wie AI, sondern auch verlassen von Vollscreen-Modus zum Beispiel.
So das Intuitive, wenn man irgendwo, ich will raus hier, Escape.
Und die ist auch an einer sehr praktischen Stelle leicht erreichbar. Und das ist halt das, was mich jetzt gerade so ein bisschen irritiert an diesem Bild da. Da ist nämlich nicht nur, dass das halt eine virtuelle Taste ist, sondern die scheint auch noch an einer falschen Stelle zu sein. Auf jeden Fall nicht ganz links.
Das Problem ist, dass ganz rechts ist ja der Fingerprint-Sensor. Das heißt, Johnny hat wahrscheinlich gesagt, das muss symmetrisch sein, also lassen wir da so und so viele Pixel weg. So sieht's aus.
Kann aber sein, dass die trotzdem reagieren, nur optisch nicht angezeigt werden.
Das kann natürlich sein.
Gut, also wir müssen jetzt schon zu der Touchbar kommen, weil wenn wir über die Tastatur reden...
Da sind wir denn schon fertig über die Escape-Taste? Weil ich muss sagen, ich dachte erst so, Escape-Taste, habt ihr keine anderen Probleme? Und dann hatte irgendjemand so ein Bild gepostet, wo er so ein Stück Papier auf die Escape-Taste geklebt hat, so nach der Art, jetzt schauen wir mal, ob wir die tatsächlich tippen. Da hab ich das auch gemacht, weil ich wollte wissen, drücke ich eigentlich auf die Escape-Taste, so ein Stück Papier auf die Escape-Taste geklebt.
Was soll das bringen?
Du merkst, wenn du sie benutzt, weil sie plötzlich anders ist.
Oder Klebstoff drauf machen oder Honig drauf.
Nein, einfach von so einem Post-it oben so ein Stück abschneiden, das ist so zusammenkleben, dass es so wie so ein Ding hoch steht.
Und?
Hat ungefähr 30 Sekunden gedauert, dann hab ich auf die Taste gedrückt und dachte mir, oha, ich dachte, du benutzt die nicht. Aber es ist nämlich so, die Code-Autovervollständigung von Xcode wird mit der Escape-Taste getriggert.
Nein.
Das heißt, du tippst, drückst die Escape-Taste. Tipps drei Buchstaben, drückst die Escape-Taste. Gehst mit dem Cursor rauf und runter oder tippst noch ein paar mehr, drückst. Weiter, Escape-Taste. Also ich war mir absolut nicht im Klaren darüber, dass ich diese Escape-Taste total oft drücke. Also mehr als die Tab-Taste zum Beispiel. Ja, okay, die Tab-Taste auch relativ häufig, weil du ja Code einrückst.
Die Tab-Taste benutze ich wahrscheinlich seltener als die Escape-Taste.
Die Tab-Taste, klar, zum Einrücken natürlich beim Codeschreiben.
Die Tab-Taste brauchst du schon für den App-Switcher. Beides ist vergessen.
Ja, stimmt.
Obwohl, die benutzt eh keiner.
Ja, also wenn es mich zu sehr nerven wird bei dem neuen Gerät, dann wäre ich mir die Escape-Taste hier denn auf die Carrot.
Nee, du kannst sie auf Caps Lock legen. Ist doch schon drin, geht schon mit Sierra, kannst sie jetzt schon probieren, ob es toll ist.
Also wenn du wirklich zu so Leuten gehörst, die die Caps Lock-Taste nicht benutzen, dann hast du ja kein Problem. Aber ich benutze halt alle Tasten. Es gibt keine Tasse, die ich nicht nutze. Außer diese komischen Medien, komischen...
Doch hier, Caps Lock und dann kannst du der Escape da drauf legen.
Diese Abübersichtstaste, F4 benutze ich.
Oder du kannst auch sagen, no action, wenn dich die Caps Lock stört. Das war ja vor Jahren schon mal unser Tipp, dass man die einfach mal ausmacht.
Gute Idee, mach ich gleich mal.
Kurze Zeit später kam dann Apple mit dieser Verzögerung, dass die Caps Lock nicht mehr sofort angeht, sondern dass man sie ein bisschen länger festhalten muss, damit diese Unfall Caps Lock aktiviert... Ja, das war ja früher nicht so. Das ist jetzt so. Du musst schon so ein bisschen länger festhalten, damit sie angeht. So ganz kurz, dann geht sie nicht an.
Hä, wo stelle ich das ein?
System Preferences, Keyboard und dann unten rechts Modifier Keys.
ah, Sondertasten. Sondertasten.
Stimmt, das ist ja auch krass.
Was?
Wenn du die nur ganz kurz, also die Caps Lock, wenn du die nur ganz kurz tippst, dann geht sie nicht an. Dann geht sie nicht an.
Das ist Absicht. Das ist......bei Design.
Übrigens wie bei einer richtigen Schreibmaschine auch.
Ja, aber dann diskutieren wir jetzt nicht über Tasten, wenn wir über richtige Tasten, richtige Schreibmaschinen sprechen.
Ich hab übrigens die, vorhin noch, die IBM Tastatur, die du vorhin angezeigt hattest, die nutze ich tatsächlich jeden Tag. Ich hab die heute, ich hab halt in einem der Rechner jetzt an dem aktuellen, nehmen wir halt auch, ja, mit den fetten Grafikkarten, da hab ich aber halt diese Tastatur dran.
Das ist diese, ich schiebe die Taste nach unten, dann schiebe ich sie noch ein bisschen mehr, dann macht sie rack, lack und dann bist du unten angekommen.
Die ist halt laut, so das stimmt schon, also beim Tippen, aber das ist halt...
Ich hab auch das Gefühl, das ist so Fingerworkout, weil die sich so schwer drücken lässt.
Das ist schon eine geniale Tastatur, diese IBM-Tastatur.
Der Panzer unter den Tastatoren.
I am not convinced.
Ich hab mir irgendwann vor zehn Jahren noch mal vier Stück davon hingelegt.
Noch so mit diesem alten Stecker auch?
Ja, also mit dem DIN-Stecker. Nein, die haben schon PS2-Stecker, die ich habe. Aber so von der Mechanik her und so alles, also schön solide Metallgehäuse.
Die will man übrigens nicht auseinanderbauen und wieder zusammenbauen, diese Tastatur. Das ist unmöglich.
Aber das ist eine von denen, die man in die Spielmaschine tun kann, ohne dass es was tut.
Das weiß ich nicht. Die ist eigentlich auch so groß.
Das Problem ist wirklich, wenn du mit mehreren Leuten in einem Raum mit solchen Tastaturen arbeitest.
Für mich war das der Sound auf Musik. In den 80ern gehörte das einfach zum Sport. Da war die Tastatur noch das geringste Problem. Da war es noch von so lauten Festplatten und Lüftern umgeben.
Diskettenlaufwerke waren damals auch noch laut.
Ja, aber auch vor allem Festplatten.
Ja, oder halt wie gesagt, ich nenne sowas ja Feedback. Da wusste ich immer, wenn ich da mach was, da konnte man am Sound schon erkennen, ist das jetzt okay oder ist das jetzt nicht so? So, alles klar, das hört sich sehr gleichmäßig an, gut, das läuft, das läuft.
Da haben sie uns noch für Zauberer gehalten. So, hoi, kannst du dir mal mein Laptop angucken? Ich hab da ein Problem.
Kurz hingehört? Ja, nee, Platte im Arsch.
Ja, ne, also Platte ist nicht kaputt, aber dein Fallsystem solltest du mal runter und wieder rauf machen, dann läuft das wieder.
Ein Kollege von mir, der hatte ja irgendwie dann seine eigene externe Tastatur dabei, sich mitgebracht in die Firma, er wollte unbedingt die eine Tastatur haben. Und weil sie ihm nicht so richtig gefallen hat, hat er sie komplett, also alle Tasten orange, so mit Revell, Modellbau, Lack, alle Tasten orange gemacht. Also ohne Beschriftung, komplett.
Also schwarzes Gehäuse, orange Tasten.
Damit sich ihm keiner mehr klaut, ja.
Ja, was machen wir jetzt mit dem Escape? Also ich meine, wenn man jetzt diesen Touchbar haben will, dann muss man sich entscheiden. Wir können ja mal gucken. Also haben wir jetzt eigentlich die Liste durch, was wir alles nicht mehr haben. Also wir haben die gute Tastatur nicht mehr. Und wir haben eine neue mit fragwürdigen Cursor-Layout. Also das finde ich auch persönlich fast noch schlimmer als diese Escape-Nummer.
Und ohne Eurovision Song Contest hast du.
Ja, genau. So, was ist neu ist, haben wir eigentlich schon alles angesprochen.
Nicht alles, aber vieles.
Wir haben jetzt überall Thunderbolt 3. Das ist eine super Entwicklung. 40 Gigabit auf so einem kleinen Stecker ist einfach grandios. Und dass man darüber einfach alles anschließen kann, ist auch grandios.
Aber mal ganz ehrlich, ich habe Thunderbolt 2 schon nicht ausgenutzt, weil ich nie ein Gerät hatte, was das gesprochen hat, weil die waren immer so teuer.
5K-Bildschirm halt.
Ja gut, habe ich jetzt auch immer noch keinen.
Ja, aber jetzt will man ja auch einen haben. Also jetzt ist das sozusagen genau das.
Ja, aber von irgendeiner Firma, wo ich mich darauf verlassen kann, dass ich keinen Schrott kriege. Und die gibt es momentan nicht.
Apple, sagt man, soll jetzt LG kaufen.
Ich habe Thunderbolt auch noch für nichts benutzt. Ich schenke da mal meinen Mini-Display-Portstecker rein und das war's.
Ich habe da mein Internet dran.
Ich habe ja Ethernet.
Ja, okay. Ja. Aber das ist jetzt auch wieder nur so ein Rumgedongel.
Ja, Ethernet, Firewire.
Ja, Firewire habe ich auch.
Das ist halt ein schneller Port gewesen. Mit Thunderbolt 2 ist er halt doppelt so schnell. Mit Thunderbolt 3 ist er nochmal doppelt so schnell.
Nein, aber ich hatte nie ein dediziertes Thunderbolt-Gerät. Klar, die Adapter-Stecker.
Aber dass das praktisch ist, muss man ja wohl nicht sagen. Also wenn du so ein externes Plattengehäuse hast.
So ein Pegasus oder wie die heißen.
So was halt. Ich meine, sowas ist ja jetzt nicht vollkommen von der Hand zu weisen, dass man sowas vielleicht mal gebrauchen könnte. Dafür ist es halt super.
Zumindest die Pro User.
Ja oder halt eben was wir eben auch schon hatten. Externe GPU-Karten, überhaupt so PCI-Karten, Gehäuse.
Ich meinte nur, also ich selber hab's halt nie gemacht. Hab ich verstanden. Also deswegen ist jetzt alles Thunderbolt 3.
Ja gut, aber du hast halt dann, ja, ist ja auch egal. Auf jeden Fall große Bildschirme anschließen, finde ich, ist einfach schon mal eine top Anwendung dafür.
Vor allem, wenn der Bildschirm dann gleich Ethernet, USB und weiß nicht, was da drin hat.
Ja, und wir werden demnächst dann auch vielleicht 10 Gigabit Ethernet nochmal willkommen heißen, who knows.
Ja, also Vorteil ist sicherlich, dass sich das Thunderbolt 3 wahrscheinlich nicht, also generell durchsetzen wird. So wie ich das sehe, haben die meisten aktuellen auch non-Apple-Laptops jetzt auch Thunderbolt 3. Und deswegen kann man eigentlich erwarten, dass es da jetzt auch, was weiß ich, Peripherie halt, Festplatten, Gehäuse, den sie eh alle reinbauen müssen. Und das ist sicherlich gut. Bisher war es halt so, war Apple eigentlich mit Thunderbolt so ein bisschen alleine, auch wenn es eigentlich eine Intel-Geschichte war.
Ja, das war so Firewire für Fortgeschrittene.
So wie früher USB, da waren die am Anfang auch erstmal alleine.
Ja, aber USB ist relativ schnell in einen breiten Markt gekommen. Aber Firewire hat halt nie groß bei PCs gezündet. Und Thunderbolt 1.2 hat auch nie groß bei PC gezündet.
Was daran gelegen hat, dass alle mit USB weiter marschiert sind. Und dann kam USB 3.0 und das war schnell genug. Und jetzt haben wir auch 5 Gigabit.
Aber da ist die Argumentation von Pavel schon richtig. Also man wird jetzt endlich auch mal Thunderbolt in der Breite sehen. Und dann wären die entsprechenden Peripherien vielleicht auch ein bisschen günstiger.
Aber weil es jetzt der selbe Stecker ist, das ist der Schlüssel zum Erfolg. Gar nicht mal, dass das Ding schneller ist. Einfach weil man es jetzt einfach noch...
Ja, das wird sicherlich auch noch Geburtswehen geben.
Keinen weiteren Port. Lustigerweise setzt es sich auch bei PCs durch, weil sie keinen weiteren Port machen müssen, obwohl sie ja sowieso schon so gerne immer so viele unterschiedliche haben.
Schweizer Käseeffekt, ne?
Also die Anwendungen sind sicherlich vielfältig. Wo Thunderbolt 3 auch total sinnvoll ist, ist halt einfach in dieser Docking-Funktionalität. Also selbst wenn du nicht für eine einzige Schnittstelle diese Geschwindigkeit brauchst, ist es halt einfach möglich jetzt über dieses eine Kabel, du kannst halt da 10 Gigabit Ethernet und du kannst da nochmal HDMI und nochmal...
Das bestreite ich alles gar nicht. Aber auch da wieder auf das Argument von Pavel verweisen, es gab vorher Thunderbolt Docks, die waren nur alle irgendwie in einer Preis-Range, dass du gleich den 27 Zoll-Monitor von Apple mit dazu kaufen konntest.
Das ändert sich jetzt auch schon gerade.
Und wenn sich das ändert, dann wäre das für mich der wesentliche Fortschritt davon. Nicht, dass es jetzt doppelt so schnell ist wie Thunderbolt 2, weil das war mir auch nicht so langsam.
Richtig.
Ja.
Lautsprecher sind laut steht hier. Lautsprecher sind laut. Das hab ich nicht ausprobiert im Apple Store, hätte ich vielleicht mal tun sollen.
Ja, das hab ich nur gehört, dass dem wohl auch wirklich so sei. Also sie haben da wohl kräftig dran gearbeitet, auch mehr Bass zu haben, sodass sie halt nicht mehr so schäpprig klingen, wie man das von Lautsprechern in Laptops normalerweise. Ich kenn...
Schön fand ich den iFixit Teardown, wo sie halt dann auch bemerkt haben, ja, die Lautsprecher sind jetzt auch mit gummiummantelten Schrauben angebracht, damit nichts scheppert. Die scheinen also tatsächlich so laut zu sein, dass Apple sich genötigt sah, da gummiummantelte, vibrationshemmende Schrauben einzusetzen.
Das ist schon mal ein gutes Zeichen.
Ansonsten, naja, solange man sie nicht wirklich mal gehört hat, kann ich nichts zu sagen.
Nee, finde ich aber gut, dass sie das machen, dass das einfach auch so etwas da eine Rolle spielt, wenn auch in so einem kompakten Gehäuse, aber man hat ja auch von so externen Lautsprechern, die jetzt nicht durch Größe beeindruckt haben, teilweise sehr viel Besseres gehört, als aus dem Laptop rauskam. Und von daher war da auf jeden Fall was zu holen.
So, RAM.
Na, da hat sich ja nichts geändert. Also zumindest nichts von der Größe her.
Genau, deswegen müssen wir darüber reden.
Ja, also erstens, genau, also die 16 Gigabyte fand ich enttäuschend nicht, weil 16 Gigabyte im Moment nicht ausreicht. Ich meine, ich hab jetzt auch 16 Gigabyte und hab jetzt nicht das Gefühl, dass ich irgendwie Probleme hab mit zu wenig RAM. Das Ding ist nur, dass man halt bei einem Gerät, was nicht erweiterbar ist, kauft man die RAM-Ausstattung nicht für den Bedarf von heute, sondern eigentlich für den Bedarf von in drei oder vier Jahren will man halt immer noch genug RAM haben. Und wenn heute 16 Gigabyte reichen, wird es in drei oder vier Jahren halt knapp. Beziehungsweise, wenn ich es nicht aufrüsten kann, begrenzt halt die RAM-Größe einfach die Lebensdauer oder die Nutzbarkeitsdauer dieses Geräts. Und ich hatte mich ja gefragt im Vorfeld, ob es nicht auch Build-to-Order-Geräte gibt, die halt mehr RAM haben. Irgendjemand meinte hier, nee, wobei die CPU selbst bis zu 64 GB RAM unterstützt. Also an der CPU?
Ja, aber nur von dem Low-Power-RAM halt nur 16. Das ist der eigentliche Punkt, weil es gibt da irgendwie Low-Power-RAM und dann gibt es noch anderes. Und von dem Low-Power-RAM werden aber nur 16 GB unterstützt.
Richtig, also der Memory-Controller ist an der Stelle die Limitierung. Sie hätten einen anderen Memory-Controller nehmen müssen, der dann mit diesem Low-Power-RAM DDR4 arbeitet. Aber da war ihre Aussage, dieser Controller oder diese Gattung von Controllern hätte einen deutlich höheren Stromverbrauch mit sich gebracht, der bei ihrer Bewertung der Situation hinten drüber gefallen ist.
Und das ist wohl der Grund, warum man relativ viel von den Konkurrenzgeräten auch genau mit dieser Grenze sieht.
Es ist kein Apple-Problem, sondern es ist einfach derzeit ein portable-device-Problem.
Es ist trotzdem traurig, dass ich zu Hause noch dieses MacBook Pro von Ende 2007 habe. Dieses Gerät, wo sie das Mainboard getauscht haben. Ich glaube Ende 2007.
Da hast du doch auch, oder?
2011. Dann war es 2009. Auf jeden Fall, da sind halt auch 16 Gig drin. Jetzt ist das Teil irgendwie sieben Jahre alt.
In welchem Ding?
Mein letztes Gerät. Das 2009er MacBook Pro 15 Zoll.
Das hatte schon 16 Gigabyte.
Da habe ich 16 Gigabyte drin in dem Gerät. Jetzt habe ich hier dieses 2013 Zoll. Da gingen halt auch nur 16 Gigabyte rein. Jetzt kommen die neuen Geräte, da gehen auch wieder nur 16 Gigabyte rein. Das ist irgendwie so täglich größt das RAM-Mummeltier.
Ich habe in meinem Jahr nur acht. Ich glaube, ich nutze die acht schon nicht vollkommen aus.
Es ist halt am Ende des Tages ein portables Gerät.
Ja, aber da steht Pro drauf. Ja, aber Speicher, das macht man sich halt... Also 16 Gigabyte RAM sind halt auch einfach mal weitere 16 Gigabyte an Bits, die einfach Strombedarf haben, also die zusätzlich noch mit Strom befüttert werden müssen. Den Einwand lass ich nicht gelten, da steht Pro drauf. Wenn sie es nur MacBook nennen würden, da hätte ich kein Problem mit. Aber da steht Pro drauf.
Es gibt ja diese Technologie offensichtlich am Markt nicht. Dann hätten sie halt sagen müssen, dann hat zwei Stunden weniger Akku laufen.
Gibt es ja ganz viele Kommentare, wo die sagen, das hätten sie. Da einer meint, er würde locker, dann soll halt Apple ein bisschen machen und tun und so weiter. Und er würde auch locker ein doppelt so schweres Laptop nehmen. Kannst du dich erinnern, 3400 hieß das Ding damals, eine dreieinhalb Kilo. Ich will das nicht mehr haben.
Also es kommt wirklich darauf an, was du damit machen willst. Das, was du da hast, ist das alte 15 Zoll, das wiegt halt zweieinhalb Kilo. Ja, du hast dem dem dem 17 Zoll nachgetrauert, das hat dreieinhalb Kilo gewogen. Ich weiß, ich hatte damals im Job, hatte ich mal so ein Teil, hab das dann immer mit nach Hause geschleppt und dachte mir so, Scheiße, was tust du hier eigentlich? Und wieso habt ihr mir diese Kacke bestellt? Ich will keinen Monitor mit mir rumschleppen.
Dein zählt jetzt hier, Pavel, 2,1 Kilo circa.
Ja, also es war jedenfalls ein deutlicher Unterschied. Wobei ich halt hier sowieso in meiner Rucksack, den ich immer mit mir führe, hab ich sowieso immer alles drin. Da sind halt noch irgendwie vier Telefone drin und noch irgendwie extra Akkus und noch ein internationaler Adapter.
Tim, eigentlich müsst ihr jetzt den Otto Walke Spot einblenden, wo er mit dieser Uhr irgendwie auf die Bühne kommt und meint, was sie für 100 geile 1000 Features hat und so.
Plus natürlich den Geigerzähler, der nicht gehen darf.
Was, du hast einen Geigerzähler dabei?
Ich mein, wenn du den nicht immer dabei hast, bringt's ja nichts, wenn du... Der läuft jetzt schon mit einer Batterie seit acht Jahren oder so ist immer an.
Ernsthaft? Kannst du mal kurz messen, wie viel Radioaktivität hier im Raum ist?
Keine.
Vernachläsigbar.
Nee, nee, nee, ist relativ wenig. Das sind jetzt zwischen 0,2 und 0,3 Mikrosiwatt pro Stunde, also normale Hintergrundrauschen, was man halt... Also keine erhöhte Radioaktivität hier im Raum.
Großartig.
Wir haben das auch immer bei den Vorstandssitzungen, so als ich noch im Piratenvorstand war, gehörte halt die Radioaktivitätsmessung auch immer zu Beginn der Vorstandssitzung. Halt Kassenstand und sagen, wo die ganzen Verstrahlten herkommen.
Ja, okay, dann macht's Sinn. Nein, aber dein Einwand mit den 16 Gig ist richtig, aber ich glaube, dass mein Einwand mit den 16 Gig auch richtig ist. Und natürlich will ich nicht wieder anfangen, zweieinhalb Kilo rumzuschleppen. Das ist irgendwie klar. Die zwei Kilo von dem derzeit gerade nicht mehr aktuellen 15 Zoll, ja.
Ja, ich kann auch sagen, also warum? Ich hab halt sehr häufig Xcode und IntelliJ offen. Das ist halt alleine schon und IntelliJ halt dann mit einem großen Projekt oder so. Dann laufen dann manchmal noch irgendwelche Datenbanken im Hintergrund, zum testen, was weiß ich, dann läuft dann halt noch eine MongoDB drauf.
Oder wenn du einen Docker aufmachst.
Oder Docker und genau, wenn ich dann noch eine virtuelle Maschine laufen hab, noch irgendwie zwei, drei andere Betriebssysteme, so dann reichen mir 16 Gigabyte einfach nicht. Das ist halt dann einfach, ja, also ich bin, will sagen, ich bin halt dann schon eigentlich limitiert.
Zu deiner Beruhigung, die Gerüchteküche geht ja schon so weit, dass es im nächsten Frühjahr schon zu Updates kommen könnte, wo dann tatsächlich das 16 Gigabyte-Limit auch fällt. Also Gerüchteküche kann sein, kann nicht sein. Ich mein, irgendwann wird es soweit sein. Naja klar, ich muss jetzt eh noch so lange warten, bis ich die Cursor-Tasten wieder draufmache.
Also in den neuen Geräten ist ja diese Skylake-Architektur drin, oder? Hab ich das richtig verstanden? Genau. Und der Nachfolger, dieser Cabylake, den gibt es halt einfach noch nicht in den richtigen Varianten. Ja, aber das ist dann der Nachfolger und ich glaube, der kann auch ein bisschen mehr von dem LD-Ram.
Ja, da geht es sogar schon wieder um den Nachfolger von dem Nachfolger. Da gibt es irgendwie Coffee Lake und keine Ahnung. Ja, ne, ist so, also ich blicke da auch nicht so richtig durch bei der ganzen Geschichte, aber dieses Cabylake, das war jetzt nicht so der große Bringer.
Ja, das habe ich nämlich auch gelesen, dass Cabylake selber jetzt auch nicht der Bringer ist, aber was dann danach kommt.
Ja, natürlich, next version will fix it. Das werden wir dann sehen. Deutlich schlechter wird es halt nicht. Die Frage ist halt nur, wie viel besser und wie schnell.
Die Frage ist, weil wenn man nicht genug RAM hat, wird ja wie früher, nicht virtual, virtual memory, wird ja ausgelagert, was halt so eine SSD, die mit 3,3 GB die Sekunde wieder einlädt, ich meine, da sind deine weiteren 16 GB, die dir fehlen, hätte der theoretisch in fünf Sekunden wieder drin und du musst ja nicht komplette 16 GB reinladen, sondern immer nur kleine Teilbereiche und du nutzt ja auch nicht den gesamten Speicher komplett gleichzeitig, weil es sind ja anscheinend viele verschiedene Programme. Das heißt, da hin und her zu twitchen, das macht einfach Checkout, das ist da.
Das ist ein gutes Argument, finde ich. Ja, einerseits ja, das Problem ist aber, dass die SSDs natürlich eine bestimmte Maximalmenge haben an Daten, die du da drauf schreiben kannst. Also sie sind spezifiziert für, lass mich lügen, irgendwie 1000 Terabyte oder so. Ich guck gleich mal nach. Also jedenfalls kriegt man die halt schon innerhalb von ein paar Jahren kommt man da durchaus ran. Also plus da gab es jetzt das Ding mit Firefox, der halt bis zu was waren das 4 oder 5 Gigabyte am Tag oder noch mehr einfach auf die Platte schreibt, weil er alle paar Sekunden des Preference-Files wegschreibt. Man kann man abschalten, aber nicht Preference, sondern History.
In dem Browser zustande, mit alle Tabs damit. Irgendwas dampft halt die ganze Zeit.
Und das führt dann zu zig Gigabyte pro Tag an Last auf der SSD, sodass man wohl allein mit Firefox innerhalb von einem Jahr oder zwei... Seine SSD schrottet.
Das macht er verändern aber auch. Oder bei jedem Fensterwechsel speichert er die Positionen.
Genau, bei anderen hatten sie es halt auch teilweise. Also war jetzt nicht FireFox der Einzige.
RAM weiterhin verlötet? Na ja gut, ja. Das wird sich auch nicht mehr ändern, denke ich. Das wird sich nicht mehr ändern, also dafür sind die Dinge einfach zu dünn geworden.
Also im Moment benutze ich halt 14 von den 16 Gigabyte, die ich drin habe.
Ja, auch mit gutem Recht. Ich gönne dir auch die 32 GB, das sollen alle haben. Ich habe nur so den Eindruck, da ist jetzt einfach nochmal ein halbes Jahr mindestens zu gehen und dann ist das Thema wahrscheinlich auch durch.
Ich frage mich sowieso, was der hier macht. Bei mir sagt er, ich hätte 5,5 Gig frei, aber er hat ein Swap-File von 6 Gigabyte angelegt, was auch fast voll ist.
Irgendwann mal nicht so viel frei und er holt es ja nicht wieder, solange es nicht gebraucht wird oder bleibt das da liegen. Du hast ja gut lachen, ne Timme, weil du hast ja in deinem Mac Pro da 32 drin. Und wie weit kommst du da so?
Ich weiß nicht genau, welche Anzeige ich da glauben soll, um ehrlich zu sein, aber... Hier ist gerade sehr wenig in Benutzung. Ich kann die ganzen Zahlen hier nicht so richtig. Was ist denn die Pressure?
Memory Pressure, das ist ja wie...
Was heißt das?
Das ist irgendeine Gummi-Paragraphenzahl von Apple, die irgendwie ansagt, wie kritisch das System darüber nachdenkt, wie viel Speicher da jetzt ist.
Guck doch mal den System Profiler, der sagt einem das doch.
Den System Profiler?
Ja, da oben erbaut, das ist doch das. Oder? Quatsch in den... Nee, Quatsch, total falsch. Activity Monitor, genau. So, komm ich gleich noch auf System Profiler.
Weiß ich nicht.
So, Speicher. Du kannst den nämlich von Speicherdruck irgendwie umstellen auf... Aber...
Speicherdruck umstellen. Ja, was soll ich denn jetzt glauben? Memory used oder was?
Na, Speicher belegt. Wie viel hast du Speicher belegt? Dateien im Cache, verwendet der Swap.
Swap habe ich hier... 6 GB sind hier gerade belegt. Und? Was heißt das groß? Ich meine, das heißt ja nur, dass Prozesse... .gesagt haben, dass sie so viel Adressraum haben wollen, aber nicht, dass der jetzt wirklich in diesem Moment tatsächlich wirklich gerade benutzt wird.
Doch, sie haben gesagt, sie wollen ihn haben. Ob die den dann benutzen, ist ja egal.
Nein, aber ich hab hier...
Naja, ich hab hier Speicher belegt und verwendet das Wop. Ja, aber das...
Wie viele Cached Files hast du denn?
Genau, und dann hast du noch Cached Files. Also Dateien im Cache und Speicher belegt kommt bei mir zusammen ungefähr auf die 16 GB.
Also der benutzt halt den Rest, der nicht benutzt wird, benutzt er halt als Cache immer.
Ja eben ist es halt so.
Na wie viel ist bei dir als Cache?
Na der Rest halt. Ja, 14 GB.
Na du schon, bei mir nur zwei.
Bei mir sind es vier.
Bei mir anderthalb. Aber ich hab ja nur acht GB.
Ja, also vier RAM viel gut, das ist ja gar keine Frage. Das war schon immer so, das wird nie anders sein. Aber so ist es halt jetzt. Ich komm hier mit meinen 32 GB wunderbar klar. Ich komm sowieso mit meinem Mac Pro von 2009 wunderbar klar.
Wir beschweren uns über die 16 GB. Und was sagt er, was sagt Tim? Ich komm hier mit meinen 32 GB wunderbar klar.
Nee, ich sag ja nur, wenn du Serious Business machst, dann hast du halt einen Mac Pro.
So eine vier Jahre alte Mülltonne hol ich mit einem an. Ja, aber wenn ich jetzt heute einen Mac Pro kaufen wollte, dann könnte ich entweder irgendwo bei Ebay gucken, ob ich sowas geschossen kriege.
Hat der Huckel gemacht? Mac Factory Kreuzberg. Wir machen jetzt mal Schleichwerbung. Gibt es auch andere Buden, also man muss auch nicht da kaufen. Aber bei Ebay kann man gucken, also bei 600, 700 Euro.
Ist schon so ein bisschen wie Schallplattenspieler kaufen.
Bisschen besser wie Schallplattenspieler.
Ja, weil wir können auch die neuen CDs damit abspielen.
Das große Problem ist, dass Strom spart das Gerät unter Garantie nicht. Also von daher...
Ja, hat ja auch kein Akku.
Man zahlt, naja...
Du musstest ja bezahlen, den Strom.
Muss man ja auch bezahlen. Also ich würde sagen...
Hast du ein Strommessgerät dranhängen?
Ich kann es dir so sagen.
Ja und?
Also ich habe bei mir keine Platte mehr drin, aber ich habe ja SSD, habe diese R9 280X Grafikkarte, die ist zwar fett, aber ich glaube, die ist schon so von den Karten, die wenn sie nichts macht, gar nicht mehr so viel verbraucht und die Kiste schluckt immer noch 110 Watt bei nichts tun. Mit 16 GB war das. Also...
Ich glaube, ich hänge mal mein Messgerät mal ran.
Ja, am Messgerät ranhängen ist immer eine sehr interessante Experience.
Aber ist alles noch gut für die Umwelt, weil ich habe ja hier Solarstrom.
Hast du selber Solarzellen auf dem Dach?
Diese Sendung erreicht ihre Ohren CO2-neutral.
Und Solar bestromt. Du hast hier in der Liste noch Trackpad.
Ja, das ist die Frage.
Ich hab's ausprobiert und es ist ganz interessant, weil das ist nämlich so groß, das Trackpad. Also in der Grundeinstellung, wie sie es im Apple Store hatten, da ist das Trackpad so groß, dass du würdest zweimal über den Bildschirm kommen, wenn du tatsächlich von einer Seite zur anderen Seite mit dem Zeigefinger einmal rüberstreichst.
Ja, das auch natürlich.
Ja, das auch, aber selbst wenn du es relativ langsam machst. Es ist einfach massiv groß. Ich hab das Gefühl, so groß müsste es nicht sein. Aber auf der anderen Seite, nie mehr am Rand anstoßen. Das ist auch ein cooles Feature.
Ich stoß da in ihr, ich mach...
Und was ich extrem cool fand, ist, ich hab's extra ausprobiert. Also ich hab erst auf dem Ding rumgetippt und so weiter. Ja, Trackpad, Trackpad. Und da fiel mir ein... Moment, das hat ja diese Taptic Engine da drin. Und dann hab ich natürlich an der einen Ecke, an der anderen Ecke, oben, unten, rechts, links, überall mal geklickt, um mal geklickt zu haben. Und das ist wirklich, als würdest du an jeder Stelle ganz normal tappen können. Als würde sich das Ding dann normal bewegen.
Also das ist das Magic Trackpad, was ich hier habe. Das ist ja im Prinzip genau dasselbe.
Das Trackpad ist ein No-Brain, das ist wirklich geil. Und mit Handballenerkennung, was es angeblich hat, das scheint auch zu funktionieren. Also ich hatte zumindest irgendwie kein Problem damit. Also ich habe auf dem Ding getippt und hatte bestimmt auch die Handballen auf dem Trackpad. Und das funktioniert einfach.
Ja, ich habe gelesen, dass wenn man so beide Hände am Start hat, dann das relativ gut funktioniert mit dieser Palmrejection. Aber wenn du nur so mit einer Hand an so einer zentralen Taste rumhängst und da öfter mal drauf tippst und die andere ist nicht dabei, dann kannst du schon mal den ein oder anderen Zappler erzeugen.
Also mir ist es nicht aufgefallen, dass da irgendwas wäre. Ja, ist mir jetzt auch nicht wirklich aufgefallen, dass der jetzt deutlich besser gewesen wäre als der von den Geräten nebenan.
Ja gut, aber das siehst du halt auch erst, wenn du bestimmte Bilder anschaust.
Genau, das habe ich nicht gemacht, weil es mich nicht interessiert hat. Also insofern kann ich nichts zu sagen.
Also das mit diesem P3 Farbspace, das ist schon ein dickes Ding. Also das ist schon etwas, wo es eine riesen Nachfrage gibt. Und dass sie da jetzt alle Lücken schließen, das ist einfach nur gut. Na, mit diesem HDR ist ein bisschen die Frage, was du damit genau meinst.
Wer soll man sagen? Ich sehe das immer aus der anderen Ecke. Wenn ich gehe zu Pirate Bay, lade mir eine Mui runter. Mit X265, der mit 10-Bit-Farben kommt. Ist das HDR? Was ist das dann? Sind das die besseren Farben genau für dieses neue Display?
Ja, unter Umständen. Also 10-Bit heißt ja einfach nur, dass mehr Farben unterschieden werden können. Und dann ist die Frage, ob dein Bildschirm auch mehr Farben unterscheiden kann. Und dieser P3-Farbraum ist halt viel größer als dieser sRGB-Farbraum, der bis vor kurzem noch so ein bisschen der State of the Art war. Das heißt, du kannst halt in diesem Farbraum auch mehr Nuancen abbilden.
Das heißt, man bräuchte auch mehr Bit, damit man nicht so eine Sprünge hat?
Genau. Also das muss nicht jetzt unbedingt bei dem jeweiligen Film was bringen, kann aber. Grundsätzlich ist es so, dass einfach dieser P3-Farbraum naja, also erstmal mehr Farben bringt. Also einfach auch Farben bringt, die die anderen Bildschirme bisher nicht gebracht haben. Also es ist einfach mit bestimmten Farben gar nicht zu sehen.
Ich glaube, sRGB war aber eigentlich schon immer der kleinste gemeinsame Nenner, wenn ich das richtig in Erinnerung habe.
Also sRGB-Farbraum war schon mal ein Sprung nach vorne von ein paar Jahren bei den Bildschirmen. Na, nur nicht vollständig sRGB. Also, ich will mal ein Beispiel nennen, auch wenn ich ehrlich gesagt nicht weiß, ob das jetzt auf die neuen P3-Bildschirme wirklich zutrifft. Aber ich kenne das zum Beispiel noch aus der medizinischen Anwendung. Hier in dieser Krebserkennung zum Beispiel, wenn die sich halt so Röntgenbilder anschauen. Da ist dann zur Interpretation, ob da irgendwo ein Tumor ist oder nicht, ist eine extrem hohe Graustufenauflösung erforderlich gewesen. Und die haben halt alle nicht mit normalen Computerbildschirmen gearbeitet, sondern die haben halt so extra 10-Bit-Grau-Stufen-Bildschirme gehabt. Wie gesagt, nur Graustufen, nicht Farbe. Nur diese feinen Übergänge in bestimmten Helligkeitstönen ist an der Stelle halt relevant. Und genauso willst du natürlich in einem professionellen Pripress oder Filmretouche etc. Willst du das natürlich haben. Du willst so viele Farben irgendwie haben, wie in irgendeiner Form von Menschen wahrgenommen werden können. Und da waren die Bildschirme halt in gewisser Hinsicht und sind sie auch sicherlich auch immer noch beschränkt. Und diese Beschränkungen weichen halt jetzt langsam zur Seite. Und da ist halt dieser P3-Farbtraum, der jetzt hier erzielt wird, eben schon mal wieder ein neuer Meilenstein.
Ja, es ist wohl so, dass Radiologen wohl auch mit der Zeit sehr geschulte Augen haben, dafür halt auch sehr feine Farbabstufungen zu erkennen, weil die halt nichts anderes machen den ganzen Tag lang.
Genau.
Und deswegen hast du halt viel noch diese gröntgen Bilder, die tatsächlich auf Film sind, weil die halt auch eine sehr, sehr hohe Graustufenaufflösung haben. Also insofern, keine Ahnung. Mir ist nichts aufgefallen, aber das muss wirklich nichts heißen. Und überhaupt im vollen Apple Store. Und darf ich mal dränge, ist das sowieso ein bisschen schwierig.
Ja, heller soll er sein, stromspannender soll er sein, mehr Kontrast haben und bunter. Also das ist schon mal jetzt nicht schlecht, aber naja gut, muss man dann halt your mileage may vary. Aber sicherlich besser als meiner.
Heller, bunter, kontraster.
So, bei Grafikkarten haben wir ja jetzt schon gesprochen. Gibt es da jetzt noch irgendwas nachzutragen? Sonst könnten wir uns mal dieser Touchbar widmen, weil ich glaube, das ist ja so ein bisschen der Heilige.
Grafikkarte, solange es keine Benchmark gibt, kann man ja nicht viel zu sagen, wie viel Bumpf wir haben.
Ich habe irgendwo welche gesehen und es ist okay, aber das ist halt wie immer nicht die schnellste. Und wie gesagt, das Problem ist halt, ich hätte halt lieber eine Nvidia gehabt wegen CUDA.
Na gut, was hätten wir auch gerne gehabt? Wir hätten gerne eine Escape-Taste gehabt, aber die Escape-Taste muss leider weichen, zumindest bei zwei dieser drei vorgestellten Modelle. Und wie es jetzt schon lange gerüchtet wurde, gibt es jetzt eben ein neues User-Interface-Element, was Apple sich da hat einfallen lassen, ihrer Meinung nach jahrzehntelang gröbeln, was sie nicht alles ausprobiert haben. Und jetzt sind sie also der Meinung, dass man diese Funktionstasten doch mal weglassen könnte und ersetzen könnte durch ein flexibles Display mit Touch-Funktion. So ganz nebenbei fließt dann auch noch Touch ID, also die Fingerabdruckerkennung, mit in das System. Und im Prinzip hast du jetzt quasi so eine Apple Watch im Mac.
Naja, es wurde irgendwo gesagt, dass da drauf Watch OS läuft, was ja nicht heißt, dass es eine Watch ist, weil Watch OS ist ja auch nur ein runtergedampftes iOS. Und iOS nur ist nur ein runtergedampftes Mac OS.
Ich rede nicht so sehr von Watch OS, sondern ich rede einfach von der Hardware. Sie haben da im Prinzip einen eigenen Armstein drin. Sie nennen das jetzt BT1. Das ist im Prinzip dasselbe wie in der Uhr.
Der ist wohl sehr ähnlich zu dir in der Uhr.
Das Display ist halt auch dasselbe wie in der Uhr.
Naja, aber es ist das gleiche.
Das Prinzip ist halt ein OLED-Screen.
Ich stell mir gerade so ein längliches Display am Arm vor.
Und vielleicht auch noch.
So touchbar am Arm.
Ja, aber es ist diese Technologie. Sie haben sozusagen damit das gemacht. Das Teil ist irgendwie über USB mit dem System verbunden. Also es gibt da irgendeinen Datenpfad, der schneller ist als das Bluetooth zwischen der Watch und dem iPhone, immerhin.
Na alles ist schneller als das Bluetooth zwischen der Watch und dem iPhone.
Aber es sind zwei unabhängige Computer, die miteinander über ein Protokoll kommunizieren. Und es ist nicht Teil des Adressraums des normalen Macs. Also du kannst nicht irgendwie in dieses Display direkt was reinschreiben. Du kannst nur das dort anzeigen, was das System dir gestattet darstellt.
Ja, ja. Also das Ding ist, dass die Escape-Taste, die man immer sieht, die Escape-Sondertaste, oder wie auch immer du sie nennen willst, die ist tatsächlich vom System. Und dann ist irgendwie rechts auch Zeug, was du systemweit konfigurieren kannst. Und alles, was dazwischen ist, in der Mitte, ist halt app-abhängig. Und du kannst dann als App-Entwickler wiederum an fast jedes User-Interface-Element in deinem Programm wiederum eine Touchbar-Belegung ranhängen. Also das muss man sich halt so vorstellen, wenn du...
Die Toolbar, die man jetzt so belegen kann, das ist ja das gleiche GUI-Log dafür.
Die Toolbar hängt ja am Fenster. Aber die Touchbar hängt tatsächlich an jedem Control. Also das Control, was den First Responder hat, also die Events, die Tastatur und Mausevents bekommt, kann dann auch die Touchbar anzeigen, die es braucht. Also wenn du jetzt, weiß ich nicht, irgendwo ein Eingabefeld hast, dann kannst du für das Eingabefeld irgendwie Zeug machen.
Genau, das heißt, die ändert sich, wenn du halt in das Eingabefeld klickst.
Genau, dann kann die also quasi maximal Kontext sensitiv sich ändern.
Apple sagt auch, man soll da eben das Ding nicht als als weiteren Bildschirm für Informationen anbieten, sondern man soll das wirklich benutzen als Eingabe. Man soll halt wirklich Tastatur spielen und soll nicht irgendwie hier so, ich sehe schon wieder, wie iStart Menu irgendwie da so sein Zeug reinpinselt. Das wollen die bei Apple aber eigentlich nicht gerne sehen. Werbung geil. Nee, ich benutze das nicht, weil...
Ich benutze das.
Das zieht mir nur meinen Rechner leer. Aber das ist so das Ding, was alle benutzen eigentlich.
Da oben, Pavel, auf dem Beamer.
Okay, aber ich bin noch auf Menümeters.
That's over, man. iStart Menus ist the thing.
Schon lange.
Also das ist wirklich...
Ich mag meine Menümeters.
Ich mochte Menümeters auch immer, aber iStart Menus hat halt einfach so zwei, drei Features, da willst du halt einfach nichts anderes mehr haben. Also allein, dass er mir pro Prozess anzeigt, wie viel Netzwerktraffic da gerade ist. Dass ich einfach mal sehen kann, wer reist denn hier irgendwie.
Ja, das ist sehr schön.
Es ist alles super neat gemacht. Also iStart Menus, konfiguriert sich ordentlich, läuft gut, wird immer aktualisiert.
Er sagt dir, welche IP-Adressen an welchem Netzwerkadapter hängen und solche Sachen. Was du öffentlich für eine IP hast und so, das passt drin.
Okay, guck ich, werde ich mir mal anschauen.
Kostet aber auch, ne?
Ja, aber nicht die Welt. Also für Leute, die irgendwie eine größere Anzahl rechts unten Modelle kaufen.
Ja, ja, daran soll es nicht liegen.
Sollte das zu stemmen sein, denke ich mal.
Allerdings.
Da ist auch nochmal ganz korrekte Speicher-Stats und Memory-Stats und das wird ja alles... Verlaufe über die letzten 24 Stunden und 7 Tage und so. Naja, worüber redet man eigentlich?
Hatspar.
Ja, also wenn ich dich richtig verstehe, also du hast hier immer das API angeguckt?
Ja, so ein bisschen.
Und wie frei ist man darin, was man da reinmalen kann? Und was da...
Aus irgendeinem Grund habe ich den Democode nicht zum Laufen gekriegt. Ich weiß nicht wieso. Es gibt irgendwie auch einen Simulator für die Touchbar von Xcode aus. Also man braucht kein Touchbar-Gerät, um dafür zu entwickeln. Wie es genau funktioniert, kann ich jetzt nicht so genau sagen. Weil, wie gesagt, ich habe es nicht zum Laufen gekriegt, aber... Ah, man ist wohl relativ frei.
Gut, also... Die Frage ist, macht das... Ist das jetzt ein großer Wurf? Oder ist das etwas, von dem wir in 5 Jahren nichts mehr sehen werden? Ich bin mir nicht sicher.
Das kommt sehr drauf an, glaube ich, von was für einer App man redet und was für einer Anwendung man dafür hat. Ich glaube, dass gerade so monströse Apps, die, wenn du allein das Hauptmenü aufklappst, Angst bekommst, dass die dafür profitieren können. Also wenn du jetzt als unbedarfter Nutzer so einen Photoshop aufmachst und du markierst mit der Maus irgendwas und du kriegst dann das Kontextmenü auf die Touchbar, was du mit diesem Objekt, das du gerade markiert hast, machen kannst, dann glaube ich, das kann ganz geil sein. Wenn du jemand bist, der seit 20 Jahren die gleiche App benutzt und alle Funktionstastenbelegungen kennt und motorisch einfach weiß, wo du drücken musst, wenn du das und das haben willst, dann ist das komplett das Falsche. Und irgendwo dazwischen, glaube ich, wird sich das ansiedeln. Ich kann mir vorstellen, dass es für einen ganz größeren Bereich ganz gut funktionieren wird.
Und welche Tasten waren jetzt fest vom Betriebssystem?
Also auf jeden Fall die Escape-Taste.
Okay.
Und dann hast du, wir hatten vorhin dieses Bild.
Lichtbreit, Lautstärke, diese ganzen Sachen.
Die sind immer da oder kann man die FN drücken und dann ändert sich das Display?
Du siehst die und wenn du die dann auswählst, dann klappt das so seitlich auf und dann siehst du die alle. Dann kann man auch so die Lautstärke mit einem Griff.
Du kannst wohl die Systemtasten auch systemweit konfigurieren und sagen, ich will jetzt immer ganz links die Taste haben und die drei Tasten will ich immer ganz rechts haben und alles was dazwischen ist, darf dann die Software benutzen. Also es muss ja auch für die zwei Geräte unterschiedlich lange Touchbars geben.
Richtig.
Insofern müssen die Programme irgendwie damit umgehen, dass sie mal mehr und mal weniger Platz haben.
Die Tastatur ist immer gleich breit.
Stimmt. Stimmt. Okay, also ist auch die Touchbar gleich breit. Aber trotzdem müssen sicherlich die Programme damit umgehen, dass sie mal mehr und mal weniger Platz haben. Also du kannst ja die Belegung dann auch irgendwie hin und her schieben und so weiter.
Man kann die Belegung einstellen, wie man sich seine Natur über auch einstellen kann.
Für die Systembelegung ja. Für die Programme weiß ich es nicht genau.
Ich dachte genau andersrum.
Nur für den Systemkram.
Für den System auf jeden Fall. Du kannst ja in Programmen, die die normale Toolbar im Fenster haben, kannst du ja auch konfigurieren, wenn das Programm das zulässt. Das Programm muss ja aktiv sagen, wenn der User das konfigurieren will, dann hab ich hier diesen Sack von Controls, den kann er benutzen und dann ist gut. Ich kann mir vorstellen, dass beide Varianten irgendwie drin sind. Die API sah auf den ersten Blick auch sehr ähnlich aus wie die von der Toolbar von Fenstern.
Aber ehrlich gesagt, ich hätte da gerne mein iStart-Menü da drin.
Naja, aber da werden sie... Ich frag mich halt, was Apple... Apple sagt ja, tut das nicht. Ich frag mich nur, wie sie das verhindern wollen.
Das können sie ja eigentlich nur im App Store verhindern. Das ist ja vom Prinzip eigentlich schon verhindert, weil es ja pro Programm umgeschaltet wird. Und da iStart-Menü nie Frontprogramm ist, hat es einfach mal die Arschkarte.
Ja, ich denke, das werden wir da nicht sehen. Aber es ist schon ganz interessant, wenn man sich die geposteten Varianten anschaut, dass zum Beispiel halt die Escape-Taste dann auch nicht immer da ist. Also so ein richtiger Ersatz ist es halt nicht.
Ja, aber wenn das Programm, was gerade vorne ist, und das scheint ja nun mal touchbar, ohne zu sein, wenn das kein Escape braucht, dann brauchst du auch keins anzeigen. Weißt du, wenn das Programm eh nicht auf Escape reagieren würde?
Also, ich denke, man wird, also ich, kann ja dann noch mal irgendwann, wenn wir dann alle ein bisschen touchbar...
Ich drücke auch manchmal auf Escape einfach nur aus Langeweile.
Dann musst du halt auf irgendwas anderes touchen aus Langeweile. Das wirst du ja wohl hinkriegen.
Haptisches Feedback gibt es aber kein.
Nein, gibt es nicht.
So einen leichten Tick oder so.
Hätte nicht eine Touch-Taste ausgereicht, auf der einfach touch steht.
Das ist zu fett. Und nicht mehr mit DLC.
Ich gerade sah, dass ich das hier ansonsten noch zwei Watch-Träger hier sitze. Und ich bin nämlich ganz vom Uhren tragen. Also ich bin ja so in den letzten zehn Jahren oder in den letzten 15 Jahren technologisch beim Uhren tragen eher rückwärts gegangen. Ich hab dann irgendwann bin ich halt ganz von elektronischen Uhren hin zu mechanischen. Und jetzt so seit, ich glaube seit zwei Jahren, trage ich überhaupt gar keine Uhr mehr.
Ich hab das mit den Uhren eigentlich aufgehört zu tragen, seitdem die Telefone kamen. Also noch nicht die Smartphones, sondern überhaupt.
Lass uns beim Touchpad bleiben, oder willst du da irgendwie wieder drauf hinaus?
Nein, nein, nein, ich will, weil ihr hattet ja das Thema irgendwie längliche Apple Watch und so.
Naja, ich denke man muss es abwarten, welche Programme das wie gut unterstützen und ob das überhaupt sinnvoll ist.
Also ich sehe ja da, also ich kann mir alles vorstellen. Ich kann mir vorstellen, dass das irgendwie fliegt. Mit manchen Leuten zumindest. Aber ich sehe auch ein paar Punkte, wo ich mir vorstellen könnte, dass es daran zumindest die Adoption sehr schwierig wird. Zunächst einmal, das ist halt was, das geht auf einen Laptop. Das geht, wenn die Tastatur unmittelbar an den Bildschirm sich anschließt. Wenn du dir das Ganze jetzt mal vorstellst als Desktop-Tastatur, wäre ja die nächste Frage, ist es möglich, dass selbe User-Interface auch auf eine andere Tastatur zu bringen. Ich meine, wenn man sagt, das ist jetzt unsere neue Art und Weise, wie wir uns eine Tastatur vorstellen, wo die Funktionstasten wechseln und ersetzt werden durch so etwas, dann müsstest du ja konsequenterweise auch sagen, okay, auch auf einem iMac mit einer vollständig abgesetzten Tastatur, die auch wirklich vom Blickwinkel her ganz woanders ist. Also auf dem Laptop hast du deine Tastatur ja mehr oder weniger immer im Blick. Wenn du den unteren Rand des Bildschirms siehst, dann siehst du auch den oberen Rand der Tastatur. Zumindest ist es kein großer Aufwand, diese Scrollleistung zu verbringen. Aber eine Tastatur, die auf dem Tisch liegt und in einem Meter Abstand davon ist so ein 27 Zoll Bildschirm, ist schon noch mal ein bisschen was anderes.
Ja, aber wie Roddy schon sagte, gerade für diese Riesenprogramme, wo du voll erschlagen wirst von der ganzen Vielfalt und dann eben so ein normaler User kommen, die eben nicht irgendwie so Power-User sind, sondern die jetzt mal irgendwie was machen wollen, mal so ein iMovie editieren, was sie nicht jeden Tag machen, sondern wo sie sich gerade reinfummeln, dann hilft doch dieses Menü da, also diese Touchbar total. Und sie gucken doch eh, die können doch eh nicht blind tippen, sage ich jetzt mal ganz böse. Aber denen hilft das. Die gucken dann hin und sagen, ja das will ich jetzt machen, das ist genau das, was ich suche.
Ja, dann gucke ich mir an, wie meine Karten-App, wie lange die, wie die 10 Sekunden braucht, um eine scheiß Landkarte lag zu laden, die auf meinem iPhone bereits vollständig gerendert vorliegt. Und frage mich, wie so eine Bluetooth-Tastatur, wo diese Responsiveness hinbekommt.
Ja, mit Bluetooth geht das eh nicht, weil dieses Display verbraucht viel zu viel Strom.
Ja, aber Bluetooth ist das Interface, was...
Ja, Moment.
Nee, aber nicht das.
Was heißt das, das verbraucht so viel Strom, das verbraucht so viel Strom wie eine Uhr.
Ja, nee, das Display ist ein bisschen breiter.
Ja, ein bisschen.
Okay, er hat auch vielleicht fettere Batterien als...
Zwei Sachen dazu. Ich gebe dir Recht, wenn du sagst, für den Pro-User, der an einem Desktop sitzt und die Tastatur hat, ist es wahrscheinlich schwierig. Und ich kann mir aber auch nicht vorstellen, dass sie das als externe Tastatur rausbringen. Also, might happen.
Aber warum nicht?
Weil die haben gerade eine Tastatur rausgemacht und da wussten die schon lange, dass sie ihr Touchbar rausbringen.
Nö, das ist weniger der Grund. Ich kann mir also einerseits dieses über Bluetooth performtes wahrscheinlich nicht. Kann gut sein. Dass Apple eine kabelgebundene Tastatur nur für die Touchbar rausbringt, kann ich mir nicht vorstellen.
Wenn sie möchten, dass es responsive ist, dann stecken sie Lightning ein.
Genau, das kann ich mir nicht so richtig vorstellen. Und ansonsten ist es auch was, ich kann mir so eine Tastatur, also ganz ehrlich, die Tastatur, die dann da oben noch diesen Leuchtstreifen hat als Standalone-Tastatur, das kann ich mir auch optisch nicht vorstellen, dass das irgendwie gut aussieht.
Warum?
Das ist glaube ich ein lösbares Problem. Das Ding ist halt nur, wenn sie es über Bluetooth nicht implementiert bekommen, dann bedeutet das, dass es bei Desktop-Rechnern nicht Einzug hält. Wenn es bei Desktop-Rechnern nicht Einzug hält, handelt es sich hierbei um einen User-Interface, was ausschließlich auf MacBook Pros vielleicht irgendwann auch noch mal bei dem normalen MacBook Einzug hält, aber eben nirgends woanders.
Ja gut, aber Desktops sind ja vielleicht 5% Marktanteil von Apple oder so. Also ich glaube nicht, dass Apple das als Problem sieht.
Nein, also vielleicht mal meine 5 Cent dazu. Ganz kurz, was ich glaube, was sie sich dabei gedacht haben. Jetzt, klar, durch die ganzen iDevices und so sind die Leute jetzt gewohnt auf irgendwie etwas leuchtendem, bunten, bewegenden rum zu operieren. Microsoft dachte sich dann, wow, dann machen wir doch gleich unser ganzes Betriebssystem so und packen da Touchscreens auf die Laptops, was aber eine ziemlich blöde Idee ist, weil du willst eigentlich nicht auf deinem großen Laptop-Bildschirm rumtouchen aus tausend Gründen.
Das Gorilla-Arm-Problem, ne?
Genau, vom Gorilla-Arm-Problem über Fingerabdrücke, über, dass die Dinge eigentlich nicht dafür gemacht sind. Ich glaube, wir haben jetzt versucht, irgendwie einen Kompromiss hinzukriegen für ein Zwischending, was halt auch ergonomischer ist, weil du halt nicht den Arm hochheben musst. Du kannst aber eben ein bisschen mehr Interaktion und Bandbreite drauf machen und einfachere als jetzt mit nur Tasten. Also sprich, du bist ein Regler, du kannst halt Sachen hin und her schieben oder scrollen und andere Dinge. Gut, auf der anderen Seite hast du dafür ja auch das Trackpad, aber offensichtlich ist das Ganze dann auch noch für User, die vielleicht Probleme haben, irgendwie diese Transformationsleistung. Zwischen das sehe ich auf dem Bildschirm und jetzt muss ich die und die Geste machen oder so. Ich glaube, das ist eigentlich so ein bisschen auch was für haptisch nicht so oder... Es ist, glaube ich, nicht eher weniger für den Power-User gedacht, als für eher den bequemen User. Auf der anderen Seite sind wir alle bequeme User.
Man könnte auch sagen, das ist ein Accessibility-Feature. Ja, es macht die Sache zugänglicher. Ja, das auch. Aber auch Accessibility. Wenn da nicht F1 steht, sondern 2Ds, dann ist das auf jeden Fall eine Hilfe. Und ich würde mir wünschen, dass sie es schaffen, aus jeder Taste ein OLED zu machen. Nur weiß ich nicht, ob sie das wirklich...
Was ich wiederum, wenn man jetzt nicht gerade täglich mit kurilischer Tastaturbelegung zu tun hat, die man umschaltet zu lateinisch und dann vielleicht noch griechisch, halte ich das jetzt nicht so wichtig.
Warum? Groß, klein, eine einheitliche Tastatur?
Ich brauche keine kleinen Buchstaben auf der Tastatur.
Ich würde schon mal zwischen englischer und deutscher Tastatur umschalten und fände es auch mal ganz geil, wenn die richtigen Buchstaben drauf sind.
Ganz ehrlich, was ich da lieber hätte wäre...
Und wenn ich aufschneidrücke und Funktion drücke, möchte ich auch sehen, was da kommt.
Nach Jahrzehnten ein Standard, wo eine Tastatur von alleine weiß, was sie für eine Belegung hat, dass ich eine deutsche USB-Tastatur einstecke und sie hat das richtige Layout vom Betriebssystem her, weil das Betriebssystem weiß, welches Layout diese Tastatur hat. Dann stecke ich eine deutsche und eine englische ein und wenn ich englisch tippen will, nehme ich die englische und wenn ich deutsch tippen will, nehme ich die deutsche ohne irgendwas umzuschalten. Das will ich haben. Aber gibt's nicht.
Schreiben wir auch nochmal auf.
Weil Intel irgendwie damals beim USB-Standard irgendwie, das verpasst hat irgendwie, keine Ahnung, zwei Byte dafür zu reservieren, dass die Tastatur vielleicht eine Belegung hat und nicht nur unter zwei Tasten. Das ist, weißt du, also, naja.
Da müsste man aber nochmal ein bisschen weitergehen und sagen, so sieht diese Tastatur auch konkret aus. Und nicht nur irgendwelche Keycaps, Tasten, Zahlen und so weiter.
Wenn ich die Taste 25 drücke, dann ist das ein Z und kein Y.
Und was ist die Taste Enter für eine Zahl? Und wann ist die über zwei rein? Und wann ist die quer über eine Reihe?
Das spielt keine Rolle.
Das spielt eine Rolle, wenn du das anzeigen willst. Ja, das ist nur eine Taste. Das ist eine große Taste. Die Tasten sehen halt unterschiedlich aus. Du hast mal eine mehr, du hast mal eine weniger.
Ja, eben. Aber das sind halt Tasten. Auf der Hardware ist ja eine Beschriftung drauf.
Aber das ist jetzt nicht das, worüber wir jetzt reden. Ja, weiß.
Ja, aber ich finde Tasten mit veränderlichen Keycaps, finde ich einfach...
Wieso? Ich meine, du drückst Alt. Du hast auf jeder Taste eine andere Funktion. Du drückst Command. Du hast auf jeder Taste eine andere Funktion. Du drückst Control. Du hast auf jeder Taste eine andere Funktion. Du drückst Function. Du hast allein links unten vier Metatasten, die die komplette Belegung der gesamten Tastatur ändern. Da willst du mir erzählen, das wäre sinnlos, wenn man auf jeder Taste ein OLED-Screen hätte. Also das ist natürlich jetzt technisch ein riesen Aufwand.
Also es gibt ja solche Tastaturen, aber es hat sich ja nicht aus gutem Grund, glaube ich, nicht durchgesetzt.
Ja, weil die so teuer waren.
Ja, 2,5k oder so.
Nicht nur weil es zu teuer war, sondern du hast halt auch Probleme mit Wärmeentwicklung und wahrscheinlich Tastaturhub und...
Masse der Tasten.
Es ist ja anfällig und ich glaube nicht, dass das wirklich...
Naja, die erste Zeile ist ja jetzt schon mal OLED.
Ja, aber das sind keine Tasten.
Nö, das sind keine Tasten, aber vielleicht...
Nee, won't happen. Also das ist auch so... Das scheint mir so ein bisschen eine Lösung auf der Suche nach einem Problem zu sein.
Das ist eine Art won't happen, wo ich nicht mitgehe.
Nein, weil es auch eine Lösung ist auf der Suche nach einem Problem.
Wieso? Also, dass man Tasten haben will, ist ja wohl klar. Tasten haben sich einfach bewährt.
Ja, natürlich, klar. Aber Tasten, die irgendwie...
Und die sollen gefälligst das anzeigen, was sie gerade tun und nicht das, was sie vielleicht unter Umständen tun. Also das ist schon einer der größten User Interfaces Fails, dass Tastaturen nicht anzeigen, was sie machen sollen, nur wie sie irgendwie heißen.
Der Fail fängt nur da an, wo du plötzlich eine Tastaturbelegung hast, wo eine Taste was anderes tut, als das, was draufsteht. Das ist ein großer Fail. Alles andere ist völlig in Ordnung.
Ja, aber das tut sich doch laufend. Ich drücke auf ein großes H und es kommt ein kleines.
Ja, aber das ist...
Was ist es? Seitdem das so richtig funktioniert, wie das bei Android schon vorher funktioniert hat, finde ich das auch besser.
Hast mich aber nicht überzeugt.
Mich auch nicht.
Muss ich jetzt auch nicht. Ich wollte auch über ein Touchbar reden. Touchbar ist halt einfach jetzt ein Experiment.
Das klang nicht nach Experiment bei der Vorstellung.
Nee, das ist kein Experiment. Das ist schon... Mit AP und SDK.
Das muss jetzt ankommen, oder nicht?
Lass uns mal in einem Jahr vielleicht noch mal eine Sendung machen, wenn wir vielleicht Erfahrungen...
Nee klar, aber ich hab mir trotzdem Gedanken darüber gemacht, was, sagen wir mal, jetzt so entscheidende Faktoren sein können. Also, ich bin mir ja nicht so richtig sicher, wie das aussehen wird. Ich hab jetzt von den Leuten, die die Gelegenheit hatten, so ein Ding mal auszuprobieren, haben halt viele gesagt, Apple sei es gelungen, diese Optik, dieses Touchbar so zu machen, dass es wirklich aussieht wie eine Taste. Daraus schließe ich mal, dass es ihnen vielleicht gelungen ist, das mit der Helligkeit irgendwie hinzubekommen.
Und matt. Wir sollen matt sein, die.
So, jetzt ist aber auch so, dass ich manchmal so in dunklen Situationen einfach auch mal meine Tastatur dunkel hab. Und dann benutze ich die halt auch dunkel. Dieser Touchbar schaltet sich ja irgendwie automatisch an, wenn man auf der Tastatur irgendwas macht. Und schaltet sich auch automatisch ab, wenn man nichts macht.
So wie die Hintergrundbeleuchtung der Tastatur vielleicht?
Nach 60 Sekunden wird es irgendwie dimm, und nach 90 Sekunden ist es aus oder so was. Vielleicht ist das auch noch konfiguriert, weil ich bin mir nicht sicher. Das heißt, du hast mit etwas zu tun, was halt irgendwie leuchtet. Vielleicht leuchtet es auch nicht. Vielleicht ist das so schwach, dass es nur gut beschriftet aussieht. Und ich könnte mir auch vorstellen, dass es mit der Hintergrundtastaturbeleuchtung, dass die dann immer aktiv ist. Heißt das, dass dann die Hintergrundtastaturbeleuchtung, Tastatur, Hintergrundbeleuchtung, wie heißt das? Tastatur, Hintergrundbeleuchtung, dass die dann immer synchron ist mit dem Ding oder ist das unabhängig davon?
Ja, wir werden sehen. Aber ich denke mir, dass Apple sich da eine Menge Mühe gegeben haben dürfte. Und sie hatten ja auch eine Menge Zeit. Insofern, wenn sie das nicht ordentlich gemacht haben, dann...
Es sah jetzt nicht aus, wie schnell mal hingeschissen.
Aber sie haben schon einiges nicht ordentlich gemacht. Ja, alles was aussieht wie so ein Tischmüll-Eimer war schon immer scheiße.
Eigentlich ist der Mac Pro ja der Nachfolger vom Cube.
Wir müssen auch gleich nochmal drüber reden.
Ist auch der gleiche Typ dafür schuld?
Haben wir denn noch irgendwas zum Thema MacBook? Also zum Touchpad fällt euch jetzt nichts mehr ein. Also ich dachte, das ist jetzt der Climax dieser Sendung. Aber jetzt sag ich ja einfach nur so, vielleicht ganz praktisch mal gucken.
Ich glaube, ich finde es ganz cool.
Würdest du das Ding kaufen? Willst du das Ding kaufen? Du willst den Computer kaufen ohne Escape-Taste?
Das ist mir Schnuppe. Man muss mit der Zeit gehen.
Du bist überhaupt kein Altschul-Hacker. Ich dachte, du wärst eine coole Sau.
Aber man kann das auch Caps Lock legen.
Niemand benutzt Caps Lock.
Die Taste ist voll frei, die ist schön groß.
Freiheit für Caps Lock.
Die tippt sich wahrscheinlich sogar besser als Escape. Nur man trifft sie nicht so gut, weil es nicht in der Ecke ist. Das stimmt. Man kann die Taste in der Ecke so schön erfüllen.
Also ich hab einen bestellt.
13, 15?
15.
Aber über die Firma.
Und Pavel will noch bestellen.
Das dauert vielleicht noch zwei Monate, bis das kommt.
Pavel, denk an die Cursor-Tasten.
Wobei ich überlege, ob ich nicht irgendwie nur zwei bestelle.
Erstmal gucken. Ich stell lieber nur einen und guck erst mal.
Ich brauch ja meine Mitgründer. Einfach dringend neue Macs. Eine ist irgendwie mit einem auch, weiß nicht, also beide mit über fünf Jahre alten Macs unterwegs.
Also meiner ist fünf Jahre alt. Eigentlich ist der noch ziemlich geil. Mit Ethernet sogar.
Naja, aber die sind einfach, also mein Teil compilte hier einfach mal teilweise fünfmal schneller oder zehnmal schneller als deren Kisten.
Bei mir auf Arbeit, der ist halt dreieinhalb Jahre alt. Naja, ein bisschen älter glaube ich noch, weil es irgendwie, keine Ahnung. Auf jeden Fall, ja, keine Ahnung. Nach drei Jahren hat man Anspruch auf einen neuen. Und ich habe halt nach drei Jahren gesagt, das lohnt sich nicht, weil was es da an Geräten gibt, was soll ich jetzt damit? Dafür ist der alte noch gut genug. Und jetzt, wo es die Touch Bar gibt und die neuen Geräte und irgendwie ein halbes Kilo abgespeckt. Ich benutze eh immer eine externe Tastatur. Mir ist das mit der Touch Bar eigentlich relativ wurscht. Und auch mit den Corsakies. Ja, weil das steht, also in der Firma, da habe ich halt einen Monitor und dann habe ich das Ding daneben auf so einem erhöhten Stand. Sodass die Monitore ungefähr auf der gleichen Höhe...
Aber den Bildschirm benutzt du schon noch, auch wenn der da ein Closed List ist?
Nein, warum soll ich das tun? Das bringt ja nichts. Also von der Unterkante sind die beiden Bildschirme auf der gleichen Höhe. Da habe ich so zwei Bildschirme. Und dann habe ich die Tastatur zentral vor mir, den großen externen Monitor auch quasi zentral davor, den anderen ein bisschen seitlich daneben. Also das eigentliche Gerät eben erhöht auf dem Stand. Und dann tippe ich an der Tastatur ab, noch ein externes Trackpad und fertig. Nee, und dann will ich halt wissen, wie ist das Gerät, bringt es das überhaupt, wie ist die Touchbar vielleicht?
Welche Grafikkarte?
Ich weiß nicht, was die mir bestellen werden, keine Ahnung.
Achso, hast du das nicht in der Kontrolle?
Platte?
Wie viel brauchst du?
Also momentan ist es so, auf dem Firmenrechner hab ich irgendwie immer so 300 Gig frei. Also ich brauch nur 200 Gig irgendwie von der Platte, die da drin ist, weil...
Firmenrechner halt.
Firmenrechner halt. Da hab ich halt irgendwie mein X-Code drauf.
Aber RAM willst du schon alles haben.
Jaja, klar. Nee gut, 15 Zoll gibt's sowieso nicht mit 8 Gig RAM. Also das wird schon irgendwie passen, denk ich mal. Und wenn ich dann die Haptik und so weiter dann mal irgendwie ein Viertel Jahr ausprobiert hab, dann kann ich mir immer noch überlegen, ob ich jetzt hier dieses 13 Zoll, was jetzt aber auch erst zweieinhalb Jahre alt ist oder so, ob ich das dann ersetze. Aber momentan ist mir das einfach zu viel Geld, um einfach zu sagen, ach, das sieht lustig aus, da kaufste mal.
Also bei mir, also ich gucke normalerweise, versuch ich halt immer die Dinger nicht länger als zwei Jahre zu benutzen, weil ich halt so ein Intensivnutzer bin. Also bei mir läuft das Ding, will ich sagen, rund um die Uhr.
Aber solange du wach bist, ist das Ding in Action.
Und meistens fangen so nach zwei Jahren an, so langsam die ersten Ausfallerscheinungen sich zu zeigen. Aber wenn ich die nach zwei Jahren abgebe, kann die irgendjemand anders noch beliebig lange benutzen. Aber wenn ich die dann so ins dritte oder vierte Jahr reingehe, dann kann das sein, dass das Ding dann einfach durchgerockt ist. Dann fangen halt, weiß ich nicht, teilweise Kontaktprobleme bei den USB-Ports und gut, die eine oder andere Macke oder so. Ich nenne noch ja die Batterie. Also ich habe es jetzt auch geschafft. Innerhalb dieser zwei Jahre bin ich, glaube ich, auf knapp 600 Ladezyklen gekommen. Allein auf der Batterie. Das heißt, wahrscheinlich so noch ein Jahr oder so, dann ist hier auch eine neue Batterie.
Ja, Batterie ist das Einzige, was mich so langsam, aber sicher in Richtung eines neuen Geräts drängt. Weil besser wird das halt nicht.
Das ist bei mir halt auch so. Ich habe den eigentlich fast immer am Strom. Sowohl hier den privaten als auch den in der Firma. Da kommen halt kaum Ladezyklen zusammen.
Ich habe 900 Ladezyklen in 5 Jahren. System Profiler, also hier baut das Mac, dann System Profiler und dann bei Power. Und da gibt es dann in der Reihe einen Cycle Count, der bei mir gerade zufälligerweise auf 911 ist.
Oh, ich gucke einfach mal mit der Coconut-Batterie.
Das ist ganz schön alt, das Tui, oder? Okay, das update ich immer noch, aber es gibt schon ganz schön lange.
Hä, wo muss ich denn da jetzt gucken?
Wie viele Load-Cycles hastest du gerade?
911, ja. Ist auch durch die Batterie. Die hält nicht mehr so wirklich lange.
Wo guckst du da? Ach, Anzahl der Zyklen. Hier, 201.
Das ist aber noch ziemlich frisch, der Rechner dann, oder?
Von, warte, Ende 13 steht hier.
Ich hab den, glaub ich, damals auch relativ bald, er vorgestellt wurde, gekauft.
Ja, also ich hab halt nicht mehr so viele Ladezüge, seitdem ich zu Hause auf MacBook Pro setze.
Tja, also ich bin auch bei 3,8 Ampere-Stunden und Design war mal 5,1.
Verbleibende Ladung und volle Ladekapazität.
Welche Fehler euch Koko hatte, Battery?
Bei mir sind irgendwie 30 mAh runter von der vollen Ladekapazität.
Oder?
Auf jeden Fall glaube ich nicht, dass ich mir eins von den neuen MacBook Pros im Affekt kaufen werde.
Nee, im Affekt nicht, auf keinen Fall.
Erstens sind sie auch nicht gerade billig. Also es ist auch alles ganz schön teurer geworden. Ja, ganz schön viel teurer geworden. Worauf auch immer sie da reagieren. Dadurch, dass sie jetzt das 11 Zoll MacBook Air rausgeschmissen haben, ist auch die Einstiegshöhe für den ganzen MacBook Spaß quasi auf die Höhe von dem neuen MacBook One gestiegen und liegt irgendwie weit über 1300 Euro, glaube ich.
Das war übrigens massiv verwirrend am Montag in dem Apple Store. Die haben ja immer diese Preise-App und da machst du die auf und da sind da Geräte, Geräte, Geräte, Geräte, Geräte drin. Irgendwo steht dieser Mac und du denkst dir so, äh?
Welche Preise-App meinst du denn?
Wenn du im Apple Store an so ein Gerät rangehst, dann gibt es dieses schwebende Fenster, überall schwebende Fenster, wo der Preis von dem Rechner, was das Feiner ist, und der Preis steht da. Ja, auf dem Bildschirm. Und wenn du dieses Fenster anklickst, dann bekommst du halt ein großes Fenster, ein richtiges App-Fenster von einer App und die heißt Preise oder so ähnlich.
Glaub ich.
Und da kannst du dich dann so durchklicken und da gibt es halt irgendwie dann so eine große Auflistung von Geräten und irgendwo steht mit Rot dran dieser Mac. Super verwirrend. Ich hab ja auch das eine Foto gepostet von dem von dem 15 Zoll mit DVD-Laufwerk noch, was da auch noch rumstand und auch noch zu kaufen war irgendwie. Also ich weiß nicht, was da abgeht.
Na ja, auf jeden Fall teuer ist schon mal der erste Punkt. Dann, ich hänge halt an so ein paar Sachen und sehe gerade, also Körsertastatur, Körsertasten hatten wir gerade, so finde ich halt nicht geiler. Das heißt, man kauft sich da was ein, was eben nicht so geil ist und da stehe ich nicht so drauf. Genau, dasselbe Problem habe ich auch mit meinem iMac hier. Würde ich jetzt meinen iMac gegen den aktuellen iMac austauschen, dann hätte ich zwar 5K und Performance und Hass nicht gesehen.
Die kannst du aber nicht extern anschließen an deinen anderen Rechner.
Richtig, ich kann den nicht mehr als externen Bildschirm betreiben.
Das ist für mich total der Killer von den iMacs.
Das ist für mich auch der totale Killer und zum Mac Pro brauch ich glaube ich nichts zu sagen. Da haben wir jetzt schon oft genug darüber geredet. Sprich, egal was ich jetzt kaufe, ich würde auf irgendeinen Lieblingsfeature verzichten und naja, deswegen weiß ich halt auch nicht, es wird halt auch sehr viele Leute geben, die dieses MacBook Pro erstmal nicht kaufen. Klar, sicherlich ist diese Leiste dann auch schon eher was für Power-User, was so ein bisschen der anderen These, die vorhin hier durch den Raum flog, widerspricht, dass es ja dann eben auch gerade so für Anfänger hilfreich wäre. Ich glaube auch eher.
Power-User nehmen F-Tasten. Die sind eher so blind am Start. Die brauchen dieses...
Das kommt auf die Art von Power-User, also Unix-Power-User vielleicht. So Oldschool, 80er-Jahre-Power-User. Die kommen damit klar.
Wenn einer Photoshop macht, dann hat er seine Actions doch da auch auf den Tasten. Da guckt er da nicht hin. Das weiß der alles.
Das glaube ich auch.
Er hat den Kontext sozusagen im Kopf, der muss den nicht sehen.
Die haben sowieso ihre spezielle Tastatur, die mit ganz vielen bunten Tasten ist, wo irgendwie dann auf jeder Taste draufsteht, was für eine Aktion die auslöst und so weiter. Also das ist so, weil ich hab halt auch das Gefühl, dass die Touchbar halt dafür da ist, dass sie Aktionen, von denen man nicht weiß, dass sie existieren, einem anbietet, damit man lernt, was man mit einem Programm machen kann. Das ist halt nicht für Leute, die ihr Programm in- und auswendig kennen, das sie jeden Tag benutzen. Es ist vielleicht praktisch, dass die eine oder andere Funktion schneller da ist.
Aber jetzt sage ich es mal ganz ketzerisch. Wenn man das haben will, dann hätte man den Touchbar auch auf dem Bildschirm machen können. Dann hätte man das in jedem Programm, auf jedem Rechner, überall.
Du willst doch Fullscreen haben und du willst das eben nicht, dass dein schickes Foto durch andere Grafik versaut wird. So wie die Leute, die viel mit Grafik machen, hier nicht ein buntes, die viel mit Grafik machen, ein buntes GUI haben, sondern auf grau umschalten, damit die Farben nicht ablenken.
Na gut, aber dann könnte man ein iPad nehmen. Warum kann ich nicht das iPad an das System anmelden und sagen, hier liegt jetzt ein iPad. Mach alle speziellen Kontext-Kontrollen hier drauf.
Die Sache ist ja, wer weiß, vielleicht kommt das ja sogar.
Nein, der eigentliche Punkt ist, an diese Dinger kommst du ran, ohne halt deine Arme hochheben zu müssen, so ergonomisch. Kommst du halt gerade bis oben an die, aber selbst zwei Zentimeter, ein Zentimeter weiter oder zwei Zentimeter musst du schon halt ganz andere Muskeln in Betrieb nehmen und für das iPad auch. Das heißt, es ist halt, dann kannst du auch gleich ein Touchscreen nehmen. Also der ist dann, ja. Ich glaube, das ist der entscheidende Unterschied. Und deswegen, also ich gebe dem ganzen eine Chance. Ich halte es für möglich, dass es geil ist. Und eigentlich würde ich auch erwarten, dass Apple, bevor die halt das Ganze jetzt zehn Millionenfach produzieren und herstellen, dass sie halt schon sich eine Gruppe von Leuten da mal drangesetzt hat und das halt auch einfach getestet hat und die Leute gefragt hat auch. Also das traue ich.
Also ich finde das ist jetzt schon ziemlich geil eigentlich. Und ich denke immer, dass die geilen Innovationen von den Third-Party-Developers, die kommen erst noch.
Also sie prototypen eigentlich immer relativ viel. Und zum Beispiel aus iOS, es hat ja in iOS nie das Hamburger Menü gegeben von Apple. Gut, es gibt immer Leute, die es gebaut haben, aber von Apple gab es es nie. Sondern es gab immer unten diese Tab Bar, wo du halt zwischen drei, vier, fünf Optionen wählen konntest. Und fertig. Und nach umzig Versionen Android sagt Google plötzlich, macht unten eine Tab Bar hin. Die haben dafür ein Ding gebaut. Und das ist jetzt der neueste heiße Scheiß unter Android, es so zu machen, wie es bei iOS halt unter iPhone 1 das allererste Gerät schon war. Weil offensichtlich Apple wirklich das Prototyping sehr, sehr, sehr gut gemacht hat und gemerkt hat, alles andere als das da unten hin zu machen, ist halt erschass. Also ich kann mir vorstellen, wenn die wirklich an dieser Touchbar jetzt fünf Jahre gearbeitet haben, oder lass es drei Jahre sein, dann kann ich mir durchaus vorstellen, dass sie halt auch Varianten versucht haben und gebaut haben und Leute davor gesetzt haben, wo halt irgendwie alle dachten, super Idee, und dann hat es keiner benutzen können. Und dass das dann die Lösung war, wo sie rauskam, die zumindest irgendwie funktioniert. Also da ist sicherlich auch hier shiny shiny Leucht und Touch und so. Das ist sicherlich ein Teil dessen, warum jetzt unbedingt so eine Bar her musste. Aber dass die so ist, wie sie ist, ist bestimmt auch ein langer Prototyping-Prozess gewesen. Weil das machen sie schon. Also Steve, weg hin oder her.
Keine Frage, aber das werden sie auch mit anderen Computern gemacht haben. Das werden sie auch mit einem Cube gemacht haben.
Da wäre ich mir beim Cube gar nicht sicher, dass sie den groß geprototypt haben. Da wollten sie einen coolen Rechner bauen. Lass uns den mal hier so und fertig.
Ja gut, wenn sie das da nicht gemacht haben, ist die Aussage, dass sie alles prototypen, natürlich auch Bogus. Ob sie das hier ausreichend getan haben.
Aber einen Rechner hochkant hinzustellen und das Laufwerk oben zu machen, das ist jetzt, das ist was, wo man sagt, das ist ein cooles Design, das wollen wir so sehen. Und dann prototypt man es halt nicht so sehr. Ich meine, der Cube...
Das Problem war nicht, dass die CD nach oben ging.
Das Problem war, dass er zu teuer war. Und...
Auch?
Dass es auch niemanden interessiert hat, so ein Rechner.
Nee, der hatte einfach ganz praktische Probleme mit diesem Rechner. Na, erstmal, die Kabel gingen alle nach unten. Versucht mal an diesem Rechner was anzuschließen. Das war eine Katastrophe. Du musstest das immer, immer den irgendwie umkippen. Ja, wo er dann immer so Gefahr lief, auch wirklich dabei umzufallen auf das schöne Acryl.
Hattest du mal einen oder weswegen?
Ich weiß das ja genau. Ich hatte nicht einen selbst, aber ich war damals in der Uni und da hatten wir so einen Teil stehen und musste das halt irgendwie administrieren. Der geilste Effekt war natürlich, dass oben dieser leuchtete Touch-Knopf zum Einschalten und zum Sleepen war. Und dann immer alle so, oh, das ist der neue Cube, darf ich ihn mal anfassen? Weil wir natürlich immer erst mal den Rechner ausgeschaltet haben. So eine Sache, da fehlte ein gewisses Maß an Prototyp. Deswegen bin ich da etwas zurückhaltend, wenn sie jetzt hier so großkotzig sagen, hier die geilste Nummer. Aber es ist halt beschränkt erst mal nur auf eine Generation. Es ist überhaupt etwas, was nur mit Laptops so funktioniert und was man noch mal hinterfragen muss für Desktop. Und meinetwegen sind Desktop irgendwie nicht mehr so wichtig. Aber letztlich sind auch die Desktops Teil dieser Plattform. Und dann müsste man sich ja fragen, wenn sie sagen, wieso geht doch bei Laptops, der Rest ist es doch egal. Dann muss ich halt die Frage fragen, okay, sind dann die Desktops nicht mehr Teil dieser Plattform? Also habe ich sozusagen einen Malus?
Aber vier Jahre alter Mac Pro, die Frage, die steht sowieso seit geraumer Zeit im Raum, also da kommst du jetzt auf einer Touchbar nicht mehr an. Also, und du musst zugeben, dass der Cube kam in einer Zeit, als Apple jetzt auch nicht gerade auf der Höhe der Zeit war.
Der Cube ist mir in dem Zusammenhang auch vollkommen egal, ich sag nur, die Touchbar muss ich erst nochmal beweisen.
Der Mac Pro, jetzt mal abgesehen davon, dass er nicht wirklich Pro ist, weil man nichts reinstecken kann und so weiter, hat ja diese Probleme vom Cube nicht gehabt. Also, den müssen sie ja irgendwie geprototypt haben. Du kannst ihn ja sogar...
Doch, der Mac Pro hat auch so ein Problem von diesem Cube.
Ist der nicht irgendwie drehbar gelagert, dass du in die Kabel kommst und so?
Na, erstmal steht er genauso düsselig auf dem Tisch rum.
Du kannst ihn auch unter den Tisch stellen. Ist wahrscheinlich nicht gut, weil er den ganzen Staub ran saugt.
Nee, ist vor allem nicht gut, weil du ja dann hinten Kabel anschließen musst, ohne die du diesen Rechner ja nicht betreiben kannst.
Ja, aber das Problem hast du bei jedem Desktop oder unterm Desk, also Desk Bottom.
Nein, aber nicht, wenn er dafür gemacht ist, unterm Tisch zu stehen, wie zum Beispiel ein ordentlicher Mac Pro. Aber dieser komische, diese komische...
Ja, aber dann musst du ja trotzdem unter den Tisch robben, um was anzuschließen. Ich verstehe jetzt den...
Der hat einen Griff, den kannst du nach vorne, nach hinten schieben. Das ist einfach dafür gemacht, unterm Tisch zu stehen.
Der rollt halt auch nicht weg. Oder er kippt nicht um, weil die Kabel so eine starke Drehung haben, dass sie den Rechner umschmeißen.
Ja, dann dreht sich das Ding auch noch.
Der ist ja jetzt relativ schwer, also umfallen tut der jetzt mal nicht so schnell.
Wie lange machen wir denn jetzt noch? Und was haben wir denn noch für Punkte?
Ich wollte eigentlich als Punkt tatsächlich diese Desktop-Debatte nochmal aufmachen, weil das ist ja sozusagen etwas, was aus diesem Touchbar herauskommt. Deswegen betone ich das auch so. Man macht jetzt ein User-Interface, man adelt das im Rahmen dieser Kino zu der dritten Wiedergeburt des Macintosh. Aber es ist halt reduziert auf eine bestimmte Geräteklasse. Parallel dazu haben wir einen Mac Mini, der irgendwie gefühlt seit drei, vier Jahren keinerlei dinswerte Evolutionen mehr gesehen hat, vielleicht sogar seit fünf. Und ein Mac Pro, der schon auch ein paar Jahre lang nicht mehr wirklich aktualisiert wurde, dann wurde er aktualisiert und jetzt seit drei Jahren überhaupt nicht mehr auch nur im Ansatz, nicht mal durch irgendein GPU- oder CPU-Upgrade oder irgendwas. Und das ist halt das, was mich so ein bisschen zu diesem Kotz-Tweet gebracht hat. Dass ich mir einfach nur dachte so, ja schön, jetzt habt ihr da irgendwie was ein bisschen vorgestellt, aber keiner sieht, was eure Strategie ist. Keiner spürt, wohin die Reise geht. Es gibt einfach kein Vertrauen in diesen Pfad. Man kann da jetzt alles Mögliche rauslesen. Man kann auch diese MacBook Pros geil oder exciting finden. Sind sie sicherlich ein Stück weit auch. Nur, wo ist die Botschaft, wie es weitergeht? Was ist die Mac-Plattform? Was ist nach dem Mac Pro?
Ich hatte hier noch diesen einen Link ziemlich weit unten. Die Veränderung von Apples Revenue Mix über die letzten 20 Jahre. Da ist halt eine sehr schöne Grafik drin, wie sich die Umsatzanteile seit 1997 sind jetzt 20 Jahre verändert hat. Und Apple war halt 1997 zu 100% Macintosh. Also gab es nichts anderes. Power Mac, iMac, Powerbook. Und jetzt ist es so, Apple macht, oder in 2015 war es so, roundabout zwei Drittel des Umsatzes von Apple macht das iPhone, also bringt das iPhone zwei Drittel.
Und das iPad so viel wie der Mac.
iPad, Mac und Services liegen ungefähr jeweils gleich auf. Bei 10-12% würde ich sagen so in der Gegend. Und dann nochmal, ich weiß nicht, 3-4% andere Produkte. Und das ist natürlich, wie gesagt, jetzt wirtschaftlich gesehen, jetzt oder rein vom Umsatz her, ist für Apple der Mac ungefähr nur noch so wichtig wie das iPad. Was wir ja auch wissen, das ist das iPad.
Da hab ich aber ein schönes Gegenargument gehört. Und zwar, warum investieren Autofirmen in das Racing, in Formel 1, in andere Dinge?
Weil das Werbung ist.
Weil sie damit beweisen, dass sie die Cojones haben, dass sie die Technologie haben, um halt auch die Besten zu sein und in den anderen Produkten auch glänzen zu können. Und genau so ein Racing-Produkt fehlt Apple aber.
Umgekehrt, aber um das nochmal abzuschließen, in absoluten Dimensionen, ist halt der Mac-Anteil, also der Umsatz absolut, sind so 20, 30 Milliarden würde ich schätzen, sind die Macs alleine im Jahr. Alleine im Jahr. Und das ist halt mehr als in den goldenen Zeiten, also mehr als in den zurückgegangenen Zeiten. Ist nie wirklich groß zurückgegangen, das heißt, es ist immer noch verdammt viel. Und jetzt kommen wir zu deinen Desktops. So 2012 hat Apple aufgehört, die Desktop-Umsätze getrennt öffentlich auszuweisen und insofern ist...
Das darf man auch nur machen, wenn sie einen geringen Anteil spielen, richtig? Die dürfen das ja nicht einfach weglassen, die müssen das ja öffentlich machen.
So, das heißt einfach, dass das Thema Desktop wahrscheinlich so umsatzmäßig, keine Ahnung, ja wahrscheinlich in der Adapter-Gegend oder so, wahrscheinlich verdienen sie genau so viel mit Netzteilen.
Das hat natürlich auch den Grund, weil wenn sie keine ordentlichen Desktop anbieten, dann kauft die natürlich auch keiner, weil keine da sind oder weil niemand kauft jetzt noch so eine runde Tonne außerhalb, keine Ahnung, weil ja entweder eine neue kommt oder es kommt keine mehr, aber dieses alte Ding willst du eigentlich nicht mehr. Das ist voll überholt und Apple nimmt ja auch den Preis um keinen Cent runter, richtig? Das kostet genauso viel wie vor drei Jahren mit dem gleichen Scheiß, den keiner mehr will.
Ja und was sie sich damit natürlich kaputt machen, ist so eine Third-Party-Software-Anbieter und auch Hardware-Anbieter, die halt sagen, warum soll ich denn was für ein Mac produzieren? Das hat ja keinen Sinn, also am schlimmsten fand ich ja das als, was war das Oculus Rift, die neueste Version, als sie gesagt haben Mac? Nee, Mac brauchen wir nicht zu unterstützen. Es gibt keinen Mac, der Powerful genug wäre, irgendwie die Oculus Rift, die neueste überhaupt zu fahren. Selbst der Mac Pro nicht. Das mag ja sein, aber was ist denn das für eine Message dahinter, wenn du sagst, hier haben wir eine Gaming-Brille und nicht mal der Mac Pro hat genug Power, die zu unterstützen. Das sollte den Jungs in Cupertino hochnotpeinlich sein, dass sich so jemand hinstellt und sowas sagt.
Auf der anderen Seite hat Apple trotz dieser miesen Strategie Marktanteile auf dem gesamten PC-Markt, was jetzt der OS X-Anteil angeht.
Das heißt jetzt Mac OS.
Dieses BSD, was da läuft. Die sind halt jetzt im letzten Jahr erstmals auf 10% des Marktanteils.
Was für ein Marktanteil?
PC-Betriebssystem.
Nach Verkäufen, nicht nach Browser-Statistiken?
Jede Statistik hat irgendwie ihre Macken.
Ich weiß, ich wollte nur wissen, welche.
Ich glaube installierte Basis.
Installierte Basis, das ist ja nochmal eine ganz andere Nummer. Es ist ja kein Marktanteil.
Na ja, Betriebssystem.
Ja, aber es ist kein Marktanteil.
Schon insofern, als das... Sie verkaufen es zwar nicht mehr, oder die upgrades nicht, beziehungsweise bezahlst du es halt mit der Hardware mit, aber nichtsdestotrotz...
Install-Base ist natürlich super wichtig, gar keine Frage.
Im Mai...
Der Punkt ist ja auch nicht so, dass Sie auf den Mac verzichten könnten. Ich meine, es ist ja nicht so, dass Sie den weglassen können.
Das ist die andere Seite. Es ist halt ein unentbehrlicher Bestandteil des gesamten Ökosystems.
Ja, und vor allem, Sie verdienen so scheiße viel Geld. Und das ist das, was mich jetzt auch an dieser ganzen Mac Pro und insbesondere auch nochmal an dieser Mac Mini-Situation noch stört. Sie schwächen halt diese Plattform, wenn Sie nicht auch den Mut haben selbst... Also es muss ja nicht defizitär laufen, aber Sie brechen sich da keinen Zacken aus der Krone und mehren den Wert der Plattform als solche, wenn Sie mehr Variabilität reinbringen in die Art und Weise, wie man diese Geräte nutzt. Mag ja sein, dass die meisten Leute sich über ein MacBook Pro lehnen wollen und dann geil irgendwie auf ihrer Tastatur da auf dem Touchscreen rumfummeln wollen. Super geschenkt, sollen es 90-95% der Leute sein. Aber was so ein Mac Mini an strategischer Benutzbarkeit auf einmal mit sich bringt, weil du weißt, na so ein Teil, da verhältnismäßig billig, da schieb ich mir einen ins Regal, dann kann ich das so und so aufbauen. Niemand würde dann MacBook Pros an dieselbe Stelle stellen, sondern dann ist das ein Projekt, was du nicht verfolgst. Und dasselbe gilt natürlich auch für High-End, wo es halt auch klar sein muss, wenn ich überhaupt auf diese Plattform setze, dann muss ich zumindest mit der technologischen Entwicklung in Geruchsweite sein. Also ich will ja jetzt nicht mal sagen, der Mac Pro muss jetzt bei allen Benchmarks auf Platz 1 sein und so weiter. Der muss mithalten können, der muss binnen eines Jahres immer wieder aktualisiert werden und dem Trend folgen. Und genau das ist das, was sie derzeit nicht tun. Die Frage ist natürlich jetzt, warum? So, und die eine...
Es gibt keine gute Erklärung dafür.
Nein, vielleicht gibt es keine gute Erklärung, aber man kann ja zumindest mal darüber nachdenken, was jetzt der Grund ist. So, und ich könnte mir halt zwei Sachen vorstellen. Das eine ist so die offensive These, die ja jetzt auch gerade kräftig durchs Internet gejagt wird. Apple hat keinen Bock mehr, verdient dann mit nicht genug Geld, weil sie verdienen ja woanders mehr und ihnen geht es ja nur ums Geld. Was ich so nie unterschreiben würde, ehrlich gesagt, bei Apple. Und sie haben halt gesehen, du kaufst jetzt keiner mehr, dann ist ihnen das scheißegal und die lassen den Mac Pro jetzt auslaufen und in den USA produzieren, war sowieso ein Fehler. So, und der Mac Mini stirbt dann halt auch einfach mit, weil wird ja nicht mehr aktualisiert. Kann man so sehen? Lesen bestimmt viele Leute auch so.
Aber ich glaube, dass der Mac Mini tatsächlich noch relativ viel gekauft wird, weil das ist eigentlich das Gerät, was du als iOS-Developer, als Continuous Integration Server haben musst, wenn du dir nicht einen Mac Pro hinstellst. Also wenn du irgendwie Continuous Integration machen willst und willst, dass dein...
Also weil es da eine Büchse ist, die die ganze Zeit deinen Code übersetzt.
Du machst einen Check-In und die Büchse baut deinen Code, macht deine Unit-Tests, macht deine UI-Tests, macht diesen ganzen Rümpel. Das macht inzwischen jeder. Wer es nicht macht, kann man nur mit dem Kopf schütteln. Warum nicht?
Ja gut, wenn aber Developer das kaufen müssen, dann haben sie da nicht viel Pressure.
Ja, wahrscheinlich ist die Kiste auch deswegen so scheiße, weil sie halt noch läuft, weil irgendwer, irgendwer sich immer dieses Ding irgendwo in die Ecke stellen muss. Weil du brauchst es halt, irgendwie.
Jetzt mach ich eine zweite These auf. Sie haben gesehen, dass es mit den Mac Mini ein schwieriges Ding ist.
Ist es ja auch wahrscheinlich.
Komplizierter Formfaktor ist irgendwie klein, Wärmeprobleme, lalalala.
Nee, Wärmeprobleme überhaupt nicht. Überhaupt nicht. Also ganz ehrlich.
Wärmeprobleme, die dabei bedacht werden müssen, kann es halt da keine Highend-Prozessoren reinstecken, ist sozusagen prinzipbedingt in der Performance beschränkt. Und auf der anderen Seite hast du den Mac Pro, der wiederum maximale thermale Ablüftungen bereitstellt und den totalen Overkill macht, um sozusagen das Maximale, was sie gerade für vertretbar halten, abzurocken. So, aber im Prinzip decken beide Geräte einen ähnlichen Markt ab. Nämlich diesen Desktop-ohne-Bildschirm-Markt. Könnte ja sein, dass sie angefangen haben, ihre Strategie zu überdenken und vielleicht eine Geräteplattform rausbringen, die diesen Mac Pro und Mac Mini in irgendeiner Form zusammenbringt. Wo du irgendwie mehr Skalierungen hast und wo sie dieses Segment für sich auch erfrischender bauen können und besser skalieren können. Ist nur so eine These.
Halt dich für unwahrscheinlich. Meiner Meinung nach sollte Apple irgendwie zurück...
Und dass sie noch mal so eine Tonne rausbringen?
Die Tonne war ein großer Fehler, meiner Meinung nach. Meiner Meinung nach sollten sie was rausbringen, was eine normale PC-Büchse ist, vom Innenleben her. Du hast ein Mainboard, du hast ein paar andere Bauteile, alles billig, darf von außen ruhig schön aussehen, mit einem gebürsteten Apfel und allem drum und dran. Ein schöner Klappmechanismus, dass man das Gefühl hat, man hat was Wertiges. Aber im Prinzip, eigentlich willst du ja Grafikkarte Mainboard steckbar, sodass sie mindestens einmal im Jahr ein Update machen können, wenn es auch nur ein Silent-Update ist, wo sie ein neues Mainboard reinstecken, dann kriegst du mal einen neuen Prozessor, dann kriegst du wieder ein neues Mainboard, alle halbe Jahr eine neue Grafikkarte, sodass sie vorne dabei sind. Das ist das, was sie eigentlich machen müssten. Möglichst klein Mac Mini, ich gebe dir recht, das ist zwar irgendwie ein schönes Ding, hat auch nicht wirklich thermische Probleme, aber das ist halt auch so eine Sonderanfertigung für so einen Markt, der halt nicht riesig ist und dann auch nicht so billig zu produzieren ist, dass du mit dem Ding wirklich Geld verdienst.
Warum nicht eine Plattform für Headless-Macs bauen, die quasi von kleinem Bedarf zu großem Bedarf skaliert, die irgendwie serverplatzierungsfreundlich ist und nicht nur auf dem Tisch, sondern halt auch irgendwie im Rack irgendetwas, was wirklich sinnvoll ist und diesen gesamten Bereich abdeckt? Also ich denke, Sie müssen da in dem nächsten halben Jahr auf jeden Fall eine Antwort drauf liefern, sonst verdienen die Leute vollkommen die Hoffnung.
Einmal von euch in letzter Zeit, ich sag mal, in den letzten zwölf Monaten mal selber einen PC zusammengestellt und zusammengebaut.
Nicht in den letzten zwölf Monaten, aber doch zumindest in den letzten 24 oder 36 Monaten.
Hat sich da irgendwas dran geändert?
Ich hab das ja sehr lange nicht gemacht, ich weiß gar nicht wann. Ich hab's jetzt vor einem halben Jahr oder so hab ich es tatsächlich gemacht und davor, keine Ahnung, 5, 7.
So mit Mainboard selber kaufen und so?
Mit alles, einzeln mit Mainboard und Gehäuse und Netzteil und Grafikkarte und RAM und CPU auswählen, also alles mit zwei Tage recherchieren.
Nur zwei Tage?
Ich muss sagen, es hat sich da eine ganze Menge getan. Einmal was das ganze Thema Lüftung angeht, Sammelmanagement, Netzteilqualitäten und so, das fand ich beeindruckend. Also da ist gegenüber fünf Jahren so heutige PC-Gehäuse. Ja, also leise.
Was man kauft.
Ja, ja, klar. Aber jetzt schon nichts super teures. Ich sag mal, ein Gehäuse zwischen 100-150 Euro Kategorie. Die Netzteile sind leise, die Lüfter sind leise geworden, die die Gehäuse selbst machen. Früher war das ja alles so ein Taiwan-Blechpress-Schrott. Da hast du jetzt schon teilweise mit Alufinish und mit richtig auch teilweise geilen Wegen, um die Kabel schick zu verlegen und so.
Öffnungsmechanismen?
Also auch eine komplette Auswahl und so. Also da hat sich, muss ich sagen, elektromechanisch hat sich wirklich eine ganze Menge getan. An der Stelle gut.
Musst du noch eher Q-Jumper?
Aber manche Bauteile kaufst du einfach zweimal, weil das Betriebssystem deiner Wahl sie dann doch nicht unterstützt. Oder die Kombination Mainboard-Steckkarte einfach nicht tut. Und auch nach dem 25. Firmware-Update immer noch nicht tut. Also das ist so, das passiert halt immer noch.
Und ja, selbst ein bisschen teilweise zu den Kühlungen von den Grafikkarten und so alles ziemlich abgefahren. Und die Vielfalt an Lüfterkonstruktionen. Und dann natürlich, was ich jetzt halt nicht gemacht hab, dann die ganze Wasserkühlungsszene. Also es gibt eine so große Auswahl jetzt auch an Möglichkeiten, wassergekühlt zu arbeiten und die entsprechenden Größen. Also will nur sagen, selbst wenn man jetzt mit relativ, also mit relativ wenig Geld, kann man sich wirklich ziemlich nette Kisten zusammenstellen.
Du redest jetzt im Wesentlichen schon auch von diesen, mit den ganz vielen Grafikkarten, die du da verwendest.
Ja, also jetzt schon.
Ich war da halt mehr so auf der Server-Seite, ich hab immer Bild in Grafikkarte von dem Chipset benutzt.
Ohne Lüfter oder so, genau.
Ja, weil das war mir alles irgendwie, macht eh nur Text.
Ne, plus, also und natürlich hier so die M2, also mittlerweile alle Motherboards haben irgendwie ein bis drei M2-Slots, wo man gar keine Festplatten mehr reinmachen muss, sondern nur noch so ein Modul da reinsteckt, dann fällt auch die Karbelage weg dafür. Ja, das desbooten von M2 ist.
Teilweise, ist ein Problem noch aktuell, aber ja. Das ist der erste Rechner, der von diesen M2-Modulen booten konnte, weil die hatten halt einen EFI-Bios irgendwie drauf, oder wie auch immer man das nennt, und die Mac Pros konnten schon von booten, und die PC Motherboards, die waren noch nicht so richtig so weit mit ihrem Bios das so richtig zum booten auch zum Nutzen.
Das ist so ein kleines Projekt, was ich eigentlich nochmal angehen wollte, war mir einen ordentlichen Hackintosh zu bauen. Da gibt es ja diese TonyMacX86.com-Seite, die immer wieder jeden Monat einen neuen Bios Guide rausbringen. Das kann irgendwie nicht so schwer sein, wenn die das so machen.
Deswegen müssen die aber auch jeden Monat rausbringen. Da musst du halt dann basteln, machen, tun, gucken und so weiter. Ich hab ja meinen alten Bitcoin Gaming-Kiste, wo ich halt drei Grafikkarten gleichzeitig drin hatte. Der steht jetzt im Club, den haben wir jetzt umgebaut. Der ist jetzt Hashcat-Maschine. Also nicht Deep Learning, sondern der kann jetzt Passwörter knacken, damit man da mal ein bisschen Passwörter knacken kann.
Falls einem sowas passiert wie Huckel, meinste?
Dafür wäre das genau das Richtige. Er meinte ja auch, dass man seinen Anfang von seinem Passwort wusste. Aber hinten waren ja nur am Ende seiner Story, hat er doch gesagt. Da waren irgendwie zwei, drei Sachen. Aber das meiste wusste er eigentlich noch. Und bei diesem Hashcat kannst du sagen, hier die Buchstaben, die sind fix. Dann hier drei, weiß ich nicht, was es ist. Dann weiß ich, kam da auf jeden Fall noch eine Zahl, aber ich weiß nicht welche. Und dann kamen noch mal die beiden Zeichen. Und wenn man das alles so einträgt, dann testet dann nur die durch, die variabel sind. Und diese Grafikkarten, die rocken dann da durch. Und je mehr du reinsteckst, umso schneller ist das Ding. Und Progress sagte der auch, das ist ungefähr irgendwie zweieinhalb Tagen fertig oder in vier Stunden. Je nachdem, was man da so reinsteckt. Sind zwar jetzt nicht die neuesten Grafikkarten, aber dafür war for free und rockt dick.
Worauf wolltest du denn jetzt hinaus mit der PC?
Ich wollte darauf hinaus, dass man sich sagen, jetzt von der Hardware her, wie auch vom elektromechanischen Design und so, für relativ wenig Geld, man ziemlich geile Kisten kriegt. Im Gegensatz zu jetzt bei Laptops, so sagen wir Laptops, kommt ja noch bei den Macs dazu. Das ist irgendwie nach meiner Erfahrung die einzigen Rechner sind, die du einfach zuklappen und wieder aufklappen kannst. Und das über Wochen hinweg ohne irgendwelche negativen Auswirkungen zu haben oder mal booten zu müssen oder das nicht hochkommt oder so, sondern das ist einfach so just works. Und zumindest in einem gewissen Rahmen, also die Abstimmung von Hard- und Software ist halt einfach das Ding. Und jetzt bei den Desktops, glaube ich, ist dieser Faktor nicht so bedeutend. Und da ist halt die Frage, wie groß der Markt jetzt für Desktops bei Mac-Usern ist. Natürlich gibt es den, die werden ja auch verkauft. Aber meine Befürchtung ist, dass die Vorteile, die Apple hat bei den Laptops, nicht so, bei den Desktops vergleichsweise nicht so groß sind.
Aber ich glaube auch nicht, dass sie in dem Moment so sehr mit den PCs in Konkurrenz stehen. Hier geht es einfach wirklich nur um Leute in der Plattform zu halten, was ja seinen Reiz eben auch unter anderem von den Portables bezieht. Das ist ja das Argument für den Mac. Wie gut ihnen diese Laptops gelungen sind. Sie müssen ja jetzt nicht so einen Mega-Wurf machen. Mein Gott, ich meine auch dieser Mac Mini ist eher eine Frage des Preises. Shave 100 bucks off.
Naja, das Problem ist, der ganz kleine Mac Mini, der kostet jetzt auch schon 600 Euro oder so und hat nur einen 1,4 GHz Prozessor drin. Das ist halt totaler Gülle. Dafür zahlst du dann schon 1,2. Dann ist es aber auch keine Desktop-Performance, sondern du hast da eigentlich nur einen Laptop ohne Display. Das ist irgendwie so, was du denkst.
Das ist das Ding. Ich denke, dass sie da sehr viel in besseres Angebot machen könnten und es aus irgendwelchen Gründen nicht tun, die ich nicht verstehe. Ich meine, gerade wenn man sich halt anschaut, wie es schon auf so einem freien PC-Markt, der ja eigentlich eher Nachteile hat, weil er gar nicht so gut integrieren kann, weil jeder quasi auf jedem einzelnen Teil seine Marge voll durch die Hände durchkriegen muss. Und Apple baut ja teilweise diese ganzen Steine auch selber. Da ist ja noch nicht mal ein anderer Hersteller dran beteiligt. Selbstverständlich können die ein Mac Mini bauen, der sie vielleicht, was weiß ich, 200 Euro kostet und den sie dann für, keine Ahnung, mal 300, 400 auf den Markt schmeißen könnte. In so einer Low-Version mit wenig SSD und Pipapo. Aber jetzt noch diese ganzen Mumpets mit Fusion, Drive und dann noch Festplatten da drin und so weiter. Bitte, einfach weg damit. Auch diese iMacs, einfach mach da überall einfach SSD rein. Das ist so jetzt noch mit rotierenden Platten hausieren zu gehen, ist einfach ein Fehler. Wo ich ein bisschen skeptisch geworden bin, ist halt die Sache mit dem Bildschirm. Also wenn sie das nicht ganz schnell fixen, dann werde ich langsam unruhig. Ja, aber gerade wenn du den Mac Mini kaufst, oder gerade wenn du den Mac Pro kaufst, oder etwas in der Kategorie, ey, dann willst du doch nicht auf so ein hässliches Plasteteil da schauen, den ganzen Tag. Also der Brand Estate, den der Bildschirm ausmacht.
Brand Estate?
Naja klar, ich mein so ein iMac drückt dir die ganze Zeit einfach den Apfel ins Gesicht und sagt, schau mich an, ich bin schön. Und jetzt empfehlen sie doch tatsächlich auf ihrer komischen Keynote, man soll sich da diesen Plastibomber von LG kaufen, mit diesen asymmetrischen Rändern.
Ja sag mal geht's noch?
Wo bitte ist das Problem, dass, ich meine, wenn sie denen da schon so geholfen haben, wo ist bitte das Problem, einfach da noch so einen Alurahmen drumrum zu machen, Apfellogo drauf zu klicken, 300 Euro mehr zu nehmen und fertig das Glauben?
Das macht nur Google.
Na, Geräte von anderen einkaufen und sein eigenes Zeug draufkleben.
Ich meine, Apple hat diese Displays noch nie selber gebaut. Und alles andere haben sie an Technologie. Ich meine, wer macht jetzt hier die ganze Zeit Thunderbolt? Apple weiß doch, wie das geht. Sie haben sowas ja auch schon mal gebaut.
Na ja gut, es kann natürlich sein, dass das einfach nicht fertig geworden ist. Oder dass sie irgendwie diese externe Grafikkarten-Nummer fahren wollen. Man weiß es nicht.
Was soll denn da nicht fertig geworden sein?
Was soll denn an einem 5K-Bildschirm nicht fertig werden? Apple verkauft das seit einem Jahr mit Computer. Sie müssen nur den Computer rauslassen und dann haben sie einen Bildschirm.
Ja gut, ganz so einfach ist es natürlich nicht.
Aber in einem Jahr schaffbar.
Ich traue ihnen das zu, dass sie da ein paar Leute kennen, die da schon mal was von gehört haben. Sollen sie mich anrufen?
Wir drehen uns im Kreis und alle Pfeile zeigen Richtung they don't care.
Das glaube ich auch.
Wenn sie uns einen Bildschirm nachschieben, dann hätten sie den jetzt nicht so vorgeschlagen.
Ja, natürlich ist es ein Fehler. Da sind wir uns ja einig. Nur die Indizien häufen sich, ne? Also das ist halt...
Man kann auch sagen, vielleicht ist das jetzt mit diesen MacBooks, vielleicht war das jetzt sozusagen ihre große Last und die musste jetzt erstmal abfallen.
Du meinst, das gesamte Hardware-Department Mac hat jetzt erstmal an den MacBooks arbeiten müssen?
Das nicht unbedingt, aber so auch in ihrem Rollout, ich meine, das hat ja auch was mit Produktionsstätten und Kapazitäten und Finanzflow Ihnen war sicherlich die MacBook Pros am wichtigsten von allem.
Wäre auch sinnvoll, weil von der Mac-Sparte ist wahrscheinlich das, womit sie wirklich am meisten Geld verdienen.
Vielleicht haben sie den Touchbar versucht, in die Bluetooth-Tastatur reinzukriegen und es performt nicht.
Oder die Mac Pros sehen... So Pizza-Schachtel und vorne dran gibt es die Touchbar. Oder das neue Apple-Display hat dann eine Touchbar. Kannst du dir das vorstellen? 27 Zoll mit irgendwie einem halben Meter Touchbar drunter?
Kann ich mir nicht vorstellen.
Nee, ich auch nicht, aber wär lustig.
So, wir können das jetzt, glaube ich, das Mac-Thema zu Ende bringen, oder? Ja, haben wir jetzt alles gesagt, Leute.
Haben wir noch Themen?
Das einzige, ja...
Das Einzige, was ich noch berichten möchte, ist mein Highlight am Apple Store Besuch war, im Tesla Store nebenan hatten sie ein Model X stehen. Und jetzt hab ich auch mal das Model X livehaftig gesehen. Und ich muss sagen, das ist ja ein Panzer, das ist ja unglaublich. Also das Teil ist dermaßen fett.
Das ist ein SUV.
Das ist ein SUV, ja. Aber ich hatte nicht damit gerechnet, dass das Ding wirklich so fett ist. Also es ist ein echtes SUV. Aber dafür hast du halt auch drei Sitzreihen, wo auch bequem erwachsene Menschen hintereinander sitzen können, ohne sich die Knie anzustoßen und alles. Und hast hinten auch noch Kofferraumplatz. Also es ist wirklich ein großes Auto.
Ja, ich mein...
Das sind bei Tesla momentan sowieso Preise, wo brauchen sehr relativ wird.
Gut, das ist nach wie vor das Grundproblem. Ich hätte ja auch gern was Elektrisches. Wenn ich so fahren würde wie mit meinem Turan, die Geschwindigkeit, die Strecken mit so einem Tesla, dann entspricht jetzt die aktuellen Batterien entsprechend ungefähr einem Tankinhalt Diesel 12 Liter. Also es ist ungefähr so, wie wenn ich einen Turan mit 12 Liter Tank hätte. Mehr ist da einfach nicht drin in diesen Batterien. Und wenn ich so fahre...
Du fährst wie eine gesenkte Sau.
Ich fahre 12 Liter.
Was für eine Reichweite rechnest du aus 12 Litern Diesel?
150 Kilometer? 250 bis 200 Kilometer. So ein Tesla Ding, wenn ich den so fahre wie mein Turan...
Da musst du aber Strich 250 fahren.
Nee, nix 250. So 180, 200.
Mit dem neuen Batterie-Update hat sich das sowieso alles verdoppelt.
Vergiss es. Wenn du 120 fährst, wenn du schleichst, so ja, aber wenn du Gas machst, 100 Kilometer, 150 Kilometer auf der Autobahn, also du schaffst keine 200 Kilometer, also wenn du 150 schaffst, wenn du sozusagen weitgehend Vollgas fährst, dann du hast dann keine Rekuperation. Nichts. Ich meine, das ist eine ganz einfache Rechnung. Ich habe es nicht nur durchgerechnet, sondern ich kenne genug Leute, die mit so etwas rumfahren, die halt sagen, vergiss es, Langstrecke kannst du knicken.
So habe ich auch schon andere Aussagen gehört.
Das sind dann Leute, die dann halt mit, also klar, wenn du mit 95 hinter einem LKW im Windschatten fährst, dann kommst du auch auf die 450 oder 500 Kilometer, die da angegeben sind. Aber nicht, wenn du Gas machst.
Ja, hier ist so eine Grafik, die das so anzeigt. Und sie meint, mit 100 kmh kommt man 430 Kilometer weit. Mit 32 kmh übrigens so 800 sogar. Aber wenn du schon, warte mal, das sind 430, wenn du schon 150 fährst, sind es nur noch 260. Und wenn du schon 180 fährst, sind es schon unter 200.
Ja, und 180 finde ich ist jetzt nicht so eine besondere Geschwindigkeit. Und das ist halt ein zehn Jahre alter Turan.
Also für den Start wäre er super sozusagen.
Und wie viel NOX und CO2 haut der so raus im Vergleich zum Tesla? Die Menge zum VW.
Ach das ist, das ist, das ist alles. Das ist eh alles, ich halte das eh alles für, ja was. An der Sache vorbei. Die ganze Diskussion um Volkswagen? Nein, die Diskussion um Abgaswerte oder um die Abgaswerte oder die Abgase, um die es da geht. Aber das wäre vielleicht mal eine Extrasendung. Fühlt so weit. Ich hätte ja gerne Elektromobilität, auch selber gerne persönlich, aber es ist halt einfach unbrauchbar. Das ist das Problem.
Ja, muss stattfinden. Wird auch stattfinden.
Leute beklagen, dass wir nicht über Touch-ID geredet haben. Wollen wir noch eine Minute über Touch-ID reden?
Was soll man denn da sagen?
Ich meine, man legt einen Finger drauf und kann bezahlen, das ist halt wie auf dem iPhone.
Naja, das ist aber eben nicht nur bezahlen, sondern auch locken, ne?
Es ist halt praktisch und gefährlich.
Ja, wie halt meisten Dinge praktisch und Apple Pay auf Webseiten.
Weil man dann halt nicht so oft sein Kennwort eintippen muss.
Ja, man vergisst es schneller.
Deswegen ist es praktisch und gefährlich, dass einen halt jederzeit jemand zwingen kann, seinen Finger da drauf zu legen.
Ja gut, das ist aber ein Angriffsszenario, was man vielleicht an jeder Grenze hat.
An jeder Grenze.
Grenzen und Flughäfen, ja.
Ja, schaltest du es halt vorher ab, den Scheiß. Außerdem nimmt man eh seinen Laptop nicht mit über Grenzen.
Wahrscheinlich hast du auch da so ein Drei-Versuche-Limit und dann nimmst du den falschen Finger dreimal.
Nee, du machst das am besten vorher schon dreimal weg, dass es nicht geht. Ganz einfach.
Also ich denke auch, das hängt sehr davon ab, wie sie es konkret eingebunden haben. Darüber weiß aber derzeit halt einfach noch niemand was. Deswegen ist es auch gerade so ein bisschen sinnlos, darüber zu reden. Es ist halt technisch genauso sauber gelöst, wie in der Watch und wie im iPhone.
Wahrscheinlich, ja.
Zumindest mit secure enclave und so weiter.
Also sauber geht es halt derzeit nicht.
Interessant an der Sache finde ich natürlich, dann macht es auch Sinn, dass die Touchbar selber halt ein komplett getrenntes System ist, weil die Touchbar dann eben auch die Anzeige jetzt leg mal deinen Finger auf das Ding, weil dann kannst du das und das tun, unter Kontrolle hat und du nicht mehr Scam-mäßig einfach nur Fingerprints abfangen kannst. Also wenn sie da ordentlich gearbeitet haben, dann sollte das zumindest halbwegs robust sein.
Und du kommst halt auch nicht an die Fingerabdrücke selber ran, so wie auf dem iPhone. Auch du keine Möglichkeit hast irgendwie.
Aber Details sind noch nicht bekannt insofern.
Also ich denke, ich werde es benutzen, genauso wie ich es beim iPhone benutze. Aber es ist halt kein Sicherheitsgewinn, meiner Meinung nach.
Nö, aber ich glaube, das behauptet auch keiner.
Das bezahlen auf jeden Fall schon.
Ja, über die gesamte Apple Pay Schiene?
Also Apple Pay über Rechner finde ich ja mal saugeil. Also ich auf jeden Fall eine bessere Nummer als...
In welchen Ländern war das gleich noch verfügbar?
Tja, nicht in Deutschland. Na gut, ich meine die Infrastruktur bat sich auf in dem Moment, wo... Also im Web ist das halt so eine Sache. Also gut, ich könnte halt... Das ist halt immer die Frage von wo buchts ab und so. Deswegen haben wir es in Deutschland nicht. Aber man kann ja dann auch nicht nur in Deutschland kaufen, wenn man dann so weit ist. Und das sehe ich schon als ein Feature an. Und ein bisschen schade eigentlich, dass es an diesen Bar gebunden ist. Zumindest auf dem Mac.
Also ich habe ja diese... Ich hatte vor ein paar Jahren mal mit dieser ganzen ich sag mal Zahlungs-Abwicklungs-Payments-Szene so ein bisschen Kontakt, weil ich halt auch ein bisschen was für PayPal, also PayPal was gemacht hab mit Läden und so. Sagen, alles organisierte Kriminelle. So. Das ist seit Jahrzehnten. Das ist also eine schlimmere Truppe. Ja, das ist... Ich weiß nicht...
Weißt du jetzt konkret nur die Online-Payment-Leute oder alles, was mit Finanzen zu tun hat?
Also ich rede jetzt nicht von normalen Geschäftsbanken, die jetzt Überweisung tätigen und ein Konto führen sollen. Ich rede jetzt halt von Kreditkarten im Wesentlichen. Also ist ja zu, weiß ich nicht... Also Payment, meine ich jetzt. Deswegen habe ich nicht gesagt Banking, sondern Payment und speziell elektronisch und so. Ja und technologisch ist das alles ein komplettes Desaster, aber dann auch noch, ich meine da geht es halt natürlich um viel Geld. Und da hängen so viele Parasiten dran an diesem ganzen Payment-Ding, die da irgendwie sich dazwischenhängen und selber auch noch Kohle abziehen. Also es steht in überhaupt gar keinem Verhältnis, also die Gebühren, die erhoben werden, stehen in überhaupt gar keinem Verhältnis zu dem, was tatsächlich an Kosten da ist. So was weiß ich jetzt hier in Kreditkarten, zwischen drei und sechs Prozent oder so, wenn da Leute sitzen würden, die irgendwie von Hand die Dinger prüfen und abzeichnen, dann wäre das vielleicht angemessen, diese Gebühren. Heutzutage mit dem Grad der Automatisierung hat sich halt nicht wesentlich was geändert. Und Paypal war ja ursprünglich angetreten, um das Ganze zu revolutionieren und billiger zu machen. Was sie tatsächlich gemacht haben, ist, dass sie halt da eben genauso reingewachsen sind und genauso abzocken wie alle anderen. Und es sind wirklich auch jetzt nicht nur Abzocke, sondern es ist tatsächlich, also das organisierte Verbrechen mischt da einfach tatsächlich wirklich mit. Und ich meine, es gibt ja auch viele, viele Geschichten historisch aus diesem ganzen Kreditkarten-Business, aber das ist so ziemlich das widerlichste Business, was mir in den letzten 30 Jahren über den Weg gelaufen ist. Vielleicht zum Payment. Mal sehen, ob Apple Pay jetzt auch Apple korrumpiert.
Ich finde ja, ihre technische Lösung ist wirklich ziemlich elegant, also das macht einfach von vorne bis hinten Sinn.
Paypal ist auch mal mit einer eleganten Lösung angetreten.
Das heißt gar nix.
Ich bin durch, packen wir's.
Genau, wir reden jetzt nicht mehr über Bluetooth-Kopfhörer, das hatte ich mir ja eigentlich noch aufgeschrieben.
Das kann warten bis nächstes Mal, wenn es dann überhaupt noch interessant ist.
Wenn es dann überhaupt noch ein nächstes Mal gibt. Insofern, bis zum nächsten Mal ist dann die Wahl in den USA durch. Dann werden wir ja sehen, ob wir dann schon den Ausbruch des nächsten Atomkriegs bejubeln können.
Und wir haben aber was anderes zur Abwechslung.
Genau. Insofern wünschen wir euch schöne Träume.
Genau, Träume schön von TouchBahn.
Danke Pavel, dass du da warst.
Ja, schön, dass ich da sein durfte.
Und tschüss und bis bald.